THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS
WILL NOT COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYBODY AS WE
CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ON THE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN REYES.
THE SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME
THE PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED
ACCESS TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCE BURKE DISSIPATION
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION NUMBER IS.
1-877-226-8160 THREE AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THIRTY THREE. I WILL
MAINTAIN THE DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY ROUTE BE REMOVED. OR HAVE
THEIR SERVICE CONNECTIONS MUTED
WE ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
LAST CALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO BE PRESENT. IN THE-
COMMITTEE ROOM HERE TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
REQUIREMENT BEGIN OUR HEARING.
WE HAVE THIRTEEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA ONE ITEM THIRTEEN
SB FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO HAS BEEN
MOVED TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
BEFORE WE HEAR THE PRESENTATION
ON THE BILLS- WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE RIGHT
INTO- OF PRESENT A PRESENTATION
OF BILLS- WORKING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. OF THE COMMITTEE.
IN ORDER TO HEAR TESTIMONY ON
THE BILLS SO WE WILL BEGIN BY AT
LEAST. TRYING TO ESTABLISH. BY
BY- TAKING THE ROLE OF CLEAR
COULD YOU CALL THE ROLL OF.
WESSEL PRESENT WAS A PRESENCE
DOLLY. DAHLE THE PRESENCE BAKER
. FOR JUST. BRADFORD DOT. EGGMAN
GONZALEZ. GROW HERTZBERG MCGUIRE
. MAN RUBIO STERN OKAY WE'LL
HEAR FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR FROM
SENDER LAYERED ON ITEM NUMBER
ONE S. B. TEN TWENTY WELCOME
SENATOR BEGIN. WHEN YOU'RE READY
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND- AND
MEMBER- I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE- FOR THEIR WORK AND
COMMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS ON THIS
BILL AND COMMIT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM ON THE ISSUES
THAT ARE PENDING APPROVAL TODAY
. R. S. B. TEN TWENTY ANACS THE
CLEAN ENERGY JOBS AND AFFORDABLE
AFFORDABILITY ACTIVE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THIS IS A BIG BILL
AND I AM GOING TO TAKE TIME TO
DESCRIBE. ITS JOINT WE AUTHORED
BY THE SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM
SENATORS CABALLERO AND ARE ALSO
AND MYSELF TO GIVE GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY TO CALIFORNIA'S
ELECTRIC. CLIMATE COMMITMENTS
AND FOR THE FIRST TIME TO PLACE
RATE PAYER AFFORDABILITY ARE AT
THE CORE OF OUR ENERGY POLICY.
S. B. AT TEN TWENTY CONTAINS
SEVERAL KEY ELEMENTS TO
ACCOMPLISH THESE OBJECTIVES.
FIRST THE BILL WOULD ADD INTERIM
TARGETS TO THE POLICY FRAMEWORK
OR- QUESTION. R. BY SENATOR DAY
WE OWN IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN UNDER
SB ONE HUNDRED THE STATE'S
COMMITTED TO ACHIEVE A 60%
RENEWABLE ENERGY PORTFOLIO BY
TWENTY THIRTY TO CREATE NEW AND
STATE JOBS AND TO REQUIRE THAT A
100% OF RETAIL ELECTRICITY SALES
SUPPLIED BY ZERO CARBON
RESOURCES BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
S. B. TEN TWENTY ADS TRUMP
TARGETS TO REQUIRE RENEWABLE
ENERGY AND ZERO CARBON RESOURCES
TO SUPPLY 90% OF ALL RETAIL
ELECTRICITY SALES BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE AND 95% OF ALL
RETAIL ELECTRICITY SALES BY.
FORTY ME JUST MAKE ONE COMMENT
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN
AT LEAST ONE LETTER THAT SAYS
THIS ACCELERATES GOALS. THIS
DOES NOT CHANGE THE EXISTING
GOALS THIS JUST SETS IN TERM
GOALS TO MARK HOW WE ARE GOING
TO STEP UP TO THEM SO THERE'S NO
ACCELERATION. OF BUT IT IS
INTRAMURAL AND THEY'RE
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTEGRATED
RESOURCES PLANNING GOALS
RECENTLY ADOPTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND THE RESULTS OF SB
ONE HUNDRED MODELING PERFORMED
BY THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ENERGY COMMISSION AND
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
THE INCLUSION OF INTRUM TARGETS
WILL ENSURE THAT THE STATE MAKE
STUDY AND ACCOUNTABLE PROGRESS
TOWARD FULL DECARBONISATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S ELECTRICITY GRID.
SECOND THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE
ALL STATE AGENCIES TO RELY ON A
100% RENEWABLE ENERGY AND ZERO
CARBON RESOURCES. TO SERVE THEIR
OWN FACILITIES BY TWENTY THIRTY
. THIS TARGET WOULD PUT STATE
AGENCIES AT THE FOREFRONT OF
EFFORTS O DECARBONIZE THE GRID
AND DEMONSTRATE LEADERSHIP BY
EXAMPLE. IT ALIGNS WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S RECENT
EXECUTIVE ORDER REQUIRING
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES- TO
OBTAIN A 100% CARBON FREE
ELECTRICITY SUPPLY NO LATER THAN
TWENTY THIRTY AT A MINIMUM
CALIFORNIA STATE AGENCIES SHOULD
MATCH ANY COMMITMENTS MADE BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WOULD NOW
TO. IT ALSO ALIGNS WITH
COMMITMENTS MADE BY CALIFORNIA'S
TWO LARGEST A PUBLIC UTILITIES
ARE SMUD AND THE LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND POWER SO
UNDER S. B. TEN TWENTY STATE. BE
ENCOURAGED INSTALL URBAN
RESOURCES ON LEISTER ON
BUILDINGS AND TO WORK WITH THEIR
LOAD SERVING ENTITIES SECURE
CLEAN RESOURCES DEVELOPED TO
MEET THEIR NEEDS. THIRD THE BILL
WOULD ESTABLISH A CLIMATE AND
EQUITY TRUST FUND TO ADDRESS
RISING ELECTRICITY RATES THAT
THREATEN THE AFFORDABILITY OF
BASIC SERVICE AND OUR MIND THE
ECONOMICS OF BENEFICIAL BILL
TRANSPORTATION BACK FOR CASH. TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN
ENERGY AND DECARBONISATION
COMMITMENTS ARE NOT AT CROSS
PURPOSES WITH AFFORDABILITY SB
TEN TWENTY WOULD ESTABLISH A NEW
STRUCTURE FOR CHANNELING FUNDING
FROM EXTERNAL SOURCES. OFFSET A
VARIETY OF COSTS CURRENTLY
COLLECTED IN UTILITY RATES. OCHI
CONSIST WITH THE JOINT
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES I MENTIONED THE ENERGY
COMMISSION PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THEIR RESOURCES BOARD
AN INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR.
CONTAINED IN A SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE REPORT TO THE
GOVERNOR. IT ALSO TRACKS WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS PRESENTED BY A
WIDE ARRAY OF STAKEHOLDERS AT
THE PUC'S RECENT AFFORDABILITY
ON BALK. THE TRUST WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
AFFORDABLE DECARBONISATION
AUTHORITY A NEW NONPROFIT PUBLIC
BENEFIT CORPORATION WITH
DISBURSEMENTS REGULATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION FOR
PUBLICLY OWNED. UTILITY SERVICE
TERRITORIES AND THE OF PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION FOR THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY SERVICE
TERRITORY. THE CREATE TRUST
WOULD DEMONSTRATE A LONG TERM
COMMITMENT TO LOWER ELECTRICITY
RATES ESPECIALLY FOR MIDDLE AND
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS WHO
STRUGGLE TO PAY THEIR MONTHLY
BILLS ONCE THE TRUST IS
ESTABLISHED IT SHOULD BE ENDOWED
WITH LONG TERM FUNDING
COMMITMENTS FROM A VARIETY OF
SOURCES. AND THE LAST THE BILL
WOULD ENCOURAGE BETTER
INFORMATION SHARING AND
COORDINATION ON TRANSMISSION
PLANNING TO AUTHORIZE THE PC AND
THE ENERGY COMMISSION TO
DISCLOSE CERTAIN CONFIDENTIAL
AND USUALLY MARKET INFORMATION
TO THE INDEPENDENT SYSTEM
OPERATOR. IN ORDER TO SPEED UP
AND STREAM CITING AND
CONSTRUCTION OF TRANSMISSION.
THE PER WAS. AN S. ONE HUNDRED
JOINT AGENCY RECOMMENDATION.
TAKEN AS A WHOLE- OF THIS BILL
IS INTENDED TO BRING NEW TERM
RIGOR TO CALIFORNIA'S LANDMARK
ELECTRICITY SECTOR CLEAN ENERGY
AND ZERO CARBON TARGETS TO FOCUS
ON THE AFFORDABILITY OF MEETING
TARGETS AND TO MAKE OTHER
CHANGES TO LAW NEEDED. STATE
SCHOOLS BOB IT IS SUPPORTED BY
THE ENVIRONMENT BY ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA TURNED THE CLEAN
POWER CAMPAIGN THE CENTER FOR
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND RENEWABLE
TECHNOLOGY AND NUMEROUS OTHER
GROUPS HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
IS DAN JACOBSON FROM ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA AND MATTHEW FRIEDMAN
FROM TURN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU AND WILL-
ALLOW- NINETY SECONDS FOR EACH-
SPEAKER BEGINNING WITH DAN
JACOBSON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DAN
JACOBSON A SENIOR ADVISER TO
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORTERS OF THE S. B.
TURNED TWENTY AND WANT TO THANK
OUR THE AUTHOR AND ALL THE OTHER
AUTHORS WHO HAVE JOINED ON IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. FIRST AND
FOREMOST CLEAN ENERGY IS HERE
AND IT LOOKS WHEN SENATOR SURE
PASSED THE FIRST SB TEN SEVENTY
EIGHT IN TWO THOUSAND ONE
CALIFORNIA WAS GENERATING LESS
THAN 3% OF ITS ELECTRICITY FROM
CLEAN ENERGY SOURCES. NOW THANKS
TO THE HARD WORK THE STATE
LEGISLATURE IN OTHERS THE STATE
IS ON A PATH TO A 100% CLEAN
ENERGY IT WAS WIDELY REPORTED ON
APRIL THIRD OF THIS MONTH. THE
CALIFORNIA WAS GENERATING NINETY
SIX POINT 7% OF ITS ENERGY FROM
CLEAN ENERGY SOURCES AND IT WAS
ONLY FOR A FOR A FEW BRIEF
MOMENTS BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
SEE HOW MUCH ENERGY AND HOW
MUCH- PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE
ON THIS. I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT AS THE SENATOR HAS
POINTED OUT WE'RE NOT
ACCELERATING THE R. P. S. YEAR
WE'RE JUST SHUDDERING INTERIM
TARGETS AND THE REASON THAT
THESE ARE IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE
IT ADDS CONSISTENCY AND IT MAKES
FOR AN ORGANIZED PROCESS AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THE STEPS IN ORDER
TO GET TO THAT FINAL GOAL OF
GETTING TO HONOR. PERCENT YOU
WOULDN'T ALL OF YOUR RETIREMENT
MONEY FOR THE LAST YEAR OF YOUR
WORK TO TRY TO SAY LET'S GET IT
ALL IN THERE YOU HAVE THE SAME
KIND OF BENCHMARKS AND THE SAN.
AND FORWARDED THIS BILL. EXACT
I'M KIND OF CLEAR THINKING EXTRA
QUESTIONS TO BE ABLE TO. THIS
REASON AT THIS BILL IS SHOWING.
IS BECAUSE THE STATE AGENCIES TO
SORT OF WALK THE TALK IF
CALIFORNIA'S GONNA LEAD ON THIS
ISSUE. WE NEED THE STATE
AGENCIES TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
SAME THING. AND FINALLY SETTING
UP THIS CONNECTION OF CREATING
AFFORDABILITY AND CLEAN ENERGY
IS CRITICAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR TOP THANK YOU FOR COMMENTS
NOW WILL MOVE- TO. MATTHEW
FRIEDMAN NINETY SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK PLEASE SIR THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MATT
FRIEDMAN I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY
WITH THE UTILITY REFORM. I'M
HERE TODAY TO OFFER. SUPPORT FOR
SENATE BILL TEN TWENTY. WE
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF THE
SENATE CLIMATE WORKING GROUP AND
SENATOR LAYERED. TO DEVELOP A
PACKAGE OF CLEAN ENERGY
DECARBONISATION AND
AFFORDABILITY POLICIES THAT WILL
CEMENT AND EXPAND CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP. THE BILL BRINGS
TOGETHER SEVERAL IMPORTANT
POLICY ELEMENTS INTO A SINGLE
PACKAGE. AND ESTABLISHES THE
PRINCIPLE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT TO CLEAN ENERGY AND A
DECARBONISE. USKO AND IN IT. FOR
THE FIRST TO PROMOTE AFFORDABLE
ALIKE. RATES FOR CAL. CAN SB
TWENTY FEELS IMPORTANT GAPS IN
THE SB ONE HUNDRED ZERO CARBON
POLICY FRAMEWORK BY ADDING
INTERIM BENCHMARKS OF 90% BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. 95% BY
TWENTY FORTY. THE BILL WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE STATE AGENCIES TO
ACHIEVE THE 100% ZERO CARBON
TARGET BY TWENTY THIRTY. ESTATE
AGENCIES ARE ALREADY OBLIGATED
UNDER EXISTING LAW AND THEY
REPRESENT ABOUT 324% OF
STATEWIDE ELECTRICITY USE. I'M
AND AS NOTED BY SENATOR LAYERED
THIS APPROACH IS CONSISTENT WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S OWN COMMITMENT
THAT FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
WILL GET THERE BY TWENTY THIRTY.
FINALLY SB TEN TWENTY ADDRESSES
THE CRITICAL CHALLENGE OF
KEEPING ELECTRICITY RATES
AFFORDABLE IN THE MIDST OF A
CRISIS OF AFFORDABILITY THAT IS
BEING FACED BY CUSTOMERS TODAY.
SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS OF PACIFIC
GAS ELECTRIC AND SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC HAVE SEEN THEIR RATES
GO UP BY FIFTY PERCENT. IT'S
BEEN ABOUT A 30% INCREASE IN
JUST THE LAST TWO YEARS. THESE
HIGH RATES HOW ARE HUGE CRUSHING
BURDEN ON CUSTOMERS THEY ALSO
HAVE ANOTHER CONSEQUENCE THEY
SLOW CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESS ON
BUILDING A TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION THANK YOU. SO
FOR THAT REASON WE SUPPORT THE
CLIMATE EQUITY TRUST CONCEPT AND
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT COME UP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU GO TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC FOR COMMENTS AND
IF YOU COULD PLEASE JUST TAKE A
POSITION. ON THE BILL NAME
POSITION AND AFFILIATION TERM
MEMBERS JOB QUITE A WITH THE
CLEAN POWER PAIN WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. ANYONE ELSE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS READ
ADDIS ON BEHALF OF NATURAL
REPORT RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
ACTION FUND WELL WE TECHNICALLY
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
POLICY GOALS AND HELP YOU GET
OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY. THANK
MISTER MEMBERS CAN CAST WITH
SEPARATE SUPPORT LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON THE
AFFORDABILITY PROVISIONS. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE. NOW WILL GO TO
THE TELEPHONE LINES MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS. IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN TWENTY.
THANK YOU YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO COLLECTORS PRESS YOUR
SUPPORT FOR IT SB TEN TWENTY.
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE THREE THIRTY ONE.
THIS IS YOUR NUMBERS THAT'S
WHERE OF KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT THE
CLIMATE CENTER IN SUPPORT IF
MEDITATION WITH A PART WORK IN
THE OFFICE THANK YOU. WE HAVE
THREE TWELVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BILL MURPHY
REPRESENTING THREE FIFTY SILICON
VALLEY OTHERS CLIMATE ACTION
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND
THERE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT SILICON VALLEY CHAPTER
IN SUPPORT. LINE. TWO EIGHTY
FIVE. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
HELLO. MY NAME IS DONNA THOMPSON
I LIVE IN CARMEL AND I'M SUPPORT
OF THE BILL- AND TWINS THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE NINE TO EIGHTY
THREE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JUST
A MOMENT HERE ON BEHALF OF TWO
ORGANIZATIONS USE GREEN BUILDING
COUNCIL IN LOS ANGELES AND THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOST COLLECTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
IN HEADLINE THREE THIRTY FIFTH.
PLEASE PROCEED YOU CAN DO IT. I
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY
THREE. HI THIS IS JOHN POTTER
ROAD FOR KIDS AT WORK WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANKS SPEAKER. YEP THREE THIRTY
FIVE. DO WE GO TO THE NEXT BAKER
. THANK YOU ONE THREE THIRTY
EIGHT. HI SEAN MEDINA WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY CHOICE
ASSOCIATION- WE ARE STILL ANIL
ANALYZING THE BILL DON'T HAVE A
POSITION YET- BUT WE ARE VERY
ENCOURAGED BY THE BILL AND
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE SENATE CANNELLA CONCURRED
THANKS. THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER.
AT THREE FORTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
ERIN RODRIGUEZ UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS- IN YOUR
SUPPORT CONCEPT. NEXT BIGGER
THANK THANK YOU KNOW FOR THE
LINES IN Q. OKAY WILL NOW GO TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
AN ORGANIZING UNORGANIZED
PRESENTATION IN OPPOSITION JAMIE
CANCERS WITH THE LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. IS HE ON THE
PHONE. IF SO PLEASE ABOUT MINE.
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JENNY CATHOLIC
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY CALLING AND
COMPRISED. WE ALONG WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES FROM FOOD AND WATER
WATCH THE CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY
AND THE ANIMAL LEGAL DEFENSE
FUND WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT. TO BE
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
HOWEVER YOU MUST FIRST. CLOSE AT
TWENTY UNLESS IT IS AMENDED TO
ADDRESS THE CONTINUED INCLUSION
AND ENTRENCHMENT OF ENERGY
GENERATED FROM GLUTEN DAIRY AND
DAIRY. AS A RENEWABLE ENERGY
RESOURCE AND ZERO CARBON
RESOURCE. YOU CAN EXPECT
INSTRUMENTS WITH THE INCLUSION
OF DIGEST GOT. ELIGIBLE
RENEWABLE ENERGY RESOURCE
SPECIFICALLY AND ITS
CONSIDERATION OF THE CLEAN
ENERGY SOURCE GENERALLY. ARE
CONCERNED AREGROUNDED IN THE
EXPERIENCE OF READING FROM THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. JERRY YOU
WERE LOOK TO CONCENTRATE. ENERGY
PER FROM DERRY. THE PRODUCT OF
THE DUST JERRY IF THEY WANT
VALLEY WHICH CONTAMINATE THE AIR
AND WATER UP LOW INCOME-COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. WHAT WHAT MINORITY
REACHES INTO INTO GROUNDWATER
CONTAMINATING DRINKING WATER
SOURCES FOR GENERATIONS TO COME
I JUST KNEW WERE APPLIED TO
LANDFALLING DIGESTION CONTAINS
THE SAME AMOUNT OF MY TRADE AT
THE NEW YORK CREDAI JOSH. I JUST
. TOLD CONTAMINATION. LARGE
CAPABLE PRODUCER AIR POLLUTION
AND GREEN GAS EMISSIONS. WHILE
GAS PRODUCTION DOES NOT SOLVE
THE PROBLEM OF AIR POLLUTION
FROM GARY'S NOR THE METHANE FROM
ENTERIC COMMISSION. IN ADDITION
COMMUNITIES NEAR CAPE COAST TALK
ABOUT THE TOWEL OPENERS AND
FLIES THAT THE IMPACT QUALITY OF
LIFE IN THEIR HOME. IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS BIOGAS PRODUCTION
DOES NOT SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
INCLUDING THE DOCTOR GOT THAT
RENEWABLE ENERGY RESOURCE AND
ZERO CARBON RESOURCE HAVE PAVE
THE WAY WE WILL CONTINUE TO
POLICIES THAT INCENTIVIZE THE
PRODUCTION OF METHANE IN THE
FORM OF WEAPON IN YOUR- CURRENT
POLICY ENCOURAGES PRODUCTION.
DIED AFTER GOSSIP RESULTING IN
THE CONCENTRATION OF HOUSING THE
NEWER AND FEED RT POLLUTION
BURDEN COMMUNITIES. THROUGHOUT
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY GARY
HERBERT'S ARE CONCENTRATING
AROUND AND IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO PRODUCE
AND DISTRIBUTE DIGESTIVE JOSH
WHICH IS THE OBVIOUS CONSEQUENCE
OF INCLUDING PRODUCTION. OF THIS
DROP. ONE POLICY. WE'RE
REVIEWING THE TRUCK FUND COME OF
BE TEND TO YEAH SOME QUESTIONS
AND SOME CONCERNS BUT WE ARE NOT
TAKING A POSITION ON THAT
PORTION OF THE BILL. THAT WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH THE OFFERS TO
ENSURE THE PURSUIT SB TEN TWENTY
LAUDABLE GOALS. DO NOT DOUBLE
DOWN ON A PROGRAM THAT
INCENTIVIZES FURTHER
CONCENTRATION JERRY HERDS.
ALREADY POLLUTION BURDEN
COMMUNITIES AND MONETIZES
PRODUCTION OF METHANE. TOGETHER
WE CAN ENSURE THAT THE ENERGY WE
RELY ON TO REACH CALIFORNIA
CLEAN ENERGY GOAL. IS IN FACT
CLEAN. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANKS FOR PARK TO
PARTICIPATING. NOW WILL GO TO-
OPPONENTS ON HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION HERE. THAT LIKE TO-
OPPOSING PERSON. GO TO THE PHONE
LINES NOW MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE. OPPONENTS TO SB TEN
TWENTY. THANK YOU TO STATE
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN TWENTY ME
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. MS FOR OPPOSITION THE
TERM TWENTY.
WE HAVE ONE LINE WITH AN
OPERATOR WE JUST A LITTLE. LINE
THREE OH NINE THREE OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
RICHARD MARX AND FOR THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION BUT UNDER THE LAYERS
GONZALEZ DID NOT EXPLAIN SEVENTY
FIVE. THE PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS MANDATE. WE'D LIKE TO
WORK FOR THE PATIENT THAT.
LANGUAGE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ARE SPEAKER. THANK YOU
KNOW FOR THE LINES AND IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY- NOW WILL- COME
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENT. MY
ONLY COMMENTS ARE I SUPPORT
POLICY GOALS OF THIS BILL I'D
BIKE THE DIRECTION IT'S MOVING.
AND IF IT IS. AT ALL THE- YOUR
DECISION I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A AS A CO AUTHOR FEED SO CHOOSE-
DOWN THE LINE IS AS YOU MOVE FOR
WITH THE BILL- DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY IN THE COMMITTEE
ELECTIONS. OKAY WHAT DID YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. I DO ACTUALLY
. MIKE. NEARLY YEAH WE CAN ARGUE
THAT OKAY. SO LOOK THERE'S A LOT
IN THIS BILL AND I. HAVING A
BEER WHEN THEY PASSED SB. WHAT
ONE HUNDRED I THINK IT WAS DALY
OWNS BILL AND SO. TWO QUESTIONS
ONE HOW THE FOR ABILITY PIECES
SOMETHING THAT I AM VERY FOCUSED
ON BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
IF WE CAN'T LEAD IN CALIFORNIA
AND HAVE ENERGY RATES ARE FOR
WHICH WE DON'T HAVE RIGHT NOW WE
DO NOT HAVE FORMAL INVIGORATES
IN AND IT'S- DESTROYING. THOSE
FOLKS WHO ARE ON FIXED INCOMES
OR- HOURLY WAGE EARNERS RIGHT
NOW THAT'S THAT'S THE CASE. AND
SO- WHAT IT WAT'S YOUR VISION
FOR HOW IT'S ACTUALLY GOING TO.
YOU KNOW STABILIZE OUR- OUR
ELECTRICITY ELECTRICITY RATES
THE VISION HAS AND ONLY FOR
RESIDENTS ARE NOT NOT ONLY FOR
RESIDENTIAL BUT FOR COMMERCIAL
BECAUSE COMMERCIALS. WERE WE
CAN'T CMPETE- IN CALIFORNIA IN
NINETEEN CLOSE WITH OTHER STATES
AND WE'RE LOSING A LOT OF THAT
MANUFACTURING IN THOSE TYPES OF
JOBS OUT OF OUR STATE AND THAT
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE. WELL THE OF
THE FOCUS AT THIS POINT IS ON
RESIDENTIAL BUT WE WILL HAVE
CONVERSATIONS OVER TIME THE REAL
ISSUE IS THAT WE'VE PUT A LOT OF
THE EXPENSES OF FORTY CARBONATE
SESSION ON TO THE ELECTRICITY
RATES. AND SO THE IDEA OF THE
TRUST IS THAT WOULD LOWER RATES.
ARE FOR EVERYONE BUT ESPECIALLY
DO AN EXTRA. A PIECE FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE AT LOWER MODERATE
INCOMES AND THE IDEA IS TO EASE
EXACTLY THE CONCERN THAT YOU
RAISED. AND THIS WOULD NEED TO
BE FUNDED IN THE PROJECT BUT IT
REALLY EXPRESSLY SAYS THAT IT
CAN COME FROM ANY OF A NUMBER OF
SOURCES WHETHER IT'S FEDERAL
FUNDS. ARE- THE G. GRF FUNDS TO
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
THE GENERAL FUND OF THAT WE CAN
TRY TO GET THERE WITH ANY
FUNDING SOURCE THAT IS POSSIBLE
TO FUND THE TRUST. AND AN
APPLIED. TRY THEN THAT IF THERE
WERE OTHER THINGS IN TERMS OF
DECARBONISATION IT COULD FIT
WITHIN THE TRUST BUT ARE THE
PRIMARY FOCUS AT THIS POINT IS
ON THE RICH. SO I'M NOT GONNA BE
ABLE TO SPOT I DON'T. NOT A BILL
SUPPORT YOUR BILL I THINK THAT
THE AND REASON BEING IS THAT. WE
DON'T WE BASICALLY. HAVE PASSED
OFF THE WE'VE WE'VE FOR
STABILIZED IF YOU CAN SAFELY SAY
THAT WORD THE RESIDENTIAL RATE
ON THE BACKS OF THE COMMERCIAL
INDUSTRIAL RATE THAT'S REALLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING CALIFORNIA AND
IF YOU'RE TAKING A PART OF MONEY
TO HELP STABILIZE THOSE. LOWER
INCOME FOLKS IT'S STILL A PART
OF ME THAT COMES FROM SOMEWHERE
TO TAX BASE OR IT'S A IT'S A V.
SOMEWHERE ELSE WE'RE WE'RE
PUTTING INTO THE FUNDS SO. I'M
TRYING TO GET MY MIND AROUND HOW
WE ACTUALLY. YOU KNOW WE'RE JUST
TAKEN FROM ONE POT PUT INTO
ANOTHER THEN THAT'S HOW I
ENVISION THIS HAPPENING IS I'M
TRYING TO GET WHAT YOUR GOAL I
MEAN I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO.
RATE LOWER THE RATES AT THE SAME
TIME DOING THE RIGHT THING FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT. I UNDERSTAND
THAT PART OF IT BUT THE DEVIL'S
IN THE DETAILS OF ACTUALLY OUT
THAT. HAPPENS AND WHERE THE
WHERE THE MONEY FLOWS FROM HONG
KONG THAT'S- WHY I WAS TRYING TO
GET MORE CLARIFICATION BUT- YOUR
SPIRIT SOUPS TO FIFTIES.
SPECIFIC SPECIFICALLY SAYING
THAT YOU'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT.
INDUSTRIAL RATES OR COMMERCIAL
RATES. YOU'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT
RESIDENTIAL RATES. SEVEN
ANALYSIS THE QUESTION I'M ASKING
IS ONLY BECAUSE YOU LET YOUR
DRESS AND YOUR CLOSING COMMENTS
IF YOU WILL. THAT'S OKAY UNLESS
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS YES
YOU CAN WE CAN JUST CUT YES SO
WE CAN- WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
TABLE AND I'D LIKE YOU TO MAYBE
ANSWERS QUESTION YOUR CLOSING
COMMENTS SHOULD BE SEARCHES
THANK YOU ARE TWO MAJOR THINGS
AND CLOSE. A. N. THAT IS NOT
REARRANGING THE PIE ON THIS IS
BRINGING NEW RESOURCES TO THE
ELECTRIC RATES TO DEAL WITH IT
AND WE WILL BE HAPPY TO WORK
OVERTIME TO SEE WHERE THAT GOES
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE AS A
PRIORITY WE DEAL WITH WITH
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
ARE STRUGGLING WITH THEIR
ELECTRICITY RATES. AND THEN WE
CAN TAKE A LOOK AT IT AS IT
MOVES ALONG BUT BUT IT IS
BRINGING REVENUE INTO THE HELP
WITH THE RATES TO DOESN'T EXIST
NOW SO IT'S NOT LIKE WE ARE
RANGING FROM ONE PERSON OR ONE
ENTITY A BOOK WILL. OVER THIS IS
. COMMITTEE BUT THAT'S AND
THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING THE COURT
WILL WHERE IS THAT MY- THE
SAYING COMES FOR. WHO WEARS THAT
POT IT'S FROM IT'S EXACTLY WHAT
I DESCRIBED IT IS. GENERAL FUND
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FEDERAL
MONEY ANYWHERE ELSE THAT WE CAN
GATHER IT TO DO WHICH IS SOME
WE'VE NEVER DONE SO THIS IS THIS
WHICH IS WHY I DECIDE. ASIDE
FROM THE- I THINK WHAT WAS IT
THE TWO BILLION THAT WE SET
ASIDE TO HELP WITH THE- OR WAS
IT. SOMEBODY CORRECT ME TWO
BILLION. THAT WAS TO HELP PEOPLE
THAT WERE STRUGGLING WE HIGHWAYS
LITTER UTILITY BILL THAT'S FIRST
TIME STATE TO RETURN THAT. THAT
I KNOW OF. AT EAST IN THE LAST
FIFTY YEARS OR- IF EVER. SO.
IT'S A GOOD THING THAT WERE ABLE
TO HELP A LOT OF STRUGGLING
FAMILIES IT COULD AFFORD BILLS.
BUT IT'S A BAD THING THAT YOU
KNOW WE HAD TO DO BECAUSE OUR
RATES ARE HIGH SO THIS BILL
ATTEMPTS. TO ADDRESS. THE RATES
AND ALSO RAISE MONEY- ON THE
TRUST FUND TO HELP WITH THAT SO.
LAUDABLE GOALS DID YOU WANNA ARE
I HAD A SECOND POINT IN MY CLOSE
IN THE SECOND POINT WHEN YOU
SPEAK TO THE TESTIMONY R. K. AS
- IS AT A HIGH LEVEL BUILD.
DEALS THE GOALS AND ESTABLISHING
A- OF. OUR CLIMATE TRUST DEALING
WITH ELECTRICITY RATES IT AND
DEALING WITH CITING TRANSMISSION
IN AN EASIER WAY. AND THERE WAS
A CONCERN. THAT THE UNDERLYING
POLICY WITHIN SB ONE HUNDRED
SHOULD BE CHANGED AS PART OF
THIS. A TO DEAL WITH DAIRIES AND
IT'S OUR THIS DOES NOT CHANGE
ANYTHING. WHAT QUALIFIES. IN THE
EXISTING Y. AND IF IT IF THERE'S
A DESIRE FOR THAT CHANGE THAT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR ANOTHER BILL
THAT IS NOT APPROPRIATE FOR THIS
BILL. AND THIS BILL DOES ADDRESS
SOME OF THE SAME CONCERNS. THAT
THAT- PART OF THOSE NONPROFITS
REALLY WANT TO DO WHICH IS GET A
CARBON OUT OF THE AIR AT LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS. GETTING
MONEY IN THE POCKETS OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE LOWER MIDDLE INCOME
PEOPLE ON ELECTRICITY RATES. AND
IT'S THAT HIGH LEVEL BUT WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. ITS MAJOR BILL
ARE WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. PHONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- WE- BOB. MOTION WE
HAVE A CORE WE HAVE INSTEAD A
QUORUM SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT BILL. I THOUGHT ITEM NUMBER
TWO S. B. TEN TWENTY SIX BY
CENTER WILL KOWSKI. WELCOME SIR
THIS IS A BILL RELATING TO
RESIDENTIAL ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
AND A DISCLOSURE STATEMENT. AND
MAYBE YOU COULD ADDRESS THE
MISTER CHAIRMAN OUR COLLEAGUES I
WILL BE TAKING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ON- SB TEN TWENTY
SIX- AND THINK THE CONSULTANT
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF ON
THAT THAT DEALS WITH YEAH I- USE
AND THE PRIVACY CONCERN THAT WE
HAVE SO THAT'S THAT'S- OUT. OF
THE BILL. SO WHEN CONSUMERS ARE
SEEKING GET A NEW APARTMENT AND
THEIR- GOING AROUND THEY HAVE
SOME IDEA OF FIXED. GENERAL
BUDGET BUT THEY DON'T REALLY
KNOW ONE THING WHEN TEY FIND
THE APARTMENT IS WHAT THE ENERGY
COSTS IS GOING TO BE BECAUSE IT
SETS. THE THAT'S JUST NOT KNOWN
SO UNDER CURRENT LAW- INTO YOU
MAKE THAT COMMITMENT ON YOUR NEW
APARTMENT- YOU GENERALLY DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH THE BUDGET FOR.
HOW WHAT THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
IS OF THE STRUCTURE WHETHER IT'S
BEEN INSULATED WHETHER- THEY'VE
GOT. SINGLE PANE WINDOWS AND ALL
THE THINGS THAT WERE INCLUDED IN
THE- THE STAFF ANALYSIS I'M BUT-
THE FIND OUT QUICKLY AND BECAUSE
LANDLORDS DON'T PAY THE POWER
BILLS THERE'S NO INCENTIVE FOR
THE LANDLORD TO MAKE THESE
ENERGY AND SAVING EFFICIENCY
UPGRADES WELL THE TED HAS NO.
INCENTIVE TO UPGRADE TO WINDOWS
TO REPLACE AN OLD REFRIGERATOR
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T TAKE THEM
WITH THEM WHEN THEY LEAVE AND
THIS IS WHAT THE STAFF ANALYSIS
TALKS ABOUT THIS SPLIT INCENTIVE
PROBLEM SO THIS TRIES TO DRESS
IT SO. IT EMPOWERS CONSUMERS
WITH THE BASELINE INFORMATION ON
WHAT THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY IS OF
A POTENTIAL RENTAL UNIT THAT
THEY HAVE- THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THE BASIC ENERGY
EFFICIENCY DISCLOSURE FORM BY
THE LANDLORD AT THE TIME OF THIS
IN THE LEAST SIMILAR TO THE
REQUIREMENTS- FOR ALL RUN LEASE
. STATE OF. FOREIGN PAGE IT
EXPLAINS WHY THIS THE OTHER SAYS
YOU GET SINGLE PANE WINDOWS ARE
INSULATED ALL THE BEST THE
FURTHER IT CHARGES THE ENERGY
COMMISSION WITH CREATING A
RATING SYSTEM FOR LABELING OR
SOME SYSTEM BY WHICH CONSUMERS
WOULD KNOW IF THE RENTAL UNIT
MEETS OR EXCEEDS OUR FAILS THE
BASIC TENETS OF MODERN ENERGY
EFFICIENCY. LEAVE THAT WILL HELP
. BETTER TO SEE. OF WHERE THEY
LIVE AND HOPEFULLY ENCOURAGE
LANDLORDS- TO SEEK OUT
CALIFORNIA'S NUMEROUS ENERGY
EFFICIENCY UP GRANTS AND
PROGRAMS. I'M AYE RICHER AYE
VOTE TODAY AS I SAID. ACCEPTING
THAT. COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU AVE- FROM
WHAT I UNDERSTAND. SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT WILL GIVE A MESSAGE.
NINETY SECONDS TO GIVE THEIR
PRESENTATION SUPPORT I
UNDERSTAND THEY'RE ON THE PHONE
LINE SO WE'LL GO WITH GREG- WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA FISH TO SEE
DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL FIRST
IF HE IS ON THE LINE. OPEN UP
THE LINE FOR MISTER WIKLER. YES
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS GREG MCLEAN AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
FISHING SCENE DEMAND MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL I'M HERE IN ORDER SENATE
BILL. TWENTY SIX. SO. GIVE ME A
COUPLE OF THE NINE UTILITY TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING MORE
THAN FIFTY COMPANIES TO DESIGN
IMPLEMENT MAINTAIN AND EVALUATE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY DEMAND
RESPONSE WHEN EMPLOYED THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE TO PLAY AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
WITH AN ESTIMATE BUT THAT NUMBER
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE EMPLOYED
IN THE INDUSTRY THAT WE
REPRESENT SB TEN TWENTY SIX
WOULD CONTINUE CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERS. THE VISION P. BY GIVING
SPECT. RESIDENTIAL HOUSING
BRENNER. USED INFORMATION ON
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND POTENTIAL
ENERGY COSTS AT THE PROPERTY
BEFORE SIGNING A LEASE. THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION TO CREATE AN ENERGY
EFFICIENCY SIX CLOSURE FORM.
REQUIRED TIME OF SIGNING OF THE
LEASE AND ESTABLISHING ENERGY
EFFICIENCY TO FURTHER INFORM
RENTERS AS THEY MAKE HOUSING
CHOICES HIS ACTIONS WILL HELP
MOVE THE RENTAL MARKET SEGMENTS
OR GREATER LEVELS OF ENERGY
EFFICIENCY LOWERING THE BILL'S.
AND FURTHERING THE STATE'S CLEAN
ENERGY GOAL THAT'S A GOOD THING
GIVEN THAT THIS SEGMENT IS A
STARKLY NOT ISSUED AT THE
CONNECT AGAINST ANARCHY
EFFICIENCY POTENTIAL- TEN SB TEN
TWENTY AT TEN TWENTY SIX WILL
HELP OPEN THE RENTAL MARKET TO
GREATER OPPORTUNITIES FOR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY BY INCREASING TENANT.
AT THE END. MISSION AND THIS
WILL GO A LONG WAY TOWARD
REALIZING MUCH OF THIS POTENTIAL
AND THAT'S HELPING IT THE
CALIFORNIA SHE THAT AMBITIOUS
CARBON REDUCTION GOALS. FOR
THESE REASONS I ENCOURAGE YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS WILL GO
NOW TO STEPHAN PABLO SOMEBODY
PASS. WITH THE AMERICAN COUNCIL
FOR AN ENERGY EFFICIENT ECONOMY
GET NINETY SECONDS SIR. YOU'RE
ON THE BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
STEPHENS VERY FIRST LOCAL POLICY
MANAGER WITH A FUTURE COOLEY. AT
TRIPOLI IS A NONPROFIT RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION FOUNDED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT CORPORATIST
CALIFORNIA WE CONDUCT RESEARCH
EDUCATION ADVOCACY ON ENERGY
SAVING TECHNOLOGIES PROGRAMS AND
POLICIES I'M HERE TO CUT THE
FINE FOR THAT YOU CAN TWENTY
SIX. ENERGY CAN BE A MAJOR COST
OF RENTAL UNITS. OUR WE-
ENTERTAINED ON AT 13% MORE THEIR
INCOME HOMEOWNER THE AVERAGE LOW
INCOME OP EIGHT POINT 1% OF
THEIR INCOME ON HOME ENERGY BILL
WE'RE NOW PUTTING UP ANY
UNWANTED REACTIONS VARIOUS
ENERGY LABEL DESIGN THAT WILL BE
PUBLISHED IN. THE RENTER'S. TO
MAKE MEMBER. AND WHAT FACT
INTERVIEWED IN THE DECISION
MAKING WHEN THEY ENTER MY IS FOR
ALL THE- WE ARE PROGRAM THE
INTERVIEW ABLE HELP KIND OF LIKE
JENNIFER MORE FISH APARTMENT
THAT THEY'RE TO MORE IN RENT AND
WILL HELP THEIR BUILD WITH. THE
INFORMATION THAT HE. TWENTY YOU
. THE PHARMACY THE BILL OCCURS
MORE LAND. FROM LAND AND CRUISE
THE RENTAL YOU. IN ORDER
HEALTHCARE TENANTS QUICKLY
THIRTY ENERGY FOR AND THE
PROVIDED BY MOTEL BECAUSE- I'VE
HEARD IN A RESURGENT THE MOST
MOST FACT. WILL PROVIDE CON. AT
THE WE- I WANT. GREAT RATING WE
WRECK THE BILL DO TO CAL ENERGY
COMMISSION LOOK AT THE AND OTHER
OPTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
YOU SURE YOU'RE COMMENTS THANK
YOU FOR TO WILL GO NOW TO HERE
THE AUDIENCE INS OR OF IT WHAT
SIX YOU SEE AND MAKE MIKE WILL
GO FOR SMART.
WE GO TO LINE TWO EIGHTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS TO JEFF
MEMBERS THIS IS DUSTIN MILLER
BOB THE US GREEN BUILDING
COUNCIL IN IDEALLY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THAT WE
KNOW THAT DISCLOSURE. THANK YOU
. MUCH. AND WHAT TO GET THIS ONE
AND ZERO. IN SUPPORT OF THIS
TIME. THERE ARE NO FURTHER ONE
FEELING UP THANK YOU WILL GO TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION PRESENTATION BY
NICK NOT ON THE ASSEMBLY ENERGY
UTILITIES- IF THREE THIS. WE CAN
HEAR YOU HI HELLO AGAIN ALL
RIGHT THERE YOU GO YOU'RE GOOD
THANK YOU NIKOLAY NET AND THIS
WITH ANY OF US IN A LOT QUICKER
AND WE WERE UNLESS AMENDED.
OTHER THEIR- WE APPRECIATE WILL
BE REMOVED OUR POSITION THANK
THAT'S GREAT NEWS- NOW WILL GO
TO- SPEAK ENOUGH HERE IN THE
GALLERY. GOOD MR MANY MEMBERS
ACROSS. ALL FOUR. C. ASIAN WE DO
A PRE YOUR IN. OF THIS LIKE. THE
QUESTION WE HAVE TO INTO. IT'S
REALLY WHAT THE FAIL OR
DISCLOSURE A CALL. ONE THE CAN
IT THE AND- THEY DON'T LIKE BE
TO WEAR. CALIFORNIA'S LET SUPPLY
. MICHAEL I ASKED THE OWNER TO
REPLACE THE WINDOW OR THE
EMPLOYEE ONE OWNER MAY DO SO
IT'S NOT WILL BE GIVEN THE
ENORMOUS COST OF WINDOWS FOR A
FULL- AND IF THE IS IN A RECORD
. OF THE PAST ALL THAT. IS NOT
RIGHT PRO. BUT WE APPRECIATE THE
FACT I THINK THAT YOU'VE
ELIMINATED THE PROVISIONS
REQUIRED ENERGY SUPPLIER BY.
IMATION THEN WE HAVE LEFT WITH
LANDLORDS. OF WHAT DOES IT TELL
THE TENANT THEY WILL NOT KNOW
WHAT THE ENERGY COSTS ARE A TRUE
WE DO APPRECIATE THE PROPOSED AS
JUST A TO ME. CHOIR EACH. KERN
SAID- AND- THE TRUTH BUT THAT
ONCE OUT GOOD ANOTHER. AND IF
YOU COULD YOUR YOUR CUSTOMER TO
MAKE APPEAR IN YOUR NAME OKAY
AND OTHER CALIFORNIA PROCEED IF
WE ADDED UP STILL I. THIS BOOK
OUT OF HIS. EARLY ON AND- THE
BILL AMENDED TODAY WITH YOUR
VERY NINETIES WITH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SIR OKAY
ANYONE ELSE WHERE IT WORK ASKING
FOR UP IN THE NETWORK THE
CALIFORNIA CASES ISSUE REMOVING
OUR OPTION FOR THEM THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND- THANK YOU. SAID
PIECE OF MODERATE PLEASE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO POSE- PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
. THIS BIG DECISION. AND THERE
ARE NO LIGHTS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TEN VERY WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE- CENTER EGGMAN. THANK
YOU HELLO CENTER CASKEY- SO THE
ENERGY COMMISSION WILL PREPARE
AND IS YOUR IS YOUR IDEAL LIKE A
LIKE A CHECKLIST OF EVERYTHING
THAT COULD EITHER TO. DUCTION RG
SHIN WOULDN'T BE LIKE A HOW MUCH
EACH OF YOU EACH UNIT. BILL
STREICHER I DO I DO SEE THAT
THERE UP IT THAT'S- WE HAVE A
COUPLE LAWS THAT THAT ARE OUT.
THERE ONE OF THEM IS SAFETY IN.
ON THE COLOR BASIS- THAT YOU
HAVE WHAT THE EXPECTATION I
THINK I'M- A POINT SYSTEM THAT
COULD BE ANOTHER ONE THAT THEY
COULD THEY COULD COME UP SUS IT
GIVES SOME HOT IN THE T. ALL OF
THE OF THE UNIT. ON ON THE
GREENS CARE AND IN A- WAY THAT.
WOULD HAVE THAT ONE SHEET THAT
WOULD JUST WOULD SAY IT'S CHECK
THE BOX. IT'S BEEN IT'S
INSULATED SINGLE. OKAY IT'S I'M
- PETER WHATEVER WHATEVER THIS
IS JUST THE DATA FOR THE
CONSUMER THAT IT HAS OR DOESN'T
HAVE RIGHT OKAY THANK YOU. OKAY
ANYONE ELSE. OKAY DID YOU WANT
TO MAKE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS I
WOULD JUST URGE AN AYE VOTE ONCE
YOU ESTABLISH A QUORUM OKAY
YOU'RE VERY MUCH WELCOME REMOVAL
OUR NEXT. ALL IT YOUR NEXT OVER
. OKAY SO WELL SHE DOES THAT ON
MOTHER'S RELIGIOUS PRESENT. MY
BILL OF RIGHTS. OR DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY HERE IN THE COMMUNITIES
IN THE SUIT THAT HAS LITTLE NO.
YOU WANT TO SHARE YOUR TEACHER
GET YOUR- THE- SECOND HIT
YOURSELF OVER THE HEAD WITH THAT
. YOUR THIS MONEY. WHY DON'T
HAVE TO MOVE. OKAY SENATOR HUESO
ON WHICH WE'RE DOING START HERE
WE HAVE S. B. TWELVE OH EIGHT.
FOR. FROM EXPECTATIONS. MEDIA NO
. BOB CURTIS NUMBER. THANK YOU
MR MEMBERS OF SB TWELVE AWAIT IS
AN EFFORT TO HELP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS RESIDENTS
BY SUPPORTING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
. APPLICATION ASSIST LOW INCOME
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS OVERSEEN BY
THE CPUC. I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AND- MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE BILL WITH
AMENDMENTS ARE TODAY THE CPUC
REGULATED UTILITIES AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS ADMITTED ADMINISTER
SEVERAL LOW INCOME ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS THESE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS ARE
AFFORDED ACCESS DENTAL SERVICES
INCLUDING ELECTRIC WATER GAS-
COMMITTEE ACTION. WELL THERE ARE
. GROWING THERE ARE SEVERAL
CROAK PRO AND GROW UP. I'M COST
SUPPORT TO MOVE OVER- ONE TIME.
EFFORTS CHEN. WHEN ADMINISTERED
ONE PROGRAM AT A TIME OR ONE
UTILITY CONTACT AT A TIME SB
TWELVE AWAIT WOULD HELP
STREAMLINE THE APPLICATION
PROCESS FOR A UNIVERSAL
APPLICATION BY ALLOWING ELIGIBLE
CUSTOMERS TO VERIFY ELIGIBILITY
FOR MULTIPLE PROGRAMS AT ONCE
SPECIFIC. THE BILL BRECK THE
CPUC TO MAXIMIZE DATA SHARING
FOR CONSENTING CUSTOMERS DURING
THE APPLICATION PROCESS
UTILIZING A THIRD PARTY VERIFIER
WITH OVER FOR ME AND RESIDENTS
LIVING BEFORE BELOW. HER PERCENT
OF POVERTY LINE STREAMLINED
UNIVERSAL APPLICATION PROCESS
WILL ENSURE THAT WILL RESIDENTS
. ACCESS TO THE PROGRAMS. THIS
AIMS PAPE A WITH THE FOR- SOME
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT WILL HELP
THE MOST DISADVANTAGED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND ALLOW THEM TO
FOCUS. TIME ON MORE FOR EFFORT.
OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE CRITICAL
TO SUPPORTING ACCESS TO
ESSENTIAL SERVICES FOR LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS WE HAVE
TESTIMONY FROM JUSTIN'S GARB
WITH THE CALIFORNIA WATER
SERVICE LEE LEE S. C. A. WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ASSOCIATION
AND OF COURSE SAID. A DEAL HAD
NONE. OKAY MAYBE HERE THE FIRST
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. YOU MIGHT
NOT OR A MEMBER. I DON'T HAVE
THEIR NAMES- WHAT WEREN'T YOU
START WITH THE- WITH A JOB
INSCRIBE CAN WE HAVE JUSTICE
SCARPA PLEASE. YES I'M HERE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND COMMITTEE MY NAME'S JUSTIN
SCARRED- I'M THE CHAIR OF THE
PUBLIC POLICY COMMITTEE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION
WHAT. THIS GREATLY BY THE TPC-
WE'RE STRONG PROPONENTS OF THE
BILL HASN'T PROVIDED MANY
BENEFITS TO ALL CUSTOMERS CLEAN
BUT YOU QUALIFY. FOR REPAIR
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THAT ARE
OFFERED BY THE- UC REGULATED
UTILITIES. AND I'M SURE YOU CAN
APPRECIATE UTILITY SIMPLY AREN'T
SOCIAL SERVICE AGENCIESAND ARE
REALLY SET UP TO GO THROUGH THE
RECORDS VERIFICATION PROPHECIES
WHAT CUSTOMERS FIVE. IT'S THE
END HAVING ONE APPLICATION PER-
THE FOR TO PROBE- THAT ARE
THROUGH BILL- TWELVE THE LAKE
WILL PROFICIENCY AND ALLOW
UTILITIES TO FOCUS ON THE COURT
AFTER PROVIDING SAFE RELIABLE
PORTABLE BECAUSE MORE. SENATE
BILL TWELVE THERE IS AN ENROLLED
IN OTHER PROGRAMS FOR WHICH
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE SAME TIME THIS
MAXIMIZE THE BENEFIT THE
CUSTOMERS RECEIVED WILL DO MUCHTO HELP ENSURE THE UTILITY
SERVICE REMAINS AFFORDABLE FOR
TO CONTINUE COMING. AND YOUR
TODAY AND FOR THOSE THAT ARE NOT
INTENDED AND AS WELL THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THIS TAKE UP OUR SECOND TO THE
NEEDS OF WHICH IS YEAH ALLIES
GARCIA. MODERATOR. YOUR CA MAY
WANT TO CHECK YOUR MUTE BUTTON.
ONCE AGAIN MISTER CSU LINE IS
CONNECTED AND WE HAVE AN OPEN
YOU MAY WANT TO CHECK IF YOU BUT
- OKAY WE WILL TAKE UP BUT-
ANYONE IN HERE IN THE ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON. S.
FOLLOW A IN. SEEING NONE CAN WE
GO BACK TO THE PHONE LINES NOW
FOR WHAT HERE WE GO. COMMITTEE
CHAIR JOSE NINE THIS I SERVED ON
THE LOW INCOMES OVERSIGHT BOARD
FOR ABOUT TWELVE YEARS WITH THE
PROVIDING TECHNICAL SUPPORT TO
SET UP. ELLIOTT'S LOCUSTS
SUPPOSED TO BE ON THE PHONE ARE
THEY ARE AT STAKE WHITE OR
STATION OVER THREE HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS. BILL SIMPLE AND
OF USING MODERN DAY TECHNOLOGY
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE MAXIMIZING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
ENROLL IN ELIGIBLE PROGRAMS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH BOTH
UTILITIES AND- COMMUTE STATIONS
JOHNSON THING. ALLOW THE
CONCERNS THIS IS NOT A UNIVERSAL
APPLICATION THE VERY DIFFICULT.
GET THAT UNIVERSAL APPLICATION
THIS IS ABOUT STREAMLINING THE
APPLICATION PROCESS I MEAN WHO
REALLY. THE EXISTING. TO US
STREET THANK. RUNNING AND MAX
THE PRO REDUCE ADMINISTERS COSTS
AND REALLY ASSIST INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE IN NEED THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE ROOM
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY OR NOT
WILL GO TO THE MODERATOR THOSE
ON THE LINE THAT WISH TO SUPPORT
SB TWELVE OH EIGHT. MODERATOR
PLEASE KEEP. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
IF YOU WISH TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THIS TIME. COPS WHAT CAN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO IN SUPPORT.
AND THERE ARE NO LIGHTS COMING
UP AT THIS TIME OKAY- HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION SO MODERATOR WAS
ANYBODY HERE IN THE ROOM HE
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION OF SB
TWELVE AWAIT. SEE NON MODERATE
WOULD YOU QUEUE UP IN OPPOSITION
FOR SB TWELVE TWELVE AWAIT. AND
IF THERE IS ANY OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF THERE'S
ANY OPPOSITION PLUS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN THERE ARE NO LIGHTS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME. OKAY WE
WILL NOW BRING IT BACK TO THE
SENATORS ARE THIRTY CENTERS
WHICH TO- YES. DO NOT WORK WITH
CORMIER. SO WE WHAT WE WILL MOVE
THE BILL ONCE WE GET A QUORUM.
ARE YOU A TAKE OF MANSON. MMHM.
AFTER HAVE A. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ILL GO TO THE NEXT SPEAKER
NOW- SENATORS SKINNER AND SB TEN
SIXTY THREE.
THANKS SO MUCH. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS- AS I THINK WE'RE ALL
AWARE CALIFORNIA'S MECCA FOR
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION
INCLUDING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
STATE OF THE ART EFFICIENT AND
GREEN APPLIANCE TECHNOLOGY CAN
HELP ALL OF US USE DO YOU SLICE
. FOR AND THIS. XIN CAN POINTS
THERE ASSISTED A LONG WAITING
PERIOD BEFORE NEW STANDARDS CAN
BE ADOPTED FOR THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL SB TEN SIXTY THREE IS
TO HELP OUT. AT THIS NEW
POLICIES. ELEVEN THERE ARE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION WHO
SETS ARE POINT STANDARDS TO SET
A STANDARD MORE QUICKLY ONCE
THEY FIND A GOOD CAUSE KING THAT
THE EX. OF A TECH. IT'S
SUBSTANTIATES WHITES WARRANTED
I'M SO BASICALLY THE ENERGY
COMMISSION WOULD HAVE TO MAKE A
GOOD FINDING BECAUSE THAT THE-
STANDARD SHOULD BE EFFECTIVE
SOONER THAN A ONE YEAR- DATE
THIS LOT AS THEY- ASKED. BY THE
SURE IN THE COMMISSION. THINK
ABOUT THE DRUG THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCE THE PRESSURES ON OUR
GRID INCEPTION IF WE HAVE NEW
APPOINT NEW TECHNOLOGY THAT ARE
CAN BE INCORPORATED INTO A POINT
THAT WOULD HELP PRESS THAT.
ISN'T A BEST WITHOUT WOULD LIKE
MAKE YOU WITNESS. WHO IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA'S EFFICIENCY AND
DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL MR
RIGLER BUSY TODAY. BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GREG
MCLAREN AND EXPECT DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA FISH MAN
MANAGEMENT CAN WHEN I. AND BILL
. THREE HOW ARE YOU STANDARD
PROCESS REQUIRES STRICT WAITING
PERIODS NEW TECHNOLOGY STANDARDS
ARE ADOPTED SB TEN FIFTY THREE
WILL HELP CALIFORNIANS ACCESS
YOU IN TECHNOLOGY FASTER BY LAW
NEW CLIENT ENTERED TO BE APPLIED
SOONER IF THE COMMISSION. THIS.
MEETING HI MICHAEL READ WHAT
RELIABILITY CONCERNS AND MANDATE
. WE BELIEVE THERE ARE
SUFFICIENT SAFEGUARDS IN THE
BILL TO ALLAY MANUFACTURE
CONCERNS THAT THE SHORTER TIME
FRAMES WILL LIMIT CUSTOMER
CHOICE. THIS BILL HELPS. TIME
DURING WHICH YOU. HE MADE
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC AND
THAT'S HELP CALIFORNIANS
HOMEOWNERS AND BUSINESSES USE
LESS ENERGY AND WATER AND
MEANINGFULLY CONTRIBUTE TO OUR-
I AM IN. BUT THEN IT STAFF THERE
FOCUSED ON OVERCOMING CRITICAL
BARRIERS TO NEW TECHNOLOGY
ADOPTION ACTUALIZING IT'S A LOT
GOALS FOR THESE REASONS I
ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE. THANK YOU
TIME AND THE NEED TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN SIXTY THREE
THANK YOU KNOW WE'LL GO TO
SPEAK. PORT BIT. IN THE- THIRTY
ONE JUST A HELP YOURSELF TO THE
MIKE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS DAN JACOBSON
SENIOR ADVISER FOR ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. VERY WELL-
ANYONE ELSE- WILL GO TO SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT. ON THE- ON THE LINE-
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF TEN SIXTY THREE.
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY THE PRO. THE FIRST.
ONE THREE SEVENTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE PHILADELPHIA CLAIMS CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY STORAGE ALLIANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. BAKER. THANK YOU KNOW FOR THEIR LINE
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT OKAY WE'LL
GO TO SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION NO
LEAD OPPOSITE PRESENTATION WILL
GO TO SPEAK BY ARE YOU.
OPPOSITION ORANGE SESSION OKAY
MISTER MISTER CHAIRMAN BURSTEIN
KHAKI MCCUE KEPT CAN ASSOCIATES
ON BEHALF AIR CONDITIONING
HEATING REFRIGERATION INSTITUTE
HI WE ARE RISK POSEDA CEMENT
THAT SAD I WE REALLY APPRECIATED
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK SENATOR
STOP AS WELL ENERGY. ONE BEHIND
THE BILL. WE APPRECIATE OUR JUST
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THEM ON SOME ADDITIONAL
REFINEMENTS TO THE GOOD BECAUSE
LANGUAGE I AM HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL
GET TO A POSITION OF BEING ABLE
TO REMOVE POSITION THANK YOU
SENATOR. I MY- THANK YOU MUCH
ANYONE ELSE. ANY OTHER SPEAK.
THIS RESUME HAVE THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP IN
SUPPORT. WE'RE GOING THIS. OCEAN
OF. MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE Q.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF THE
LINES. THANK YOU THEY OPPOSITION
TO THE SP TEN SIXTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN THERE
ARE TIMES. WE DO HAVE A LINE IN
Q. ONE MOMENT.
OUR FIRST COMMENT FROM SOME LINE
THREE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF JACOB
KATHLEEN I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
THE ASSOCIATION ALMOST FIVE
MANUFACTURERS WE ARE OPPOSED TO
SB TEN SIXTY THREE- THERE'S NO
GOOD. FOR THIS. TO GO FROM ONE
YEAR TO- AN EMERGENCY THAT HAS
FAILED TO FIND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING MORE ON THIS AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER SPEAKERS. THERE
ARE NO OTHER SPEAKERS IN Q. OKAY
WILL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
NOW FOR MEMBERS OF ANY COMMENTS
SENATOR DODD YEP- THE CENTER
SKINNER CAN CAN YOU CAN HELP ME
OUT WITH WHAT A GOOD BECAUSE
FINE COULD BE. AS A COULD FIND
IT. YOUR COULD BE DRY KIND OF
SIFT THIS OUT YES- I'VE BEEN
TRYING TO COME UP WITH THE- SO.
LET'S SAY THERE WAS A NEW
ADVANCEMENT IN OUR MANY YEARS
REFRIGERATION NOT BECAUSE- I
THINK THAT IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
HERE. BUT IF WE TAKE JUST THE
CHANGE. IN APPOINT STANDARDS FOR
TRADERS WHICH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION PUT IN THE SEVENTIES
THAT ALONE. DROPPED KEPT AND WE
WHEN WE LOOK AT ALL THESE
WONDERFUL THINGS CALIFORNIA'S
DONE ALL THIS LEADERSHIP WHETHER
IT'S IN RENEWABLE ENERGY- THERE
SO THAT THE FACT THAT WE STILL
USE PER CAPITA LESS ELECTRICITY.
THAN WE DID IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO IS BECAUSE FARPOINT
STANDARDS SIMPLY NOW AS WE
ADVANCED AND WE TRIED TO GET
100% RENEWABLE ENERGY AND WE
ELECTRIFIED VEHICLES AS WE'RE
ALL TALKING ABOUT THEIR SUPER
MORE BAND ON THE HEAD AND- I'M-
TEND TO BE LESS. WE WANT TO GO.
RELY SO WE GOTTA HAVE NICK WALKS
WE AGREED WE HAVE TO REDUCE OUR
USE BUT WHY SHOULD WE BE GOING
AROUND TELLING PEOPLE JUST
UNPLUG YOUR STUFF NO. IF THERE
IF THERE ISN'T B. SPENT IN A
PARTICULAR POINT THAT BRINGS ITS
ELECTRICITY DRAWDOWN 25% JUST
LIKE THAT AND WE'VE SEEN THAT
NOW. MANY OF OUR OUR CELL PHONE
CHARGERS NOW ARE HAVE CUT THEIR
USAGE OR LAPTOPS. WE HAVE THAT
IF WE CAN MOVE IT AND GET IT ON
THE MARKET FAST. THEN IT HELPS.
AND RELIABILITY. WITH ALL OUR
SCHOOLS NO I COULD WATERIS A
BETTER EXAMPLE BUT I DON'T HAVE
THE QUITE THE SAME ANALOGY. BUT
YOU KNOW WE'RE HORRIBLE DROUGHT
RIGHT NOW AND WE'RE ASKING
RESIDENTS TO GO BACK TO REDUCE
25% SAY. NOT TO YOU KNOW GET IS
IT JUST TURN OFF FOR YOUR WATER
OR WHAT IF. ALL OF OUR DIFFERENT
DEVICES JUST USED 25% LESS WATER
BUT WERE JUST AS EFFECTIVE. THEN
IT WOULDN'T JUST BE ON OUR
MEMORY TO TURN THIS OR THAT OFF
RIGHT. SO THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT
OF A BILL LIKE THIS IS IF AND
WE'VE SEEN. ADVANCEMENTS COME
VERY FAST AND IF THEY DO AND
THEY CAN HELP US ADDRESS A
CRITICAL PROBLEM OTHERS ARE
DROPPED. THE GRID RELIABILITY
YOU NAME IT AND WE WANT TO USE.
I REQUEST THEN. WHEN COMPANY
COMES OUT WITH THE- ADVANCE WELL
LET'S SAY IT SAVES 45% OF THE
ENERGY RIGHT. I MEAN. I GUESS I
GUESS THE ONE QUESTION I WOULD
HAVE IF YOU STARTED THE STATE-
YEAH IF THE CC WHAT THROUGH THAT
PROCESS RIGHT IT SAID HEY WE
NEED TO DO THIS AND YOU ONLY
HAVE ONE MANUFACTURER IF YOU
READ OTHER MANUFACTURERS THAT-
WERE CUT OUT OUT OF THE MARKET
MAYBE THAT'S HEY YOU KNOW YOU
SNOOZE YOU LOSE. BUT I'M
INTERESTED YOUR THOUGHTS ARE
WELL USUALLY IT'S NOT. ON
USUALLY IT'S A REFINEMENT IN SAY. I'VE BEEN GOING TO STRUGGLE
HERE IT'S THREE IT'S A
REFINEMENT IN. THE PART OF THE-
IT'S NOT SO MUCH THAT THE SINGLE
COMPANY WHO MANUFACTURES SAY
THE- BIG SCREEN TV OR THE
REFRIGERATOR COMES UP WITH IT
IT'S THAT THE INNOVATORS IN
WHATEVER THAT TECHNOLOGY IS
BATTERY TECHNOLOGY STATE OR
CHARGING TECHNOLOGY THEY COME UP
WITH THE INNOVATION AND THEN IT
SUPPLIED TO STAND TO IT'S THE
STANDARD THEN APPLIED. SO
BECOMES PLAYING FIELD FOR ALL OF
THE COMPANY. THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYTHING
ELSE. OKAY I JUST WANTED A
COMMENT I THINK THIS BILL UP I
THINK THERE A LOT OF BILLS LIKE
THIS THAT- ON'T POTENTIALLY SEND
MARKET SIGNALS SEVERAL COURAGE
PEOPLE TO INNOVATE. IF THEY
REALLY KNOW THEIR THEIR PRODUCTS
WILL WILL GET TO. A BETTER
POSITION WITH CONSUMERS AND I
THINK THIS IS A WONDERFUL BILL.
I THINK IT'LL REALLY HELP IN
THAT REGARD AND BENEFITS BUT NO
NO HARM DONE RIGHT SO- BUT I.
DEFINITELY HAVE POTS. POSITIVE
X. MARKET AND- HELP US GET TO
WHERE WE'RE HEADED SO- IF
THEY'RE NO FOR THE CALMEST ONE
MAKE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS ON. I
THINK WEAVER WE'VE JUST HAD A
GOOD LOCATION SO I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE THANK YOU AND WE'LL MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR AND I
DEFINITELY WILL TALK CONTINUE TO
TALK TO THE DIFFERENT
MANUFACTURERS AND WHATEVER
CONCERNS THEY- THE RIGHT. THE
COMMISSION YOU KNOW THE THEY
WOULDN'T JUST BE MAKING SURE
FINDING AND JUMPING AHEAD TO THE
POOR PEOPLE CAN'T MEET IT WILL
MOVE ITS ITEM FOR NOW IS B.
TENSOR FONG THE BILL RELATED TO
A GREENHOUSE GEN NOVA- YEAH. WE
STORY. I'VE BEEN SITTING IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE WANTED TO NINE
OF ITS WARNING. YOUR ME PERCENT
OF MY OTHER ONE TEN SEVENTY
FIVE. I'M IMAGINE YOU'VE HEARD
SOME OTHER BILLS ON GREEN
HYDROGEN CERTAINLY YOU HAVE
ANOTHER YEARS FOR ME BUT THE
THAT IT'S ONE IF YOU. NO CARBON
ENERGY SOURCES THAT IS VERY
FLEXIBLE IT CAN BE USED TO
GENERATE ELECTRICITY THOUGH
THAT'S GOING TO BE LESS COMMON
IT CAN BE USED TO STORE
ELECTRICITY CAN BE USED FUEL.
SHIP IF YOUR VEHICLE TO FOR TO
FUEL THE OPERATION SUPPORTS IT'S
A VERY FLEXIBLE FUEL. OUT WE'VE
HAD DIFFERENT. I MEAN YOU KNOW
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER WAS A
HUGE OUT OF HYDROGEN BUT AT THAT
POINT WE'RE PRODUCING MOST FOR
HYDROGEN FROM FOSSIL FUELS DID
NOT REALLY GIVE US MUCH. BETTER
I'M IN PORT. EVEN IN THEIR- IF
YOU WHEN YOU THOUGHT ABOUT. WHAT
ITS INPUT WAS. NOW WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PRODUCE HYDROGEN FROM
. NON FOSSIL SOURCES AND THEN SO
WE'RE ALREADY WE'RE NOT
POLLUTING JUST IN THE PRODUCTION
AND THEN IN THE USE OF IT THE
BRILLIANCE OF IT IS LIKE TO SAY
IT'S IT REPLACING DIESEL IN A
LONG TRUCK. IN GOOD MOVEMENT AND
WE DON'T HAVE PARTICULAR DON'T
HAVE THAT POLLUTION THE DETAILS
BUT WE NEED TO SEND THE RIGHT
MORE SIGNALS TO BRING DOWN THE
PRICE. TO GET THE INNOVATION
THAT WE KNEW SO WHAT THIS BILL
DOES. IS IT OF ISIS OR RATHER IT
VANCE'S GROUP. BY THE NEW MONIES
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
MAKING AVAILABLE WHERE THERE
WHERE IF WE WANT TO APPLY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THESE
HYDROGEN INVESTMENTS AND CREATE
A REGIONAL HYDROGEN HUB WE HAVE
TO PUT SOME MONEY ON THE TABLE
TO SO IT IS STUCK HIS DICK IN
HYDROGEN HUB FUND TO PROVIDE
STATE MATCHING MONEY TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA MORE COMPETITIVE AND
IT DIRECTS STATE AGENCIES TO
ADOPT GREEN HYDROGEN INTO THEIR
- SO. PEOPLE HAD INCURRED A RB
TO DEVELOP A ROAD MAP FOR
HYDROGEN ROLL OUT IN CALIFORNIA
AND THESE ARE THE TYPE OF
SIGNALS THAT WILL HELP US GET
THE TYPE OF RESPONSE FROM
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATORS
RESEARCHING DEVELOPERS YOU NAME
IT AND HELP US BRING THAT PRICE
DOWN AND I'D LIKE TO HAVE MY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT GEN. TWENTY
CONSTRUCTION. THANK YOU SO WILL
GO TO JANICE LYNN NOW YOU HAVE
NINETY SECONDS- IF YOU'RE ON THE
PHONE PLEASE BEGIN YES HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS JENNIFER AND I'M THE
FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF THE
GREEN HYDROGEN COALITION WE'RE A
FIVE OH ONE C. THREES MISSION.
IS TO ACCELERATE GREEN HYDROGEN
AFTER GAYLE IF THE FACILITATE
MULTI SECTORAL DECARBONISATION
AND CLEAN AND JUST ENERGY
TRANSITION- I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBER.
FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN ADDRESSING
OUR CLIMATE CRISIS. CONSIDERING
THE ROLE OF GREEN HYDROGEN IN
ACHIEVING THE URGENT CALL. IN
ADDITION TO FIGHTING CLIMATE
CHANGE THE WAR IN UKRAINE AND
RESULTING VOLATILITY OF FOSSIL
FUEL COSTS ARE INCREASING
URGENCY EXPLORING SCALABLE
ALTERNATIVE. THREE HIGH AND
INTERMISSION IS A COMMERCIALLY
VIABLE AND SCALABLE TRINITY IF
THE FOSSIL FUELS TODAY
INTERESTING EVEN THE HARDEST TO
ABATE FACTORS SUCH AS HEAVY DUTY
TRANSPORT SHIPPING AND AVIATION.
HOWEVER TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THAT LAUPER'S EMERGING GLOBAL
ECONOMY CALIFORNIA MUST ACT
TODAY. YOU CAN SEVENTY FIVE IS
ESSENTIAL TO ACHIEVING OUR
ECONOMY WIDE TO CARBONIZATION
GOAL.
EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR FEDERAL
CLEAN HYDROGEN HUB RSG AND
SETTING UP CALIFORNIA AT THE
NATIONAL. COMMITTEE A GLOBAL
LEADER IN. ACTUALLY AFTER I
DON'T THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW WILL GO TO MIKE MONEGAN
FROM THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES MONICA.
BONTA GOT OVER HALF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IS ALWAYS A CHALLENGE TO
FOLLOW SENATOR SKINNER- ON
HYDROGEN SINCE THING THAT I WAS
GONNA SAY HAS ALREADY BEEN STAFF
HOWEVER- JUST SO YOU. BUILDING
PARADES SEVEN THREE THOUSAND IN
YOU PROGRAMS WHAT HAPPENS
HOPEFULLY IF WE GET FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR HYDROGEN HUBS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE WE'RE GOING TO
CREATE A LOT MORE JOBS MIDDLE
CLASS WELL PAYING JOBS.
CALIFORNIANS HI THIS IS AN
EXCELLENT BILL HYDROGEN HAS GOT
TO BE THE KEY. TO OUR LONG TERM
STRATEGY TO ACHIEVING OUR
CLIMATE GOALS THANK YOU THANK
YOU DO IT DO WE HAVE ANY
SPEAKERS HERE IN THE- ROOM THAT
LIKE SPEAKING. YEAH YEAH SENATE
HUESO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TIM CARMICHAEL ON BEHALF SAN
DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY IN
SUPPORT BOTH OF OUR UTILITIES
ARE KEEN. TO DO A LOT MORE WITH
HYDROGEN. AS A CLEAN FUEL FOR
HARD TO CUT. HARD TO DECARBONISE
SECTORS OF OUR ECONOMY AS WELL
AS POTENTIALLY WITH ENERGY
STORAGE AND SO WE PRECIADO THE
CENTER'S LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE. TWO ONE ELSE. MANY OTHERS
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS MATT FREEMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
WE APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK WE'VE
DONE ALREADY WITH CENTER
SKINNER'S OFFICE THANK YOU.
SUPPORTERS OF MICHAEL METZ FROM
RE CARBO WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
BILL WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR. ON IT. IT IS
BEING. IN THE DEFINITION OF
CLEAN NITROGEN THANK THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON STEVE WALK ABOUT
THE CENTER FOR TRANSPORTATION
ENVIRONMENT CITY IN SUPPORT OKAY
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. CHRIS
ROSE ON BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP SUPPORT THANK
YOU. WILL GO TO THE MODERATE
PHONE LINES TO BEGIN Q. A
SPEAKER IN SUPPORT. AND SIX
THREE. THANK YOU EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL ME PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE IF
YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY YEAH MONTHS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. FOR THE
FIRST THE LINE THREE EIGHTY TWO
. KAREN MEMBERS LEFT ELEVEN YOUR
COOKING CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE
ALLIANCE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE THREE TWENTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATOR WE FELL AND
MEMBERS ARE THAT ALL OF THAT
WITH THE WISEMAN GROUP CALLING
ON BEHALF OF ALL HIGH DRESS.
ENERGY AND THE TRADITION POWER
AND STRONG SUPPORT THE GAL. WHAT
WOULD A LINE. TO EIGHTY FIVE.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YES. OKAY
MY NAME'S ON THE FARM STAND I
LIVE IN CARMEL CALIFORNIA IT
REALLY LOVE THIS BILL I THINK
IT'S THE ANSWER TO A LOT OF
WATER PROBLEM THANK YOU- THANK
YOU. YOUR COMMENTS THE NEXT
SPEAKER PLEASE. LIME THREE
EIGHTY ONE. HI EMILY PAPPAS ON
BEHALF OF THE M. C. E. MARIN
CLEAN ENERGY AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT PICKER. THREE
FIFTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL DEATH WITH
THE PRAYER IN THE KEIGHLEY ON
BEHALF OF REPUBLIC SERVICES IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT SPEAKER. THREE TWENTY.
STEPHANIE MISTER CHEN MEMBERS
PUMPKIN CMB HALF THE UAW LOCAL
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY FIVE AND
LOCAL FIFTY EIGHT AND BURKE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
. THREE FIFTY FOUR. IT UP AND
THEN MISTER MEMBERS MICHAEL
REGARD ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WHAT.
GREAT THANK YOU- ANYONE ELSE. WE
HAVE THREE ELEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON PAUL WAS WITH
CALIFORNIA DRIVERS ON BEHALF OF
EDF RENEWABLES IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT BIGGER. NO OTHER LINES
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU AND DID
YOU WANT TO MAKE. ADDIS ON
BEHALF OF CAL START IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. OKAY WE DON'T HAVE A
ON OGANIZED PRESENTATION
OPPOSITION DO WE HAVE ANYONE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM. IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN SEVENTY
FIVE. WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
Q. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF TEN
SEVENTY FIVE. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THE SP TEN
SEVENTY FIVE MIN PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. CAME UP
TO ONE AND THEN OF THEIR. THERE
ARE NO LINES INTO AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WOULD
NOT COME TO THE COMMITTEE. AND
JUST- CENTER SKINNER AGAIN
ANOTHER WONDERFUL BILL- YOU KNOW
WHY I'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK WITH
I THINK OVER THE YEARS AND I'VE
I'VE ACTUALLY YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE
WORKED ON UPGRADING STATEMENT
BECAUSEWHILE WORKING ON THAT
LIST. THEY SHOULD. A NEW. OTHERS
THAT. BY OF FUNDING FOR EITHER
SMALL BUSINESS START UPS. AND SO
THIS IS A VERY VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM IN A IN AN INDUSTRY
THINKS CAN BE CRITICAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE. SO I WOULD
LIKE TO PUT IN A REQUEST. SHOULD
HELP THE BILL'S SIGNING OR- GET
IT THROUGH THE PROCESS TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR MS BILLS
WELL. I WELCOME THE CHAIRS
ACROSS AND I THINK I FAILED TO
SAY THAT I'M ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES MEN. THANK YOU SIR I
DID THAT AS WELL. SO THERE IS
CENTER EGGMAN. HELLO JUST LIKE
TO SAY I'M AND I'M A VETERAN
CORE ON THIS- BUT I REALLY DO
BELIEVE ESPECIALLY IN IN THE
VALLEY WHERE A LOT OF OUR- R.
COMES FROM MOST BIG TRUCKS IN.
BRAILLE AND SHIPS COMING INTO
PORT IT JUST ALL KIND OF
COLLIDES TO CREATE THAT THE HOT
SPOT OF ASTHMA. AND AIR
POLLUTION SO THINGS LIKE THIS.
AND THAT WE DO A JUST TRANSITION
OF OUR WORKFORCE I THINK IT'S
JUST IT'S ALL GOOD SO. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INFORMATION IN AND
ASKED ME. WORKING ON THIS. THANK
I JUST LIKE TO GO ON RECORD AS
SAYING THIS IS- FINALLY I WE
CANNOT LET DEFY HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS WELL I DON'T THINK WE'LL
GET THERE I THINK I THINK THIS
IS THE ROUTE TO GO I THINK I
JUNE IS DEFINITELY THE WAY TO GO
AND WHEN HE COMES TO AIR
TRANSPORTATION TRAINS AND THIS
IS STATED BEFORE EVEN SHIP THIS
IS THIS IS THE ONE THING THAT WE
NEED TO. THIS IS PART OF. COURSE
ISN'T. BECAUSE I USED IT'S EASY
TO TRANSPORT AND SO VERY EXCITED
TO SEE THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND IF YOU
WANNA MAKE ANY CLOSING COSTS I'D
ONLY OUT OF REALLY APPRECIATED
THE COMMENTS FROM THE BUILDING
TRADES BUT- TALKED ABOUT NEW
JOBS THE OTHER GREAT THING IT'S
BEEN SORT OF IMPLIED IS THAT
WHILE WE NEED SOME NEW- TECHNO
OR NOT TECHNOL. ME NEEDS.
IMAGINE TO WHAT. EXTENT THEN WE
DON'T NEED WE CAN USE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE WE CAN EVEN USE
EXISTING TRUCKS. AND SO THAT'S
THE OTHER BRILLIANCE OF IT IS
THAT IT WE CAN UTILIZE. NOT ONLY
THE PEOPLE THAT SUPPORT AND
STAFF THAT EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT THE VERY THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ITSELF SO WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY THANK
YOU AND HAVE A NICE DAY. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO ITEM FIVE CENTER
CAREER S. B. ELEVEN OH NINE A
BILL RELATED TO CALIFORNIA
RENEWABLES PORTFOLIO STANDARD
PROGRAM. OUR BIO ENERGY PROJECTS
IN CALIFORNIA WELCOME. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT S. B. ELEVEN OH NINE
WHICH WILL INCREASE THE PACE AND
SCALE OF THE REMOVAL OF FOREST
WASTE FROM CALIFORNIA'S BURN
AREAS AND ECOLOGICALLY STRESSED
PURPOSE AS WELL AS- AGRICULTURAL
WASTE. SOME AMOUNT BENEFICIAL RE
USE FACILITY WHEN I THINK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
BILL AND I'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. THERE ARE
THERE ARE AN ESTIMATED ONE
HUNDRED MILLION. BONE DRY TONNES
OR BT TEASE A FIRE KILLED FOREST
WOULD WASTE IN CALIFORNIA
LEAVING EXCESS BORIS WASTE AN
OVERGROWTH MATERIAL IN THE
STATE'S ECOLOGICALLY STRESSED
FOREST LEAVES THE FOREST AT HIGH
RISK OF MASSIVELY DESTRUCTIVE
WILDFIRES IMPEDES THE FUNCTION
OF WATERSHEDS DIMINISHES
WILDLIFE HABITAT AND HAS OTHER
NEGATIVE EFFECTS ON THE
ENVIRONMENT TO SAY NOTHING OF
THE PEARLS. OF A PROPERTY AND-
THIS WOULD WASTE DECAYS AND
PRODUCES CARBON DIOXIDE WHICH
ACCELERATES GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS WE CAN BE PROACTIVE IN
PROTECT OUR FORESTS IN NEARBY
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES BY
REMOVING FOREST FUELS TO PROCESS
AND BIOMASS FACILITIES OR WE CAN
WAIT UNTIL THE NEXT WILDFIRE
BURNS IT AWAY. NEGATING THE AIR
EMISSION REDUCTIONS THAT COULD
BE GAINED ANY EMISSION
REDUCTIONS THAT COULD BE GAINED-
SOLUTION TO OUR DEAD END UP. BUT
ALL ALSO OFFERS MULTIPLE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS RENEWABLE
BIOMASS ENERGY PRODUCTION HOPES
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL AIR QUALITY STANDARDS BY
REDUCING EMISSIONS OF CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS BY PREVENTING OPEN
AIR BURNING OF ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION TONS OF AGRICULTURAL AND
FOREST. FORESTRY WASTE EACH YEAR
BIOMASS PLANTS CUT CRITERIA
POLLUTANT EMISSIONS BY UP 298%
COMPARED WITH OPEN BURNING IN
THE AGRICULTURAL. WHEN YOU WENT
PARKS THE SIX TIMES PER DAY OF
PM TWO POINT FIVE RICHARD THAT
FINE PARTICULATE MATTER WERE
PRODUCED BY OPEN AGRICULTURAL
BURNING STATEWIDE THESE
EMISSIONS ARE SIGNIFICANT NOT
ONLY BECAUSE THEY FORTY ATTEMPT
TO MEET AIR QUALITY STANDARDS
BUT ALSO FOR THEIR IMPACTS ON
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND THE SAN
JOAQUIN ERR DISTRICT HAS. IT
FROM BURNING. IN FIVE. THE GROUP
. IT'S- IT'LL A SIGNIFICANT
POLLUTION BUT WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING WITH THAT AGRICULTURAL
WASTE CONVERTING AGRICULTURAL
MATERIAL TO BIOMASS POWER
GENERATION IS A SUSTAINABLE
ALTERNATIVE TURNITIN TO OPEN AIR
BURNING AND QUITE FRANKLY IT
PRODUCES ENERGY AT IT. WHICH IS
US THE FLEXIBILITY ON OUR GREAT
TO BE ABLE TO UTILIZE IT WHEN WE
NEED IT THE MOST. TO THIS END AS
AMENDED S. B. ELEVEN OH NINE
WILL EXTEND EXISTING BIRAM
CONTRACT FOR ANOTHER FIVE YEARS
NEW CONTRACTS WOULD HAVE A FIVE
TO FIFTEEN YEAR TIME FRAME.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL REQUIRES
ANY BIOMASS PLANT WITH THE NEW
TEN YEAR CONTRACT TO SATISFY AIR
QUALITY REQUIREMENTS AS WELL
THESE PLANTS WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO HAVE. THE BEST AVAILABLE
RETROFIT CONTROL TECHNOLOGY ARE
BARKED VALUATION COMPLETED WITH
THE LOCAL AIR QUALITY CONTROL
DISTRICT. UP WORK IN ADDITION.
OUT REQUIREMENTS DEEMED RELEVANT
AND REASONABLE THAT SHOULD BE
UPON THE BIOMASS FACILITY I
THANK YOU AND THANKFULLY. NINE
HAVE TO SPEAKER. I HAVE AN
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION WILL GIVE
HIM NINETY SECONDS EACH
BEGINNING WITH JULIE ABOUT.
MELANAU SKI BALL YEAH HOW ARE
YOU NOON MATH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
JULIE MULLIN BASKETBALL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE THE FIRST ONE I THINK
THE COMMITTEE FOR YOU WITH US
THE BILL AND OF COURSE THE
AUTHOR FOR STEPPING UP IN
INTRODUCING A VERY THAT BALL
FOREST HEALTH A PROPOSAL C. B.
MEMBERS ARE PROUD TO HAVE BEEN
PLAYING AN IMPORTANT ROLE FOR
STATES WHILE CRISIS. IN CAN BY
RAD DOWN TO HIGH PRICE HI VAL
FORCED NO OTHER HOME FOR OF YOU
HAVE BEEN AROUND THIS BUILDING
THE LAST SEVERAL WILDFIRE
SEASONS WE KNOW THERE'S NOWHERE
ELSE TO TAKE THIS MATERIAL. BUT
THE STATE IS USING EVERY TOOL IN
THE SHED BEGAN TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM. THANKFULLY CALIFORNIA
IS ONE OF THE LUCKY WILDFIRE
VULNERABLE WESTERN STATES THAT
HAS EXISTING BIOENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE A PART OF
THE SOLUTION. WE ARE LUCKY
BECAUSE WE HAVE THAT. AND
THROUGH REGULAR FUEL REPORTING
TO THE STATE AGENCIES WE KNOW
THAT THESE EXISTING FACILITY.
ABOUT ONE THREE. TONS WHAT WHAT
LAST YEAR ALONE MUCH OF THAT IS
FORCED WASTE. AND THEY'RE DOING
THIS BY CUTTING CRITERIA
POLLUTANT EMISSIONS UP 298% WITH
HIGHLY CONTROLLED EMISSIONS
TECHNOLOGIES COMPARED WITH OPEN
BURNING. AND THE BEAUTY OF USING
BIO ENERGY FOR THIS PURPOSE IS
THE STATE THEN GETS THE ADDED
EXTRA BENEFIT CLEAN RENEWABLE
ELECTRICITY ONLINE THAT BALANCES
OUT OTHER RENEWABLES HELPING THE
FOLLOWING SHAPE THE LOAD. AS A
AS IN ADDITION HAVING BASELOAD
POWER AVAILABLE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
WILL MOVE TO MATT MATT DÍAS.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MATT YES
PRESSED OF THE COP TWENTY THREE
ASSOCIATION- ONE VERY CLEAR THAT
CALIFORNIA'S THE SUPPORT OF AS
NUMBER- NOT. FIRST OF THIS IS A
FORCED FORCES ARE IN C. AND MARK
MEDIC BELL. DISPOSE BY MAY
PROJECTS ROLE IN REDUCING HAZARD
. IN BUILDING FORCE WAS. WITHOUT
HOW FOR THIS MEANT TO BE
TRANSPORTED TO- THE WE ARE
FORCED TO SIMPLY TO LEAVE THE
MATERIAL IN PLACE WHICH DOES NOT
ACHIEVE ALSO MADE THE GOALS OF
THE WILDFIRE MITIGATION OR FOR
CUSTOMERS ON THESE PROJECTS. THE
STATE BORDERS WE COME TOGETHER
TO TREAT- TO SET GOALS TO TREAT
A MILLION ACRES ANNUALLY AND
REINFORCE ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TREMENDOUS. AMOUNT
WILL BE ADDED AGAIN WITHOUT
PLACE JUST. OF THE MATERIAL IT
WILL IT WILL REMAIN ON SITE- IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SEASONS. MET LOST AND FOUND A
WILD FIRE.
AIR FORCE TO REFOREST BUT PRIOR
TO RE FORCING WE'RE LOOKING AT
TRYING TO CLEAR OFF THE DEAD AND
DYING MATERIAL THAT WAS
GENERATED FROM THE WILDFIRES.
AGAIN AS THE STANDARD OF
RESILIENCY AND WITHOUT AGAIN
OUTLETS THERE'S NOWHERE TO PUT
THE MATERIAL AND THEREFORE
YOU'RE FREE FORCING MAKERS ARE
LEFT AND A LAST RESORT STANDS
WERE DISAPPOINTED TO LEARN TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT OF THE BIRAM
PROGRAM. OR THAT'S THE BILL-
LEVEL NINE IS BEEN AMENDED TO
REMOVE THE EXPANSION STANDARDS.
AGAIN DEUCE OF DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND CENTER CABRIO FOR
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON EXPANSION
OPPORTUNITIES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL NOW MOVE TO SPEAKERS
SINCE. THE AUDIENCE IF YOU
COULD- NEAR THE THANK. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS PETER
ANSELL FROM THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE
ABERAVON BEHALF OF THE
INDEPENDENT ENERGY PRODUCERS AND
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
TERENCE SENATORS ROSANNA
CARPACCIO LEN HERE- BEHALF OF
GREENLEAF POWER IN SUPPORT AS
WELL THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON
BEHALF OF MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANY IN MENDOCINO FOREST
PRODUCTS COMPANY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. ANYONE ELSE WANNA MOVE
TO SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. ON THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. ELEVEN OH NINE. THANK YOU
TO STATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL ME PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY DONE
SO. LOCAL FIRST THE LINE THREE
EIGHTY NINE. MISTER CHAIR NUMBER
BEST A LAWSUIT ON BEHALF OF THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT PICKER. TWO EIGHTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
UNDER TOM LANDRY EVEN KERN MAIL
I NEED SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE
GREAT JOB THANK YOU THANK YOU
OUR NEXT SPEAKER. THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT. WHERE ARE YOU RIGHT.
THANK THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER WE
CUT THAT AS A SUPPORTER OF LYING
TO EIGHTY THREE. TO CHECK
MEMBERS JUST MILAN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPOSED COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER
. THREE TWENTY ONE. CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JOHN ANDERSON WITH
HUMBOLDT REDWOOD COMPANY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
PICKER. THREE NINETY FIVE. HELLO
MY NAME IS CRISTIANO FOR
EVERYTHING I CHECK OUR SERVICE
CORPORATION I'LL BE ON OPERATOR
NOBLE ENERGY HOW MUCH CALIFORNIA
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AT ELEVEN OH
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WEEK. THREE SEVENTEEN. AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THIRTY
BOYLSTON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
FRESH FRUIT ASSOCIATION AND
WESTERN ACT PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. NORTHER
LINE THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT OKAY
WE'LL GO TO A SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE AN ORGANIZED
PRESENTATION. BEGINNING WITH
ANTHONY SAMPSON WHICH I BELIEVE
IS IN PERSON- WHAT THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY. HI MISTER CHAIR I TT
MACKLER IF YOU'RE BEHALF OF
ANTHONY SAMPSON HE GOT CAUGHT UP
PRESENTING AND TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE AND THAT HE DID NOT
CLEARLY STAMPED ADVISORS ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC POWER AUTHORITY OKAY YOU
HAVE NINETY SECONDS SURE I THINK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. I HEAR INSPECT
A POSITION THAT I FEEL FINE I'VE
GOT TO IS THAT DURING HOURS YOU
CAN PRESS OF ELEVEN PUBLICLY
OWNED UTILITIES AND WANT YOUR
CREATION DISTRICT SERVE FIVE
CUSTOMERS. AND WHEN I STOP AS
MAIN FUNCTIONS IS TO PROVIDE
DRAIN ENERGY PROCUREMENT FOR ITS
MEMBERS. AS IT RELATES TO BYPASS
PROCUREMENT GOT THAT CANCELING
THE PROCUREMENT FOR ALL ELIGIBLE
HERE USING THE STATE INCLUDING
THEIR OWN MEMBERS AS WELL AS I.
YES STRICT. DISTRICT AND THE
BOARD DISCUSS OUR CONCERNS WITH
THE LIKE THE BRIEFLY MENTION HOW
BILASPUR IS. OUT THIS FOR LOW
TEN AT THE CARD IS. 20% SEVEN
CATHERINE YOU WILL BE LOAD
CONTRACTS FOR ZERO THREE LAND
GAS. AND NOT FACILITY IS BEING.
AS IT RELATES TO ROW. DUE TO THE
HIGH. OF THE BIO ENERGY FOR THIS
PROJECT IN THE TWO. CHARGES WITH
IT SCAPA IS KERN PAYING THE PAST
RIGHTS ONLY AND NOT THE END. IT
SO. AND WE APPRECIATE. I THINK
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT- WE DO
REMAIN IN OPPOSITE. ELEVEN NINE
AS EXTRA. ARE USED THAN THESE
PROBLEMATIC EXPENSIVE ATTACKS BY
. YOUR BENEFITS AT ALL. ARE YOU
MEANT HEARD IT SAYING THIS. SB
THAT- THIS BILL ONLY IMPOSE
DIMINISH IN ON BY AND WE WERE
DISAGREE. UNDER THE BILL
ASSUMING SKY- WOULD HAVE FILTER
MEANING TERMINIX THE TERM OF ITS
CONTRACT TO THE END OF TWENTY
THIRTY THREE ASCENTIAL FUTURE
COSTS FROM THE WILTON FACILITY
WOULD BE A HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN MILLION AT THE TEMPLE
FUTURE COSTS FOR ROSEBURG WOULD
BE FIFTY TWO PER TEAM. FROM MUCH
FOR CALM IN ONE TO THE NEXT
SPEAKER OPPOSITION DANIEL
BARRAGE WHAT- THE SIERRA CLUB-
HE I BELIEVE IS ON THE PHONE
LINE IF- YOU CAN BEGIN NOW YEAH
I'D SECOND AFTERNOON. GETTING
ABROAD ON BEHALF OF CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO AT
ELEVEN OO NINE. MM IS THE
PERFECT IMPROVE THE BELL BUT THE
BILL WOULD STILL EXTEND THE
PROBLEMATIC PROGRAM AND COULD
PROVIDE CONTRACTOR BIOMASS THE
DELEGATES AND THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. WHICH THEN LUNG
ASSOCIATION. REPORT THANKS
NUMBER IN THE NATION IN TERMS
PARTICULAR APPLICATION. MOTOR
BIOMASS. IN THE STATE ABOUT THE
NINETEEN NINETIES AND EVEN WITH
POLLUTION CONTROL TECHNOLOGIES
IN PLACE AND THAT LARGE AMOUNT
TIME TO TAKE THE MATTER AND FIVE
ONE. BURGER VIOLENCE CURRENTLY
DOES NOT SOLVE THE PROBLEMS THAT
IT EXACT THIS ALL. ANYTHING IT
DOES NOT MAKE SENSE. UNDER THE
FILE PROGRAM REPAIRS ARE FORTY
NINE I AM NOT PLANT BASED ON THE
PREMISE THAT THE BIOMASS PLANT
THOSE OF BIOMASS IT IS REMOVED
FROM THE FOURTH TO COMBAT
WILDFIRES OR REMOVED AT EIGHT.
HOWEVER THE COUNT BOARD BIRAM
FUEL. ONLY NEED TO COME OUT I
THINK. DEFINED REGION KNOWN AS I
HAD PICKED UP. THEY DON'T NEED
TO BE REMOVED THEY DON'T NEED TO
BE DAD AND THEY DON'T NEED TO BE
REMOVED TO BENEFIT ECOLOGY. AS A
RESULT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THESE THREE BURNED INTO OUR
FACILITIES ARE. BAAGHI A STRIP.
THAT HAPPENS HE AND I HAD.
WITHOUT NARROW FIELD WORK. THE
BIRAM PRO THE ONLY BENEFIT
LONGER THAN FIVE FACILITIES
BACKBREAKER COSTS TOPIC. I FEEL
I OH NINE BUT NEGATIVELY AND ERA
CARMEN AND- WITH FIXING THE
PROBLEM THAT EXIST WITH THE
BUYOUT. PROGRAM THANK YOU SO
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU CAN WE ARE IN OUR MAIN
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION THE BILL
HERE IN THE- COMMITTEE. PLEASE
PERSON PRESS MIKE THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK FENSTER
MAKER ON BEHALF OF EARTH JUSTICE
REFLECT SPECTRAL OPPOSITION FOR
THE REASONS STATED BY SIERRA
CLUB THANK YOU. NEXT PICKER.
PATRICK WHAT TO THE CALIFORNIA
SUITE TWO IS ASSOCIATION OFTEN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION A WINNER
COMMENTS WITH A COLLEAGUES FROM
SCAPA THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
OVER THE PHONE LINES- FOR PEAK
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
ELEVEN OH NINE MODERATOR PLEASE
Q. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU TO STAY OUT LISTEN TO THIS
BILL YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY DONE
SO I MEAN PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. OVER THE LINE B. NINETY.
YEAH FUTURE NUMBERS BACK UP WITH
THE NEW COMPANY FIGHTERS- ON
BEHALF OF BUT IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. NEXT BIGGER. LINE ONE
EIGHTY THREE. TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON THE
LINE TO EIGHTY FIVE. YES MY NAME
IS ON THE FRONT AND ONE OF HIS
BIRTH MY APPROVAL BEFORE. THEIR
EYES THAT I SAID BEFORE AFTER
HEARING OF THE OPPOSITION I'M
AGAINST IT NOW OKAY AND IT WILL
NOT IT WILL NOT APPRECIATE YOU
CALL. IN AND NEXT BIGGER. NO
OTHER LINES IN Q. ISN'T THAT
GREAT. OKAY WILL NOW. COME TO
THE COMMITTEE THE US ARE ACT.
I'M STILL FOR IT- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION I'VE I'VE
CONSISTENTLY VOTED FOR BIOMASS
BUILT BILLS- I THINK IT'S A
CLEAN SOURCE OF ENERGY I THINK
IT SOLVES A PROBLEM WE HAVE I
KNOW THOSE AGAINST IT WOULD LIKE
US I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY LIKE
IT'S TO DO WITH EVERYTHING BUT
THEY LIVE IN IN THE SAN JOAQUIN.
ON NEAR BURNING THE AIR IS YOU
CAN SEE THE ERROR AND YOU CAN
CERTAINLY FEEL IT IN YOUR LUNGS
AND THAT IS THAT IT DOESN'T JUST
GO AWAY JUST BECAUSE WE STOP
BIOMASS THIS YEAR YOU CAN'T ALL
THAT STUFF BORN OF A WAY TO MAKE
ANY OF MONEY SO IT'S GOING TO BE
LOCAL. I JAPAN'S WITH YOUR- BUT
SERTOLI WELL I WANT TO THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FOR HAD A SIMILAR BILL A FEW
YEARS BACK FOR BILL I AND THEN
SB NINE A ONE WEEK WE DID SOME
WORK IN THAT AS WELL I JUST SAY
THE OPPOSITION THAT YOU KNOW IN
THE IN THE UTILITIES THAT ARE
THAT ARE PUSHING BACK ON THE
BIRAM. BIOMASS IS NOT JUST. THE
SWEETNESS FROM THE NINETY EIGHT
PERCENT- SAVINGS OF THE MISSIONS
THAT COME FROM FIRES BUT IT'S
ALSO THE ENVIRONMENT THAT THIS
YEAR'S BEEN THE POOREST AREAS
SUPPLY TO CALIFORNIA A GROWING
FOR SEQUESTERS CARBON. AND BY
THINNING OUT. LIVE TREES WE ARE
ABLE TO LET FIRE BACK INTO OUR
ECOSYSTEM AND ACTUALLY THE TREES
GROW FASTER AND THE SEQUESTER
CARBON AT THE SAME TIME WHEN
FIRE DOES COME INTO THE AREA IT
LAY DOWN ON THE FLOOR AND
PARCEL- AND LEAVE THESE THE
WILDLIFE THERE TO THE WAY AND I
COULD DO FOR MILAN BEFORE WE
SEE. THE FOR ALL THESE NOT SHE
LUCK ON THIS BILL I WILL LIVE. I
WOULD CO AUTHOR IF YOU'D LIKE
THAT IF NOT IT DOESN'T MATTER
BUT I WILL HELP YOU GET. UP TO
GET A POOR I MIGHT NOT BE A HELP
BUT I DO- REALLY WANT TO SEE.
HOUSE IT IS REALLY A BENEFIT TO
THE PUBLIC- BECAUSE THE WHAT THE
INCREASED WATER AS WELL WE DON'T
TALK ABOUT THE WATER SUPPLY I
MEAN I KNOW THAT YOU. DO YOUR
GEISHA DISTRICTS ARE DON'T LIKE
IT BECAUSE OF THE INTERVIEW PART
OF IT BUT THEY SURE LIKED WHAT
DID STEVE SO WE HAD THE- FIRE
LAST YEAR. ALMOST A MILLION
ACRES OF DISTRICT. NOW WATERSHED
IS DESTROYED FOR FIFTY TO SIXTY
YEARS A MILLION YEARS. TENTERDEN
FOR ACRES IS WHERE MY- SO YOU
CAN DO. MATH OF HOW MANY SQUARE
MILES AND ONE FIRE. WAS
DESTROYED AND THAT'S THE
WATERSHED THAT GOES INTO OR
BILL- LAKE- WHICH WE WILL SEE
FOR THE NEXT FIFTY SIXTY YEARS
WE WILL BE GETTING GONE BUT-
FIND THAT COMES. THE CELL. THIS
BILL TO HELP PREVENT THOSE.
TYPES OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE-
TONIGHT THOUGH. OKAY VERY WELL
DID YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS BY THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER TURNER G. HONORED TO HAVE
YOU SENATOR DOLLY- CO AUTHOR-
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES WE GET CAUGHT
UP IN TRYING TO FIND THE PERFECT
SOLUTION. AND WHEN I COME TO
LEARN OVER THE YEARS. IS THAT
EVEN EVEN MY OWN IDEAS FOR
PERFECT SOLUTIONS BY MAKE A VERY
MORNING I THINK I GOT THE
PERFECT SOLUTION. WELL BRING TO.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE. ON WHAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT IS WE HAVE A-
AN ENERGY GRID THAT IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE. AND WE HAVE A POWER
PLANT WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING
OFF LINE IN JUST A FEW YEARS
THAT PRODUCES 10% OF OUR ENERGY.
SO OUR GRID WILL BE EVEN MORE
UNSTABLE AND ON MY WATCH I DON'T
WANT. US TO HAVE BLACKOUTS OR
BROWNOUTS. WHERE ENERGY CEASES
TO FLOW. BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T MADE
PLANS NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO
IT HAPPENS DURING THE HOTTEST OR
THE COLDEST TIME OF THE YEAR.
AND SO THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
NUMBER NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO IS.
WE HAVE TO MAKE THE COMMITMENT
FOR THINGS TO BE GREENER. AND
PART OF THAT IS THAT THAT THE
EXCEPT TECHNO. MAY PERFECT BUT
IT'S BETTER WHAT WE RIGHT NOW
AND- THE BURNING I HAVE TO. WITH
SENATOR EGGMAN. WHEN OPEN AIR
BURNING IS IT OCCURRING YOU CAN
TASTE IT YOUR I. IT BURN AND YOU
CAN FEEL IN YOUR- AND- DOESN'T.
WAIT AND SO WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING WITH THE WEIGHT THE-
NEW. AND. BIOMET US WITH AN- TO
ENTERED AND WE NEED IT WHEN THE
WIND MAY NOT BE BLOWING AND THE
SUN MAY NOT BE OUT. AND TO BE
ABLE TO GET RID OF WASTE THAT
THAT IS A PART OF A LIVING ON
THIS EARTH AND SO IF WE CAN DO
IT IN A WAY. THAT UPS AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE USING BARCODE
TECHNOLOGY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE- CLEANING AND SCRUBBING
THAT THAT THE RESIDUE THAT'S
COMING UP AND THEN WILL BE DOING
BETTER THAN WE DID BEFORE AND
SO- WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA OF. ASK FOR MOTION
WE HAVE A QUORUM SO FOR NOW
WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT BILL WERE
SINGLE FUNCTIONING AS
SUBCOMMITTEE OF THE- COMMITTEE
ON ENERGY POLICE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS WILL. ASK FOR
THE NEXT SPEAKER AN ITEM SIX S.
B. ONE ONE. ONE NINE CENTER
EARLY MONTHS THANK YOU TERM
MEMBERS AND I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. SB ELEVEN NINETEEN
SIMPLY CONFIRMS THE AUTHORITY OF
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
TO REQUIRE AN ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW FOR GAS PROJECTS THAT ARE
NOW BEING SUBSTANTIALLY MODIFIED
THE P. YOU SEE CURRENT. S. IS
FOR ELECTRIC UTILITIES AND ARE
CURRENTLY UNDERGOING A REAL
MAKING TO APPLY A SIMILAR
PROCEDURE TO GAS PLANTS. THESE
GAS INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS CAN
GREATLY AFFECT THE COMMUNITIES
AROUND THEM IN MY DISTRICT
INVENTOR FTER A GAS COMPRESSOR
STATION HAS RAISED ENVIRONMENTAL
AND PUBLIC SAFETY CONCERNS AND-
THE COMMUNITY AND THE GAS
UTILITY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO COME
TOGETHER TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS TO
HAVE PUBLIC FORMS- MANY PEOPLE
WERE UNAWARE. THAT THE PROJECT
OF THE PROJECT UNTIL AFTER IT
WAS APPROVED BY THE PUC'S. BY
AUTHORIZING THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO REQUIRE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW FOR A NEW
OR SUBSTANTIALLY FIVE GAS
PROJECTS WE CAN PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND MAKE SURE
COMMUNITIES HAVE. AT THE TABLE.
TODAY THAT'S WE HAVE HERE SO BE
IT WELCOME. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB OPEN NINETEEN. AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT- MARIJUANA US
ON THE PHONE LINE IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN. MERRY YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN WELCOME
ALL RIGHT WONDERFUL ROLE GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE WITH ALL OF
YOU AND MY NAME IS SOPHIA ONE
FEATHER AND I AM THE MAYOR OF
THE CITY OF VENTURA. AND I AM
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN NINETEEN BECAUSE- THE
REASON PROJECT FOR A SUBSTANTIAL
MODIFICATION. TO A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPRESSOR
STATION HAS CREATED A VERY
DIFFICULT SITUATION FOR OUR CITY
GOVERNMENT AND FOR OUR
RESIDENTS. BECAUSE IN FIFTY FIVE
OF PROJECT DOES NOT REQUIRED
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. IS REALLY
HARD TO UNDERSTAND WHY THERE IS
NO ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
REQUIREMENTS FOR THIS TYPE
PROJECT. BECAUSE WE AS A CITY
GOVERNMENT HAVE TO PERFORM E. I.
R. ALL THE TIME FOR OTHER TYPES
OF PROJECT. FOR EXAMPLE A FEW
YEARS AGO WHEN WE WERE CREATING
OUR BOTANICAL GARDENS WITH.
PLANTS IN DOUBT DROUGHT TOLERANT
PLANTS WE WERE REQUIRED TO
PERFORM E. R. AND A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO OUR COUNCIL WAS HAVING
A DISCUSSION ABOUT. THE LAW
THANKS.
SO IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT TO
UNDERSTAND WHY A GAS COMPRESSOR
STATION. CAN DO SUBSTANTIAL
MODIFICATION WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS. AND I MUST SAY I LIVE
ABOUT A HALF MILE AWAY FROM THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT. AND I WAS
NOT AWARE THAT THIS PROCESS WAS
GOING ON. WE WERE NEVER INFORMED
AS RESIDENTS. BUT TO MAKE
MATTERS WORSE WE WERE ACTUALLY
NEVER INFORMED AT THE CITY. OR
DEPARTMENTS WERE NEVER INFORMED
THAT THIS TYPE OF WORK WAS GOING
TO BE HAPPENING. AND SO THAT'S
WHY YOU THINK IT'S TIME FOR US
TO REQUIRED ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
FOR THESE TYPES OF PROJECTS.
BECAUSE WE'RE ASKING A LOT OF
OTHER. PROJECTS GO. BUT NOT. THE
STATIONS OR OTHER THE GAS MARKET
SO I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THIS BILL
WILL NO LONGER AFFECT MY CITY
BECAUSE IT'S NOT RETROACTIVE SO
THERE UNFORTUNATELY IT WON'T
REALLY HELP US IN OUR SITUATION
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS TYPE OF SITUATION IF. IN
OTHER COMMUNITIES SO THAT IS WHY
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOUNG MAYBE
NOT IN THE SYSTEMS BUT A FUTURE
INSTANCES. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS WILL GO TO ANY SPEAKERS
HERE IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT.
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINES NOW
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN Q. Q.
SUPPORTERS IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN NINETEEN. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS SUPPOR FOR THE BILL YOU
MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
HELLO FIRSTLINE THREE FORTY NINE. THREE FOUR NINE YOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE
THREE NINETY SIX. THERE ARE
MARROW WITH CALIFORNIA AND MY
MENTAL BETTER IMPORT. NEXT
BIGGER. THE FLYING THREE NINETY
TWO. HELLO DEAR YES. I
OPERATIVES JOYLAND VICE
PRESIDENT PRESIDENT OF NATIVE
LOCAL FIFTY THREE IN BURBANK
CALIFORNIA I ARISE TODAY SUPPORT
THE BILL- I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT- THERE IS
OVERSIGHT AND THAT THE HOURS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
. LINE. THREE SEVEN SIX. HI MY
NAME IS FAITH MYRA AND- I'M WITH
PROTECT I AND I WOULD LIKE TO
IMPAIR MY PORTRAIT OF SELF.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK. THANK YOU
NO FURTHER LINES IN Q. OKAY
WE'LL GO TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE AN
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION
OPPOSITION BUT IF WE CAN BRING
ANYBODY HERE FROM THE ROOM
SPEAKING OPPOSITION. SIR GOOD
AFTERNOON SAYS CENTER HUESO
CARMICHAEL ON BEHALF OF SAN
DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC AND SOCALGAS.
WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON ON THIS BILL WE WANT
TO THANK YOU. FOR ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES RECOMMENDED AMENDMENT
AS REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS I
WOULD BELIEVE IT MOVES THE BILL
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION- WE CAN.
THAT SAID WE CONTINUE WE WANT TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR ON
ADDITIONAL CHANGES TO ENSURE ANY
PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS PRESERVE
AND BALANCE SAFETY AND
RELIABILITY. WITH THE
APPROPRIATE THRESHOLDS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
MISTER CHAIR MIKE MONICA BEHALF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL- THE
ANALYSIS ASK THE QUESTION IS
BILL NECESSARY AND I DON'T THINK
IT HAS THE P. UC HAD LOTS OF
AUTHORITY TO DO WHATEVER THEY
NEED TO DO IN THIS FIELD- SECOND
WHAT WE DON'T NEED A REPEAT OF
WHAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR WHEN THE
GOVERNOR HAD TO USE EMERGENCY
PROCLAMATIONS. TO RESTART SOLD
BAKER PLANTS THE PC SHOULD BE
WORKING IN HASTE- GAS PLANTS OR
WHATEVER TO REPLACE THE OLD PEAK
OFFENSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE. WE'LL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR PLEASE CUES
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. OF SB
ELEVEN NINETEEN. THANK YOU THE
STATE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
PRESS ONE BY ZERO AGAIN USING
YOUR PHONE AS ONE OF THEM ZERO.
WE DO HAVE A LINE WITH AN
OPERATOR BE JUST A MOMENT.
HELLO FIRST TO LINE THREE IN
NINETY THREE. DUBLIN COMMITTEE
EARNED HONORABLE SURE OUR
RESPONSE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
DISCOMFORT LABORS AND WE STAND
IN OPPOSITION AT THREE ONE ONE
ONE NINE THANK YOU. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE TWO OH FIVE. EXACTLY WHAT
EVERYBODY- BUT INTERNET SHOP-
OF- LOCAL FORTY FOR YOU TO BE A
WAY. OF BUSINESS STORAGE AND- WE
COULD NOT SUPPORT THE THIS BILL
LEVEL NINETEENTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT SPEAKER. THAT'S
LINE TWO THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD EVENING
BEAUTIFUL ROBLESS WITH LABOR
CITY COUNCIL IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. THREE
THIRTY TWO. I AM VERY VERY VOCAL
THREE FORTY THREE OPPONENTS
DEFENDERS AND WE'RE GOING THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BECAUSE- TWO TWENTY ONE.
HELLO MY NAME IS THAT JOHN HURT
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE UNITED
ASSOCIATION OF PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL FOUR FOUR
SEVEN SACRAMENTO- CALLING IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER. NO FURTHER LINES
INTO AT THIS TIME OKAY VERY
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE AS
CENTER EGGMAN I THINK YOU CENTER
LAMONT- SO THE PEOPLE RAISE THE
QUESTION IS THIS DOES THIS U. P.
NEED THIS IS IT. CAN YOU CAN YOU
SPEAK TO THAT YES WE FEEL THAT
IT IS NEEDED- WERE ACTUALLY
WORKING WITH THE PC SO AS WE
YELL AT IT THIS WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL AND I THINK I THINK THE
IMPORTANT PIECE ABOUT THIS BILL
IS THAT CLARITY IS A GOOD THING
IN ORDER TO AVOID THESE
SITUATIONS WERE HAPPENING WE
JUST DON'T WANT THIS TO KEEP YOU
KNOW TO HAPPEN AGAIN. I'M IN
OKAY IF YOU ARE OF THE MIND THAT
IF YOU SCAN ALREADY THIS THEN
I'M NOT ACTUALLY SURE WHY THAT
YOU OPPOSE THE BILL. BECAUSE FOR
US IT'S JUST REASSURING LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY'LL HAVE A
AN ABILITY TO WEIGH IN- AS HAS
BEEN SAID STATED IT'S NOT GOING
TO IMPACT MY DISTRICT IN THE
SITUATION THAT HAPPENED BUT IT
WILL BE VERY HELPFUL TO. WAIT A
MINUTE I AM. OKAY YOU. WE CAN
MAKE A MOTION- BECAUSE WE'RE-
AGAIN WE HAVEN'T STOPPED SCORM
SO IF YOU WANT TO MAKE SOME
CLOSING COMMENTS. AT WHAT JUST
LIKE YOU KNOW I'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION-
CERTAINLY WE'RE LOOKING AT SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE. AT TO
KIND OF GO OVER THAT LANGUAGE-
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY
BUT- OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW I. THANKS FOR COMING BY
TODAY. CAN. EIGHT THIS BILL THE
BILL- IT'S ON CONSENT. BETTER
NOT FULLER EITHER YOU BETTER NOT
PULL IT THANKS TO A
REPRESENTATIVE.
WE HAVE FOR A POLICE. FIVE BILLS
TO.
WE'RE WE'RE JUST ABOUT TO HOLD
YOUR BILL. I REMEMBER SEVEN S.
B. THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO CENTER
ALAN. THE BILL RELATED TO
PETROLEUM PRICING WELCOME THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO THANK
YOU AND THE MEMBERS I LET LET ME
JUST START BY ACCEPTING- THE
COMMITTEES PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
TO AND I JUST WANNA THANK YOUR
STAFF FOR. WORKING OUT WITH US
IN RECENT WEEKS- VERY COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH EVERYONE ON
POTENTIAL FOR THE REFINEMENTS OF
THIS POLICY. THE BILL MOVE FOR
TODAY. SO THIS BILL SEEKS TO
PROVIDE GREATER TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT THE COST TO PRODUCE
GASOLINE SOLD IN OUR STATE. I
REQUIRES THE REFINERIES TO
PUBLICLY DISCLOSE THE AVERAGE
MONTHLY PRICE THEY PAY FOR CRUDE
OIL AND THE PROFIT MARGINS THAT
ARE MAKING ON THE GASOLINE THAT
THEY REFINE. AND SELL AND THEN
COMBINING THIS INFORMATION WITH
OTHER PUBLICLY THEY'RE MISSING
DATA WILL PROVIDE US WITH A
CLEAR PICTURE OF WHO IS
PROFITING OFF OF GASOLINE SOLD
IN THE GOLDEN STATE OF MAKING
AND ALSO- EVALUATE MANY THE
CLAIMS ARE BEING MADE BY BOTH.
LOVERS AND HATERS OF THE OF THE
OIL HISTORY. SO I KNOW THAT-
FOLKS FAMILIAR YOU HAVE REACHED
OUT TO MY STAFF AND I THE
CERTAINLY REACH OUT TO YOU- I
KNOWS WELL DONE YOU KNOW- THERE
THERE WAS A FOUR PAGE STILL
SPACE OPPOSITION THAT WE READ
VERY FOR YOU. I'M AT THE- BUT
YOU KNOW IN THE END OF THE DAY-
YEAH THAT FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE
THE FINDINGS AND DECLARATIONS IN
THE BILL MISSED THE MARK I I'LL
SAY I'M HAPPY DELETE THEM THAT'S
GOING TO HELP. I THEY'VE ALSO
CLEAN THAT THERE HAVE ALREADY
BEEN INVESTIGATIONS ON OIL
PRICES IN THE AND THERE'S BEEN
NOTHING FANTASY- THEY'VE ARGUED
THAT THE COST FOCUSES ON COST
INFLATION. THOSE ARE THE BILL
FOCUS ON COST INFLATION IT'S
REALLY MORE THE FAULT OF
GASOLINE RETAILERS- THEY'VE ALSO
ASSERTED- TO STAFF- THAT-
CALIFORNIA DRIVERS PAY MORE AT
THE PUMP MOSTLY BECAUSE OUR
GOVERNMENT REQUIRES CLEANER.
GASOLINE AND HAS HIGHER TAXES
AND ENVIRONMENTAL FEES IN
NEIGHBORING STATES. SO I'M I
THINK THERE IS ABSOLUTE TRUTH TO
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
ARGUMENTS. OUT BUT WE ALSO KNOW
WHEN YOU BREAK IT DOWN. THAT
DOESN'T THOSE ARGUMENTS DON'T
TELL THE WHOLE STORY. RIGHT WE
CAN QUANTIFY THE GAS TAX WE CAN
QUANTIFY THE ENVIRONMENTAL COSTS
. HI AND WE CAN CERTAINLY SEE.
OUR COST INFLATION- R. AS IT
WILL IT WILL BE BECAUSE WE CAN
COMPARE OUR PRIDE OUR OUR PRICES
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THEN MATCH THEM UP TO. THE
HIGHER COST HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
AND IN THE END OF THE DAY WE
STILL KNOW THAT THERE'S A PRICE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHEN YOU WE
TAKE ALL THOSE THINGS INTO
ACCOUNT THERE'S STILL A PRICE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT WE PAY
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND WHAT
FOLKS PAY ENOUGH BATES AND NO I
AM I CONTINUE I REMAIN
UNCONVINCED. THAT I THINK SOME
SUNLIGHT ON REFINING PRICING AND
PRACTICES- IS GOING TO THREATEN
THE PUBLIC. I THINK THERE IS
THAT WE HAVE EVERYTHING WE HAVE
A LOT TO GAIN FROM TRYING SOME
MORE LIGHT ON THE ON THE PRICING
STRUCTURE WHICH MEANS SO MUCH TO
EVERYDAY PEOPLE. SO I'LL JUST
GIVE AN EXAMPLE- THAT THAT I
THINK IS AT THE HEART OF THIS.
DOWN INTO MY NECK OF THE WOODS
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN IT WAS A BIG
EXPLOSION. AT THE TORRANCE
REFINERY IS ONLY ABOUT SIX OR SO
REFINERIES THAT ARE PRODUCING.
THE SPECIAL BLEND OF GAP WE USE
HERE IN SILICON. AND AND THE
PRICES WENT UP SO YOU'RE BECAUSE
THAT REFINERIES OFFLINE. THE
PRICES WENT UP ABOUT A BUCK
FIFTY A GALLON. IN THE IMMEDIATE
AFTERMATH OF THE REFINERY. OUT
BUT THE INTERESTING THING IS-
YOKOHAMA'S PREDICTED THAT ONCE.
THE REFINERY WAS BACK UP AND
RUNNING THE PRICES WOULD JUST
RETURN EXACTLY BACK TO NORMAL
COURSE YOU'RE CORRECT FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL. FLUCTUATION IN
PRICES. OUT BUT THE INTERESTING
THING IS. THE PRICES STATE
INFLATED THEY CAME DOWN. BUT
THEY NEVER CAME DOWN IT WENT UP
ABOUT A BUCK FIFTY THEN THE
PRICE CAME DOWN A LITTLE LESS
THAN A DOLLAR. I AND FOR SEVEN
YEARS NOW THE PRICES HAVE HAVE
STATED. BAITED SO THIS BILL.
AMONG OTHER THINGS WILL PROVIDE
A CLEAR PICTURE JUST WHO'S
PROFITING. AND TO WHAT EXTENT. I
WOULD PROVIDE MORE SUNLIGHT IN
AN INDUSTRY THAT WE KNOW IS
MAKING REALLY STRONG PROFITS ALL
YOU COULD DO IS TAKE A LOOK AT
THEIR END. REPORTS WE'VE ALSO.
VIEWING NO OPPONENTS OF ALSO
FORCEFULLY ARGUED THE
INFORMATION THAT WE WANNA MAKE
PUBLIC WOULD ESSENTIALLY PUT.
CONSUMERS AT RISK THAT'S AN
ARGUMENT THAT THEY'VE BEEN
MAKING. I KNOW- THEY CLEAN THAT
THE DATA IS TO MARKET SENSITIVE-
AND IT COULD BE USED BY CLEVER
COMMODITIES TRADERS TO DRIVE UP
THE COST OF GAS EVEN MORE I
DON'T DISMISS THESE CLOUT THESE
CLAIMS HAPHAZARDLY- BUT I WOULD
KNOW IF YOU THINGS. WITH REGARD
TO THIS ARGUMENT THE PRICING
INFORMATION IN THE BILL. IS DATA
THAT THE OIL COMPANIES HAVE
ALREADY SHARED IN THE PAST WITH
IN CALIFORNIA. IT STATED THERE
PUBLICLY TRADED COMPANIES ARE
YOU DISCLOSE. HOLDERS IT'S ALSO
DATA THAT IN VERY FORMATS OIL
COMPANIES ALREADY PUBLICLY
DISCLOSED IN A NUMBER OF OTHER
AMERICAN STATES. I IN AND OF
COURSE IT'S ALSO DATA SHARED THE
WAY AFTER THE FACT IS WHEN YOU
CAN ENGAGE IN VERY EFFECTIVE
ARBITRAGE IF YOU HAVE REAL TIME
ACCESS TO DATA. WITH REGARD TO
PRICING BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
A MONTH OR SO AFTER THE FACT. I
AND OF COURSE IT DISCLOSURE THE
STATE REALLY IS THAT RISKY WE AS
LEGISLATORS TO TRUST THAT ARE
REGULATED IN OVERSIGHT AGENCIES
TELECEL- BUT I'VE PERSONALLY
SPOKEN TO LEADERSHIP BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE. ARE DIRECTLY
THE TRAIN GENERAL ALSO LEADERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION- THEY HAVE NOT ASKED
ME TO ABANDON THIS PATH AND DROP
THIS BILL- IN FACT- SOME OF THE-
CLAIMS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE. THAT
THAT WE YOU KNOW THAT IF THE
FOLKS OVER IN BOTH OF THOSE
AGENCIES. ARE AT. WHAT DO YOU
DO. REGIS CAN. DISAGREE WITH THE
ARGUMENT THAT. THAT THAT THEY'VE
BEEN AT THE- OF THE TOOLS THEY
NEED. I TO BE EFFECTIVE
WATCHDOGS. TO ENSURE THAT THAT
CONSUMERS ARE BEING ADEQUATELY
PROTECTED- FROM FROM POTENTIAL
PRICE GOUGING. SO- ANYHOW. KING
ISSUE IT'S- IS MY AT THIS IS THE
ONLY ALL ABOUT TRY TO PROVIDE
SOME LIKE TO TRANSFER ON ON TO
SOMETHING THAT WE KNOW IS OF
GRAVE INTEREST TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE DRIVING
PAYING MORE THAN EVER THANK YOU
PEERS YOU HAVE TWO SPEAKERS AND
THE DATES OR ANY COURT NICE
PRESENTATIONS THAT ARE JIMMY
CARTER ON THE PHONE LINE GOT IN
THE CAR CONSUMER DARGAN GENE.
GEN THANK STRONG WITH CALPERS
YES IF UP IF- JAMIE COURT IS ON
THE LINE. YOU HAVE A NINETY
SECONDS I AM. PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE PAYING A
DOLLAR FIFTY MORE PER GALLON
THAN IN- THE U. S. AND ONLY
SIXTY CENTS OF THAT CAN BE
ATTRIBUTABLE TO ENVIRONMENTAL
COSTS OR FEES AND TAXES A DOLLAR
FIFTY MORE PER GALLON AND THE
AVERAGE COST FOR THE U.
THERE'S NOTHING IN THIS
INFORMATION THAT WOULD PREVENT
THAT WOULD ALLOW MARKET
MANIPULATION IF THERE WAS THEY
WOULD BE PUTTING THIS OUT TO
THEIR INVESTORS IN OTHER PLACES.
THEY'RE NOT GOING IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE THEY'D BE EMBARRASSED
AFTER AT AT HOW MUCH THEY'RE
MAKING WE KNOW THAT THEY ARE
CHARGING US FOR A DOLLAR A
HUNDRED DOLLAR A BARREL CRUDE
OIL FROM MANY OF THEIR LONG TERM
CONTRACTS OR FOR MUCH LESS AS
LOW AS FIFTY DOLLARS A BARREL
FOR CRUDE OIL. AND THAT WOULD
ADD UP TO A DOLLAR TWO DOLLARS
ABOUT A DOWN AND PROFITS IF THAT
CAME OUT THAT WOULD BE
DEVASTATING THE SHE THAT'S THE
FOR APPRECIATE COMMENTS CIRCLE
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE A THE NAY
SPEAKER CHEN ANGST WITH CALLED
GIVE NINETY SO. ARE YOU ON THE
LINE THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON.
YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. GREAT
CAN HAPPEN- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME JENNINGS FROM
AND I'M TO SPEAK CALPERS. STATE
WIDE ADVOCACY WORKING. AND WE'RE
PROUD OF THE S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY. I WHILE WE DRIVE
CALIFORNIA WHERE THE PRICE OF
GAS DOESN'T MATTER BECAUSE OUR
CARS AND TRUCKS AND BUSES ARE
COMPLETELY POWERED BY RENEWABLE
ENERGY IN THE MEANTIME WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA OIL
REFINERS ARE. BEING. HOW MORE AT
THE GAS AND DRIVERS AND OTHERS.
WELL COMPANIES OFTEN THIS
ENVIRONMENT REGULATION BUT OUR
REMEMBERED. THAT ARE TAXES FOR
AND BRIDGE IMPROVE ONLY ACCOUNT
FOR PORSCHE OF THE- OVER A
DOLLAR MORE PER GALLON THAT
CALIFORNIA PAPERS WITH THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE. THANK YOU FOR
THE REST OF THE HIGHER COSTS
COME FROM OR WHO IT GOES TO.
ENACT A SPECIALLY NOW WITH SO
MUCH THE ACTUATION AND GAS
PRICES. WE NEED BETTER
TRANSPARENCY SO THE PUBLIC CAN
POLICY MAKERS CAN HOLD OIL
COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE IF THEY
NEED TO SEE RATE PRICES FOR
CONSUMERS. CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS'S ERR FAIR PRICE DOES
NOT INEXPLICABLY HIGHER MARGIN
OUT THESE OTHER STATE. THAT. WE
ARE. YEAH THANK YOU. YOUR
COMMENTS. WILL NOW TO- ANY
SPEAKERS TO SUPPORT HERE IN THE
GALLERY AND- COMMITTEE ROOM.
ANYONE OKAY WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES A MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
Q. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR IT SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO ME PRESS THE
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE'LL
WE'RE LINE FOUR OH SIX GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL BROWN ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA INTO PORT
THANK YOU. NEXT PICKER. THANK
MISTER WE HAVE LINE THREE FORTY
NINE. HE TALKED FOR THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WEEK- LINE
ONE EIGHTY THREE. THIS IS JOHN
POTTER CLEAN FOR KIDS ADORE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER. TWO
EIGHTY FIVE. HELLO I'M NOT FOUND
THAT OR MAPS CALIFORNIA I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL MORE
TRANSPARENCY THE BETTER FOR THE
CONSUMERS THANK YOU. PRITCHETT
YOUR COMMENTS THE NEXT SPEAKER.
FOR TWELVE. HI A THREE SEVERITY
MORE FROM OUR PARK AND I THINK
WITH THIS BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
BIGGER. THREE TWENTY FIVE. LIME
THREE TWENTY FIVE EUROPEN. SHE
WILL MOVE THE THREE TWENTY TWO.
ANDREA VEGA FROM FOOD AND WATER
WATCH- IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THEY'RE NOT FOR THE LINES IN
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT OKAY NOW WILL
GO TO SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION WE
HAVE AN ORGANIZED. PRESENTATION
LED BY ZACHARY LEARY WHAT THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION MISTER
LEERY YOU HAVE NINETY SECONDS.
GREAT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS THAT CLEAR ON BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION. RESPECTFULLY TAKEN
UP OPPOSITION TO THE SP THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO OF THE BILL IS
SEEKING DATA THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN ANALYZED BY THE CDC AND
FOUND NOT TO BE THE CAUSE OF
ENERGY PRICE INCREASES IN
CALIFORNIA- WE BELIEVE. THIS
BILL THE NECESSARY BECAUSE DATA
COLLECTION AND- STATUTORY
OVERSIGHT ALREADY EXISTS IN THE
EARLY EIGHTIES THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED PYRO THE PETROLEUM
INDUSTRY INFORMATION REPORTING
ACT. WHAT ARE- WHO'S ON THAT WAS
ONLINE. KEEP KEEP UP HIS
SPEAKING. TO ALLOW THE CC TO
ANALYZE AND RESPOND TO SHORTAGES
OR OTHER DISRUPTIONS IN THE
PETROLEUM- MARKET- AND THEN
POWER ALSO ALLOWED CC TO HAVE A
THOROUGH UNDERSTANDING OF THE
OPERATIONS OF THE PETROLEUM
INDUSTRY ALL THE DATA THAT WAS
COLLECTED WAS COLLECTED UNDER-
CONFIDENTIALITY AS TO NOT GIVE A
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE THE
COMPANIES THAT WERE ACTUALLY
SUBMITTING THE DATA AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC- THE AG HAS
EXISTING AUTHORITY TO GO AFTER
ANTI COMPETITIVE BEHAVIOR AND-
TO. MARKET SPECULATORS. FOR THE
FIJI CURRENTLY HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO PURSUE THESE CASES- SENATOR-
REFERENCE THAT THIS HASN'T BEEN
ANALYZED THE CDC DID ANALYZE
THIS. IN TWENTY NINETEEN AT THE
CALL OF GOVERNOR NEWSOM THEY
CONCLUDED IN THAT REPORT AND ACT
OF QUOTA HERE WITH LITTLE OR NO
GROWTH DIFFERENCE IN THE UNITED
STATES IN CALIFORNIA REFINER
MARGINS WHICH IS WHAT SB THIRTY
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO IS GOING
AFTER. THE CVC CONCLUDES THAT
REFINER MARGINS ARE NOT THE
CAUSE OF RESIDUAL PRICE
INCREASES IN CALIFORNIA. OF FOR
THOSE REASONS WE MIGHT MISS A
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU NOW WILL
GO TO THE NEXT SPEAKER IT'S-
DAVID HACKETT WITH STILLWATER
ASSOCIATES. I BELIEVE IS ON THE
PHONE LINE MR HACKETT YOU HAVE
NINETY SECONDS. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MANY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DAVID HACKETT ON THE GERMAN
STOCK WATER ASSOCIATES LLC. THE
TRANSPORTATION ENERGY CONSULTING
COMPANY HEADQUARTERED IN ARMONK
. FORTY YEARS AGO TRANSPORTATION
ENERGY SPACE INCLUDING TWENTY
FOUR YEARS LEADING STILLWATER.
YOUR REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA MISSION- RESOURCES
FOR CALIFORNIA'S ATTORNEY
GENERAL AGENCIES FROM A NUMBER
OF OTHER STATES AS WELL AS US
DEPARTMENT ENERGY IN THE US
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
. I WAS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHOI MARK BARGER
COMMITTEE. WITH REGARD TO
TODAY'S ISSUE. THE GASOLINE SPOT
MARKET IN CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER
AND MORE VOLATILE THAN THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY THIS IS A
STRUCTURAL PROBLEM IT'S BEEN
WORKED OUT MANY CAR. HI SPOT
PRICES DRIVE UP BOTH WHOLESALE
AND RETAIL PRICES. TAXES AND
FEES ARE A LOT HIGHER HEARING
CALIFORNIANS AND THE DRAFT
OUTRAGE. FURTHER CALIFORNIA
DRIVERS HAVE PEER LOCATIONS TO
FILL OUT SOME DRIVERS IN THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY. ACCORDING
TO THE STILL WATERS ANALYSIS
THERE ABOUT TWICE AS MANY
DRIVERS PER STATION IN
CALIFORNIA THE US AVERAGE. IN
THE GASOLINE STATION POPULATION
THE QUAN. ONE EXPECT THE HIGH
PRICES WOULD ATTRACT NEW MARKET
ENTRANTS WHY TALK OUT OF STATE
RETAILERS LIKE WAL LONG SHE
SAID. WHAT COMING TO CALIFORNIA
I THINK ALL THE POINTS BECAUSE
OF OUR STATE UNFRIENDLY BUSINESS
CLIMATE. THE BOTTOM LINE HERE IT
ISN'T THAT THERE AREN'T ENOUGH
AFTER CALIFORNIA'S. KNOCKS NOT
LIKELY TO STICK TO CHANGE. THANK
YOU SIR APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. WILL NOW OPEN IT UP TO
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION HERE
IN THE GALLERY OR HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. ANYONE WILL GO
TO THE MIND SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO. TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN YOU HAVE A LINE OF NOT
BETTER IN JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
OUR OPPOSITION COMMENT COMES
FROM LINE FOR SIXTEEN. JERRY
MEMBERS JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE
UP CALIFORNIA GOLD COAST-
CALIFORNIA WILL BE CONVENIENT
CLIENT ALL THESE BUT I GET A
LETTER AND ON BY BUT WE ARE BOTH
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WHO-
NEXT BECAUSE- NO FOR THE LINES
IN HERE. OKAY THANK YOU- YOU
KNOW JUST THAT WOULD WHEN I
FIRST BECAME CHAIR OF ENERGY
HERE IN THE SENATE THERE WAS THE
EXPLOSION IN TORRANCE WE DID
ACTUALLY GO THERE AND DO AN
INVESTIGATION THERE WE ALSO
CONDUCTED- AND INVEST IN A GAS
PRICES STATEWIDE TOUR MET WITH
OF PEOPLE IN THE INDUSTRY AND I
AND I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW- IT.
YOU KNOW PERSONALLY IT WAS IT
WAS A DIFFICULT EXPERIENCE
BECAUSE- IT'S VERY HARD TO GET
INFORMATION IS CHAIR OF ENERGY
HERE IN THE SENATE. VERY HARD TO
GET DEFINITIVE ANSWERS ABOUT
WHERE THE PRICES- OF THE COSTS
WILL ACTUALLY COME FROM. THAT
WAS IN AND ENCOURAGE JEAN-
EXPERIENCE I DID I CAME TO MY
OWN CONCLUSIONS BUT I HIGHLY
DOUBT THAT THOSE CONCLUSIONS.
WERE ACCURATE BECAUSE WE THAT NO
REAL INFORMATION WAS PROVIDED-
TO EVEN LEGISLATORS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. WE KNOW THAT WHEN
THERE'S A DROUGHT AFFECTS
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION WE KNOW.
THAT THERE'S A SUPPLY AND DEMAND
WE KNOW WHEN WE I THINK WE'RE
WE'RE TELEVISIONS UNDERSTAND
SUPPLY AND DEMAND OF THAT
AFFECTS OF. PRICES BUT- BUT THE
I HAVE FOUND THAT ONE OF THE
MOST COMPLEX MARKETS IN THE
UNIVERSE IS PROBABLY EVERYTHING
HAVING TO DO WITH PETROLEUM
BECAUSE IS SO SECRET. AND IT'S
HARD TO IMAGINE THAT- YOU KNOW
SOME OF OFTEN THE CONDITIONS
THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH RISING
GAS PRICES. R. O. RESULT
ACTUALLY ROCK OR A RESULT OF
THOSE CONDITIONS BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IT'S NOT A
FUNCTION OF WEATHER PATTERNS
IT'S NOT A FUNCTION NOT EVEN OF
WARS I MEAN WE KNOW THAT EVEN
DURING WARS. OF THE IN SOME
CASES I MEAN I UNDERSTAND IF
THEY START PLAYING FIELD TONIGHT
I UNDERSTAND THAT IF- EXTRACTION
IN CERTAIN AREAS COMPLETELY COME
TO A HALT. AND IF THAT'S
MEASURABLE THAT WOULD DEFINITELY
HAVE AN IMPACT. ON ON ON DEMAND
ON A SUPPLY. BUT WHEN NOTHING IT
IS SIX AFFECTING THE SUPPLY
CHAINS IT SEEMS TO JUST TO HAVE
A THIS VERY CAPRICIOUS EFFECT ON
PRICES AND I THINK PEOPLE
DESERVE TO KNOW WHAT THAT IS
ESPECIALLY WHEN MANY. ARE
COMPLETELY DEPENDENT ON THIS
RESOURCE FOR THEIR DAILY LIVES
THIS IS- AT ONE POINT IN HUMAN
HISTORY SALT WAS CONSIDERED ON
AN ISSUE OF NATIONAL SECURITY
I'VE- BEEN TROLLED HIM. HIS IS
ONE OF THOSE COMMODITIES THAT IS
THAT RISES TO THE LEVEL OF
NATIONAL SECURITY WE FIGHT FIGHT
WARS OVER IT THERE ARE.
CONFLICTS RELATED TO ACCESS
UNIT. ABOUT FOR THE PEOPLE IN
OUR STATE MANY ARE DEPENDENT
UPON THIS FUEL SOURCE TO CONDUCT
THEIR DAILY LIVES AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE REALLY NO ALTERNATIVES
FOR MANY PEOPLE. AND SIMPLY
ASKING A DISCLOSURE I DON'T
THINK WOULD AFFECT- COULD COME
COMPETITION BETWEEN. OIL
COMPANIES AND IF IT DOES LET'S
LET'S INVITE A HEALTHY
COMPETITIVE ENVIRONMENT. IF IT I
DON'T I DON'T I DON'T BUY THAT
ARGUMENT I THINK IT'S A SIMPLY A
FUNCTION OF- AN INDUSTRY THAT
HAS A PROTECTED STATUS IN TERMS
OF. DISCLOSURES OF A OF A OF A
COMMODITY IS A SO IMPORTANT. TO
THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF THE
PEOPLE OF OUR OF OUR STATE THE
NUMBER COUNTRIES SO I DON'T
THINK THIS IS AT ALL- AN EXTREME
BILL I THINK IT'S- A VERY
REASONABLE BILL WE WE'VE HAD
TESTIMONY SAID IT'S BEEN DONE
BEFORE IF IT'S- IF IT'S BEEN
DONE LET ME SHARE IT WITH THE
PUBLIC LIFT PEOPLE. OF THE
COMMUNITY MAKE UP THEIR OWN
MINDS AND LET THEM UNDERSTAND
WHERE WHERE OF THIS. THIS THESE
CHARGES ARE COMING FROM IT'S
JUST BEEN- THE SADDEST THING FOR
ME TO EXPERIENCE THIS DEBATE
ABOUT OIL PRICES BEING ALL ABOUT
TAXES YET TAXES. CONTRIBUTE TO
THE COSTS. DEFINITELY BUT THE
CONVERSATION SHOULD BE LIMITED
TO TAXES IT SHOULD BE LIMITED TO
EVERYTHING ELSE. WENT WHEN THE
COST IS. FIVE TO SIX DOLLARS A
GALLON AND TAXES NEVER INCREASED
. WHERE IS THAT CONVERSATION
HAPPENED IN OUR STATE AND WHO IS
BEING HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
AND CAN CONSUMERS- WHO WHO CAN
CAN CONSUMERS GO TO ASK FOR SOME
KIND OF HELP- RIGHT NOW IN
AMERICA NOT JUST IN CALIFORNIA
BUT IN AMERICA AND THERE'S NO
WHERE PEOPLE CAN GO ESPECIALLY
IF THEY'RE DEPENDENT ON THIS. A
RESOURCE AND- I CAN'T IMAGINE
THAT THIS IS A COORDINATED
EFFORT I DON'T REALLY BELIEVE IT
IS BY THE OIL COMPANIES BUT AT
THE SAME TIME. SOMETHING IS
HAPPENING THAT IS COMPLETELY
UNFAIR. THAT IS TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF A SITUATION THAT'S HAPPENING
WORLDWIDE. AND WHILE PEOPLE ARE
COMING TOGETHER AND- RALLY IN.
AS AS AS A COUNTRY BEHIND. AN
EFFORT. BEHIND THE INITIATIVE SO
IMPORTANT TO US TERMS OF
FIGHTING FOR DEMOCRACY OR
FIGHTING FOR. A NATIONAL
SOVEREIGNTY ACROSS THE WORLD I
MEAN PEOPLE ARE STEPPING UP AND
I JUST SEE THAT. WELL COMPANIES
ARE NOT THEY ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE SITUATION IT
SEEMS THAT'S WHAT IT SEEMS LIKE.
IT MAY NOT BE IN IF IT'S NOT
WE'D LOVE TO HEAR WITH THAT
EXPLANATION IS THAT WE ALWAYS
GET. THE SAME EXPLANATION THAT
THIS DOESN'T SEEM TO MAKE SENSE
. ANYWAY THAT WAS A LONG SPEECH
ON THE SUBJECT I'LL I'LL I'M
SURE EVERYONE WANTS TO MAKE A
COMMENT I'LL START WITH SENATOR
MEN. AND IF THERE'S ANYONE OUT
OF HAND SO I KNOW THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK- OKAY I WAS RIGHT.
SO WE'LL GO TO CENTER BECKER
CENTER DOLLY CENTER BURGESS AND
I FOR STUFF. YES OKAY- I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BEFORE I APPRECIATE THE
GOALS OF THIS BILL I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT AS- MENTIONED. TRY TO
GET THE- SENATE. YES IMPORTANT
GOAL BUT I DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS BILLS THAT EXPRESS
THE AUTHOR. I STARTED MY CAREER
AS AN ATTORNEY FOR SPENT
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION OF THE
SECURITIES EXCHANGE COMMISSION-
AND I KNOW ALL TOO WELL THE
DANGERS OF COMMODITIES MARKET
MANIPULATION. I HAVE CONCERNS
IT'S THIS AT A PRETEND TO BE AN
EXPERT IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM
. OIL AND FUTURES AND DRIVEN-
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
THE SPOT MARKETS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- BOUGHT HOUSING LOC
SUGGESTS AS AS THE LAWSUIT OF A
- WE'LL SEE A CALIFORNIA BE THE
TALL AT ALL SUGGESTS. I THIS IS
A VERY PARTICULAR AS MARKET IT'S
A SOMEWHAT THIN MARKET IT'S ARE
CLEARLY VULNERABLE TO PRICE
MANIPULATION. IN SOME OF THE
DATA THAT THAT MIGHT BE
DISCLOSED THEIR AT THE CONCERN
HAS BEEN RAISED BY THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THAT. IT COULD ALLOW
FOR- YOU KNOW. PERHAPS LESSEN
SCRUPULOUS. OUTSIDE TRADERS TO
TRY TO MANIPULATE THESE MARKETS-
AND SO I THAT CONCERNS RAISED ME
I WOULD I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS IT SENATOR AND
THAT YOU'VE BEEN COMMITTED TO
TRYING TO. ADDRESS THIS AND I
KNOW SOME OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS HELP IN THAT REGARD
I'M A KEEP AN EYE ON THIS- AND I
WANT TO LISTEN THE REST OF THE
BAIT- I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO
THE RIGHT THING BUT I JUST WANT
EXPRESSED THAT CONCERN THAT I
HAVE. BECAUSE YEAH WE HAVE TO BE
CARE. THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF A BILL LIKE THIS
AND- IF IT ENDS UP LEADING TO
MORE MARKET MANIPULATION. THAT
THAT CLEARLY IS NOT WHAT WE
WANT. NO QUESTION. DID JUST
RESPOND AMERICA WHAT YOU. BEFORE
YOU GOT HERE. WE DID TALK ABOUT
HOW- HOW THIS THE DAY THAT WE'RE
ASKING FOR IN THIS BILL IS DATED
OF THE FIFTY WELL COMPANIES.
SHARED IN THE PAST WITH THE
STATE CALIFORNIA AND STOPPED HE
STATED THAT THEY DISCLOSE TO
THEIR- SHAREHOLDERS LIKE THE
PUBLICLY TRADED COMPANIES AND
IT'S ALSO. DATA THAT IN VARIOUS
FORMATS WELL COMPANIES ARE
CURRENTLY SHARING AND PUBLICLY
DISCLOSING A NUMBER OTHER
AMERICAN STATES. AND AS YOU
MENTIONED I DO THINK THE-
DEMANDS- HERE TO HELP WITH WITH.
WITH WITH WITH IN CONFORMITY
WITH AND MARKET BUT TO CONCERNS
NOT BUT I PREFER COMMENTS AND
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO THIS IS
TRICKY RIGHT THIS IS VERY TRUE.
FEELINGS ZERO DOCTORS THOUGHT
WITH THE GOING TO THE THIS.
WE'RE JUST TRYING TRYING LIGHT
ON IT AND- TRYING TO. GET THIS
IN A PLACE WHERE. WHERE TAX
GONNA GET TO THE- THE GOALS AND
NOT CONTRIBUTE TO MARKET
MANIPULATION. OKAY SIR DALY.
WELL FIRST I WANT TO JUST SAY
THAT- GOSH WERE START THIS THIS
IS A BIT COMPLICATED PERSONAL
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO I THINK
THAT. I MEAN ANYBODY THAT IS RUN
A BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA AND I
KNOW THAT. THERE'S NOT  LOT OF
LEGISLATORS THAT DO A PAYROLL
EVERY TWO WEEKS AND ACTUALLY.
MANAGE A BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA
SO I WANT TO SHARE SOME FACTS
WITH YOU IN THIS THIS IS. JUST
ACROSS THE BOARD. CALIFORNIA HAS
THREE HUNDRED NINETY SIX
THOUSAND REGULATIONS. BUT NOT
FOR OIL WAIT UP FELLOW YEAH
THERE'S A LOT FOR AND THE
CLOSEST STATE TO US IS NEW YORK
WITH A HUNDRED THOUSAND LESS SO.
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE START OF
THE END BUSINESS ENVIRONMENT IN
CALIFORNIA AND THOSE OF THOSE
REGULATIONS RULES COMES OUT OF.
THIS LEGISLATURE OVER. EVERY
YEAR THERE'S A THOUSAND A
THOUSAND NEW LAWS PASSED THE
SEMI GONNA DEAL WITH. SO WE TALK
ABOUT OIL IN CALIFORNIA AND
GASOLINE AND WE HAVE- SPECIAL
BLENDS. WE HAVE ALL KINDS OF
THINGS AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
SAYING YOU'RE TAKING ALL THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION. BUT ALSO SET
ON SUB TO. WHERE WE HAVE WE TALK
ABOUT A THOUSAND WELLS SITTING
AT CAL CHEN READY TO BE
PERMITTED THAT THE OIL COMPANIES
ACTUALLY PAY FOR THE REGULATORS
TO OUT REGULATE. AND THEY'RE NOT
GETTING RATE THEY'RE NOT GETTING
OPENED UP. SO WE START TALKING
ABOUT OIL AND FOR SOME REASON.
OIL IS LIKE. THE ANTI CHRIST
AROUND HERE. CABALLERO CAME IN
FRONT OF OUR COMMITTEE WE CAN GO
TRYING TO DO CARBON CAPTURE AND
THEY WANT TO SAY NOPE YOU WE CAN
DO EVERYTHING BUT OIL. WHAT SO I
KNOW AND WE'VE SEEN IT IT THE
PRESIDENT UNITED STATES IS
TALKING ABOUT COMPANIES ARE
GOUGING BECAUSE INFLATION IS
GOING UP THAT'S B. S. THE REASON
WE HAVE INFLATION IS COULD WE
STOP TROOP FOUR TRILLION DOLLARS
INTO OUR ECONOMY. AND YOU YOU IF
YOU'RE GONNA PLACE AND WHEN YOU
DO THAT. NATIONWIDE I'M IN
BUSINESS I AM GETTING THE DIRECT
EFFECTS OF. THE INFLATION IS
DRIVING UP AND I HAVE TO PASS
THAT COST ON AND THAT'S WHAT'S
DRIVING UP EVERYTHING IS NOT
GOING TO GO AWAY ANYTIME SOON NO
MATTER. WHO'S MAKING PROFITS ARE
NOT. SO I THINK THAT WE NEED IS
YOU KNOW FOCUS MORE ON HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY DRIVE THE COST DOWN. WE
DON'T PRODUCE MORE THE WAY YOU.
THE WAY IT HERE AT HOME. THE WAY
YOU DRIVE THE COST DOWN TO
SUPPLY AND DEMAND WHICH THAT
WHICH CHAIR TALKED ABOUT. I'M IN
THE C. BUSINESS. THE ONLY TIME I
REALLY MAKE MONEY IS WHEN
SOMEBODY ELSE LOSES MONEY.
BECAUSE WE SEE WHAT I WHAT I
MEAN BY THAT THE WEATHER
SOMEWHERE CHANGED. BECAUSE WE
PRODUCE PLENTY OF FOOD. BUT THE
TIME I ACTUALLY MAKE MONEY IS
WHEN THERE'S A DROUGHT SOMEWHERE
ELSE WHETHER SOME FLUCTUATIONS
NOW IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE IN
CALIFORNIA. WHEN YOU HAVE TO
DOLLAR GALLON FUEL HIGHER THAN
ANYWHERE ELSE YOUR LETTER GRADES
ARE HIGHER. YOUR YOUR- WAGES ARE
HIGHER ALL THE SINGER OF
CALIFORNIA YOU'RE COMPETING
AGAINST OTHER STATES. IN THIS
CASE FOR OIL IT'S THE RATE WE
HAVE SPECIAL BLENDS. SO I THINK
WE NEED TO DO WE DID YOU KNOW IF
YOU WANT TO GO AFTER THE OIL
COMPANIES YOU WANT TO BLAME. THE
END OF THE DAY WE NEED MORE OIL.
AND WE CUT TALK ABOUT WINNING
HIM OFF THEY GOING TO ELECTRIC
CARS. IN OUR GREAT ISN'T SET UP
TO DO THAT SO IT'S SUPPOSED TO
COME OUT WHEN YOU SIT DOWN TO
SEE HOW WE CAN REALLY GET THERE
AND WHAT WHAT'S THE- WHAT'S THE-
YOU TO LOOK LIKE. WE'RE DO THAT
WE SET GOALS AROUND HERE WE-
FORCE THEM TO DO. ALL KINDS OF
REGULATIONS. AND THEN. WHEN THE
PRICE GOES UP AND THEY MAKE SOME
MONEY TO STAY IN BUSINESS. YOUR
WERE FRUSTRATED WITH THAT. YOU
CAN'T. RUN A BUSINESS WITHOUT
MAKING A PROFIT. IN ANY CASE- IF
YOU'RE A CALIFORNIA RUN A
BUSINESS YOUR PROFIT MARGINS ARE
GETTING THINNER AND I KNOW THAT
BECAUSE MINE ARE IN MY BUSINESS
AND IS DUE BECAUSE- THOSE
POLICIES IS THERE SO YOU WANT TO
GO HAMMER ON THE PRICE IS GOING
TO GO UP BUT ABOUT A BUSINESS
SEE WHAT HAPPENS. SO I'M JUST
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE THE FACT OF
THE MATTER IS WE ALWAYS GOING TO
BLAME SOMEBODY IT'S UKRAINE IT'S
ALWAYS SOMEBODY TO BLAME BUT OUR
OWN POLICIES THAT COME OUT OF
THAT DRIVE THE COST OF LIVING UP
IN CALIFORNIA'S ACROSS THE
BOARD. CENTER BAKER. I DON'T
BLAME YOU JUST. MENTIONED YES
THANKS I WAS JUST GONNA SAY THAT
I WAS SYMPATHETIC TO THE
CONCERNS OF INDUSTRY ABOUT DATA-
REVEALING CONFIDENTIAL BUSINESS
OPERATIONS AND POTENTIALLY
ENABLING MARKET MANIPULATION AS
WE DISCUSSED- IT DOES LOOK AT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- HAVE
CHANGED THAT TO KEEP IT
CONFIDENTIAL SO- THAT WITH THOSE
CHANGES THAT YOU PLAN TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY. THANK YOU SIR
BORDERS. WHY I'M REALLY HEARD
FROM MY COLLEAGUES IN THIS IS BY
HIS BILL WHILE DAY THIS BUILDING
- BREVARD BODY- I AGREE WITH
WITH MANY THINGS THAT WERE SAID
ON BOTH SIDES OF THIS ISSUE-
FROM- CENTER DALLY THAT YOUNG.
YOU CAN YOU CAN EXPECT WHAT WE
DO IN THIS BUILDING TO NOT
IMPACT WHAT OCCURS IN THE
MARKETPLACE AND THE OVERALL
CALCULUS OF DOING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA NO WAS UNDER ANY
ILLUSION THAT CALIFORNIA IS A
PRO BUSINESS STATE- THERE ARE
DESIGNATED- WINNERS. AND THEY'RE
CERTAINLY. DESIGNATED LOSERS-
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I HAVE A
SOFT SPOT WHEN INDIVIDUALS ARE
LOOKING INTO MATTERS ON THE
MERITS. AND IF THERE IS A IF
THERE IS A TRUE INQUIRY TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT WHERE THE
CHOKEPOINTS ARE THAT ARE
EXAGGERATING THE COSTS OF FUEL.
I THINK THAT COULD BE HELPFUL TO
FIND THE PROBLEM IS I DON'T
NECESSARILY TRUST. THE
CONFIGURATION OF WHO WOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT INFORMATION AND
HOW IT WOULD BE ASSEMBLED SO YOU
KNOW I HAD CONVERSATIONS AND-
YOU ARE A MAN OF YOUR WORD AS A
LEGISLATOR IN A PERSON- BUT I
WOULD I WANTED TO THROW THIS OUT
THERE MAYBE YOU CAN COMMENT ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT I HAD I
BROUGHT UP TO YOU IS.
CONFIDENTIALITY WE'RE TALKING A
PUBLICLY TRADED ENTITIES WE'RE
THE REFINEMENT COSTS. ARE
ESSENTIALLY PROPRIETARY PIECES
OF INFORMATION. THAT CAN BE
EXPLOITED BY MANIPULATOR AS WE
HEARD FROM SENATOR MAN EARLIER.
THAT YOU CAN'T JUST **** NILLY
THROW OUT PROPRIETARY
INFORMATION INTO THE PUBLIC
DOMAIN AND NOT EXPECT THERE BE
TO BE ADVERSE CONSEQUENCES. AND
SO WE'RE IS THERE A REASONABLE
PATH FORWARD- WE HAVE A HISTORY
AS LEGISLATORS. OF FINDING
COMMITTEES. OR TASKING
INDIVIDUALS IN A THINK TANK
FORMAT WHETHER BE- THROUGH THE
AUDITOR OR WHETHER IT BE THROUGH
SOME OTHER EXISTING DIVISION OF
THE STATE TO LOOK INTO THESE
CHECKPOINTS IT'S SUCH AS
REFINEMENT. ASSOCIATES ALSO AND-
PUMP- SELLERS IT'S THE A TO Z.
OF WHERE ARE THE INFLATIONARY
CHIP- CHOKEPOINTS. BECAUSE YES
RUSSIA HAS EXAGGERATED THE COSTS
YES UKRAINE HAS EXAGGERATED THE
COSTS. BUT SO HAS REGULATION IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE OBSCENE
OVERHEAD- TAXES THAT WE THAT WE
PLACE ON THIS INDUSTRY. SO IT'S
MORE OF AN INCREASE TO YOU. HOW
WOULD YOU REALISTICALLY SPLIT
THIS BABY IN SUCH A WAY THAT.
THE INDUSTRY FEELS THAT
INFORMATION IS PROTECTED AND
THAT THE MERITS OF THIS ISSUE
ARE BEING LOOKED AT. ODD IN
EARNEST. SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
FIND OUT WHERE THESE WERE THESE
VITAL PIECE OF INFORMATION ARE.
SO MANY THROWED OUT TO YOU IS
THERE IS THERE A PATH FORWARD I
JUST DON'T KNOW YEAH SO THE
COMMITTEE AMENDS- DELETE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THERE BE
REFINERY SPECIFIC INFORMATION SO
WORKS A WEEK SO WE WOULD- WE
WOULD TAKE THE VISIT THE VIEW OF
THIS ISSUE UP TO TEN THOUSAND
FEET SO THAT THAT SHOULD TAKE
AWAY A GOOD DEAL THE MARKETPLACE
CONCERNS THAT ARE THERE- THAT'S
ONE THING I WOULD SAY. I WOULD
ALSO SAY THAT A LOT OF THIS
INFORMATION IS ALREADY DISCLOSE
IN VARIOUS FORMS- IN OTHER
PLACES IT WAS ALREADY IT WAS
DISCLOSED IN THE PAST IN
CALIFORNIA- THE MORE YOU HAVE
SOME OF THE FOLKS WERE INVOLVED
THIS BILL FEELS THAT THEY
STOPPED DISCLOSING IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE- THEY WERE MAKING EXTRA
MONEY HERE. THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY
I'M I'M NOT MAKING THAT
ASSERTION I'M NOT BLAMING THEM
RIGHT I MEAN WHAT THIS BILL IS
OPENING UP ABOUT. HOW TO GET
MORE DISCLOSURE SO WE CAN HAVE A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S
ACTUALLY GOING ON THERE'S ONE
ARGUMENT TO BE MADE THAT THIS
IS. LARGELY ALL HAPPENING AT THE
RETAILER'S SITE IS AT THE GAS
STATIONS AND IF THAT'S REALLY
TRUE LET'S SHOW THAT TOO BUT BUT
ULTIMATELY THIS IS AN ISSUE YOU
WITHIN YOU BRING UP TAXES DROPS
RIGHT IT'S A LOT OF MONEY. BUT
THAT'S QUANTIFIABLE. OUT THERE
FOR ANYONE TO SEE THAT THERE'S
OTHER MYSTERY SURCHARGE THAT IS
THAT THAT THAT WE KNOW IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S. PAYING OUR PAIN
RIGHT THATTHE GHOST WHAT IS
BEING CHARGED IN OTHER STATES
THAT THAT THAT THAT THAT IS
THERE EVEN WHEN YOU TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT OUR SPECIAL BLEND EVEN
WHEN YOU TAKE INTO ACCOUNT OUR
GAS TAX THAT'S ALL LAID OUT BY
BY PROFESSORS BY BY DATA
SCIENTISTS HAVE BEEN STUDIED. A
PRETTY CONSIDERABLY. SO ALL
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS JUST
GET SMART ITS DISCLOSURE ON THIS
ISSUE- I MEAN I HEAR YOU MAY
MAYBE YOU WANT TO RE FRAME IT-
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THERE THERE
ARE. ARE YOU FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE- THE- DIRT THERE
MORE TOOLS WE CAN GIVE THE CDC
AND THE IN THE DOJ. I TOOK TO
GET MORE ACCESS TO INFORMATION
THE SPACE AND YOU KNOW DEPENDING
ON WHERE. THIS BILL GOES I'M I'M
REALLY INTERESTED IN EXPLORING
THOSE AVENUES- ALL RIGHT PART OF
WHAT THE BEAUTY THAT TOO MANY
PROCESSES YOU GET THESE ISSUES
OUT WE FLUSH THAT WE ALL TALK
ABOUT IT AND- AND WE KIND OF SEE
WHERE THESE. WERE THESE BILLS
GO- MOVING FORWARD- THAT SO I'M
OPEN TO LOTS OF DIFFERENT
AVENUES HERE BUT IN THE END OF
THE DAY. I YOU KNOW THIS THIS IS
A DISCLOSURE BILL IT'S ALL ABOUT
TRYING TO. IN A IN A IN A FAIR
WAY- MORE INFORMATION TO THE
PUBLIC AND TO REGULATORS SO WE
CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
GOING ON- AND IN THE END OF THE
DATE WITH SO MUCH RESPECT TO
SENATOR YOU KNOW IT'S IT IS
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE
SUFFERING THE MOST WITH HIGHER
ENERGY COSTS AND THERE AND THERE
ARE SO MANY FACTORS AT PLAY
THERE'S NO QUESTION. SOME OF SO
MUCH OF IT IS REGULATORY I'M I'M
NOT DENYING THAT BUT THERE'S BUT
THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE GOING ON
HERE TO. THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE
GOING ON HERE TOO. AND THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S
DEMONSTRABLE. ALL RIGHT SO- WHY
WOULDN'T THIS BE FASHIONED AS A
COMMISSIONED THING TANK
INVESTIGATION. BECAUSE THE IDEA
OF PUBLICLY DISCLOSING IT
PRESUPPOSES THAT THERE'S NO
VARIOUS ACTIONS A PLAY. AND THIS
ONEROUS MONTHLY THING- THE IDEA
WOULD BE TO KIND OF WE GOT WE
GOT A MOMENT IN TIME THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO USE IT AS A
SAMPLE. COULDN'T POINTSTREAK BE
REVEALED WITHIN A SIX MONTHS OR
ONE YEAR- PERIOD OF TIME- DATA
ASSEMBLY. SO YOU'RE SAYING TO
CREATE SOME SORT OF. PASK FORCE
OR BEEF UP THE EXISTS FOR
STRUCTURE AND SEE YOU SEE THAT
IS SOME SOMETHING THAT ACHIEVES
WHAT YOU WANT BECAUSE IF WHAT
YOU WANT IS TO FIND OUT WHERE
THOSE POINTS ARE. THAT I THINK
COULD BE SMARTER AND MORE
EFFICIENT FOR US- TO A CHOIR THE
INFORMATION IN THE IN CAMERA
CONFIDENTIAL WAY. BECAUSE I WAS
GOING TO OPPOSE THIS OUT OF THE
GATE THE FACT THAT IT WAS GOING
TO BE INITIALLY THE ORIGINAL
DRAFT WAS PUBLIC DISCLOSURE LIKE
YOU'RE GOING TO JUST CREATE- A
GENIE OUT OF A BOTTLE- TYPE
SITUATION. BUT LISTEN I'M ONLY
I'M ONLY ONE PERSON I'M SORRY
I'VE TAKEN UP SOME REAL I AM NOT
ONLY ONE AT THIS POINT EXPRESS
YOUR VIEWS OR MAYBE ASK OUR YOU
KNOW YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET THE
BILL HERE. WELL AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT I THINK. YOU COULD
COULD BE DONE IS THAT IF THIS
WERE IN A THINK TANK FORMAT. IN
CAMERA. MEANING THAT THERE'S NO
DISCLOSURE OF ANY INFORMATION
AND IT'S WITHIN A REFINED PERIOD
OF TIME- I THINK THAT WOULD BE
IT IN EFFECTIVE WAY TO DO IT TO
MOVE FORWARD IN AND I'VE YOU. IF
IT WERE TO GO IN THAT EVOLUTION
IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE- I THINK
YOU KNOW THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING
THAT- I COULD PROBABLY GET ON
BOARD WITH. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR COMMERCE
FOR THERE'S NOBODY ELSE JUST.
LOOK AND AT. SERTOLI WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON BECAUSE WE GOT WE GOT
MORE BILL STAY HERE. AND WE
STILL HAVE LIMITED TIME OF. OKAY
WOULD YOU TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION NOT THE ALL THE
REGULATORY FEES THAT ARE NOT
THAT ARE JUST BUSINESS HAS TO
HAVE THE COST OF WHAT THE COST
OF PAYROLL TAXES ALL THE THINGS
IN CALIFORNIA DO WE PAY HIGHER
THAN ANYWHERE YOU THAT'S ADDS
INTO THAT EQUATION THAT THAT
THAT NEED TO BE TAKEN IN THE
FIRST IT SHOULD BE CAN USERS
ABSOLUTELY AND- YOU SEE OKAY
THAT'S FINE YES. GO AHEAD BUT-
LET'S LET'S MOVE FORWARD. AND
I'LL LET YOU MAKE YOUR- COMMENTS
BUT THE WHAT WHAT WORRIES ME
ABOUT THE DISCUSSION IS THAT.
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE IT SEEM
LIKE YOU KNOW THESE ARE MY-
SHOPS. AND THAT THAT OUR OUR
REGULATIONS ARE CAUSE FOR THE-
THE PRICING. AND THE TRUTH IS I
MEAN THESE ARE COMPANIES A LOT
OF THEM ARE NOT BASED IN
CALIFORNIA YOU CAN'T ATTRIBUTE
THAT COST. TO COMPANIES I MEAN
THESE ARE COMPANIES THAT MAKE UP
A FOUR HUNDRED BILLION DOLLAR.
INDUSTRY WORLDWIDE THAT
REPRESENTS THREE POINT 8% OF THE
ENTIRE WORLD ECONOMY. SO WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT MOM AND POPS
THAT ARE AFFECTED BY ANY STATE
REGULATION IN PARTICULAR YES OF
COURSE. THERE AFFECTED I THINK
SOME MOST REGULATIONS CALIFORNIA
PERTAIN TO SAFETY AN EXTRACTION
IN THE ENVIRONMENT. IN TERMS OF
MY EXPERIENCE HERE BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE LARGEST. OIL COMPANY
EREMENKO THEY'RE NOT EVEN FROM
CALIFORNIA AND THERE ARE MASSIVE
IF YOU CONSIDER EXXON IS NUMBER
TWO ON THE FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED
LIST. AND THEIR THIRD IN THE
WORLD LIST I MEAN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT EREKLE BRIDGE PETROLEUM
EXXON CHEVRON THE CERTAIN SET
OF. COMPANIES THAT HAVE A HUGE
MARKET SHARE THAN SHOULD HAVE
SOME LEVEL. OF COMMUNITY
RESPONSIBILITY WHEN THE MANAGER
RESOURCE THAT REALLY CONTROLS
THE ENTIRE WORLD ECONOMY WE'RE
NOT ASKING FOR A LOT WITH THIS
BILL. AND WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR
INFORMATION THAT'S EVEN
PROPRIETARY BUT- I THINK PEOPLE
NEED TO GET MORE INFORMED IN
TERMS OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
STATE AND HOW THIS RESOURCES
MANAGE POLITICALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY IN OUR COUNTRY SO
I'LL LET YOU MAKE. I OF THE
CREATURE DOT MY COMMENTS AS YOUR
CLOSING COMMENTS AND WANNA MAKE
SOME ADDITIONAL ONES FEEL FREE
THANK YOU I DO VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION I I'M
AND I SAW YOU RAISE YOUR
EYEBROWS WE SET UP A FRAZIER I
THINK HE'S AFRAID OF THE FACT
THAT IN VARIOUS FORMATS THESE
ARE THE STATE IS ALREADY BEEN
DISCLOSED IN OTHER IN OTHER
STATES- I LOVE THE KIA COMES
ISSUE CENTER I. APPRECIATE WHERE
YOU'RE GOING WITH THIS I THINK.
YOU'RE GETTING YOUR GETTING THE
CORP OR TRY TO GET OUT WITH THIS
BILL- THE END OF THE DAY. NOPE
NO MATTER WHAT. VERSION IT ENDS
UP ON THE FLOOR AND THE OTHER
HOUSE. WE WOULD WANT IT TO BE
SOMETHING THAT ULTIMATELY IS
ABOUT. SHINING LIGHT ON ON ON ON
THIS THIS. THIS THIS. MAKE THIS
DELTA THIS GAP THAT EXISTS
BETWEEN OUR PRICE AND OTHER
STATES EVEN WHEN YOU TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT. ALL THE REGULATION THE
GAS AND EVERYTHING- THE TAX
EVERYTHING ELSE. AT GIVE ME
OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP WORKING ON
THIS AND- I RESPECT YESTERDAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET SO WE'LL
KEEP. PLUGGING ALONG. WE'LL GO
TO SENATOR BECKER AND S. B.
ELEVEN TWELVE YOU CAN PRESENT
FROM. YOUR DESK DIESS OVER YOU
CHOOSE. I MEAN THE PODIUM OR THE
DIENSTE REACHES. W. EVERYTHING
EVERYTHING IS STILL GOING ON IN
THE AIL ABOUT. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS-
THIS BILL ONE ONE TO SUPPORT THE
CREATION OF THE TERRITORY BILL A
FINANCING THE INVESTOR PROGRAMS
WAY TO MAKE LOW COST OF CAPITAL
FOR CLIMATE BENEFIT THE UPGRADES
WIDELY AVAILABLE SET UP FRONT
COSTS WERE LACK OF ACCESS TO
CREDIT TO NOT GET THE WAY OF
IMPROVING OUR BUILDINGS AND
FINANCING OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
QUITTER PORTABILITY COMPOSITION
COALITION PROXY SIX MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS FOUR MILLION WHICH
ARE LOW INCOME LACK READY ACCESS
TO PRIVATE CAPITAL FOR A GREENER
HOMES CLIMATE. BENEFICIAL
APPLIANCES. REBATES CAN HELP
LOWER UPFRONT COSTS BECAUSE WE
STILL NEED ACCESS TO CAPITAL
FUND. THE BALANCE WE'RE LOOKING
AT UTILITY TERRIFYING BILL
INVESTMENT NOT PROGRAMS OFTEN
CALLED PAY AS YOU SAVE. CORRECT
UTILISING CALIFORNIA DO NOT
OFFER THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS
BUT THE PC IS AN ONGOING PROCEED
CONSIDER AVAIL ACCESSIBLE
FINANCING OPTIONS LIKE THIS
INTELLICHECK SPECTER TO PROPOSE
THAT TEAR FROM BILL PROGRAMS-
ANY DAY THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S IN
THE FINANCING IN ADDITION IF WE
PASS THIS BILL TODAY. THIS CAN
BE A GREAT WAY TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE CAN AFFORD TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS UPGRADABILITY LOWER
THEIR COSTS. THIS BILL AIMS TO
ENCOURAGE THE CREATION THIS
PROGRAM SO MAKING SURE THAT
PROPER KITCHEN PROTECTIONS ARE
IN PLACE. THEY'RE TO PARTS THE
BILL THE FIRST REQUIRES PROPER
NOTICE TO NEW BUILDING OWNERS OR
ANY RENTER'S SAID THEY'LL KNOW
THEY'RE TAKING OVER EXISTING
OBLIGATIONS TO BE HIT THE TO
PAY. THE COVER CHARGE INITIALLY
BEFORE THEY DECIDE TO BUY RENT
FOR THE BUILDING. SECOND THE
BILL DIRECTS THE CCD DEATH BY
FEDERAL FUNDING AND- HOMES THAT.
IS RIGHT LOW COST FINANCING. TWO
TERRIBLE ON BILL INVESTMENT. LOW
COST FINANCING IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE OF MAKE THESE BUILDING
UPGRADES MORE AFFORDABLE. WITH
LOWER COVERAGE CHARGES ON THE
MONTHLY UTILITY BILL. A GOOD
EXAMPLE KIND OF FUNNY LIKE TO
SEE THE STATE TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
OUR THE LOAN GUARANTEES OFFERED.
BY THE US DEPARTMENT RG UNDER
THE BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL THAT PASSED LAST YEAR.
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM BUILDINGS WHILE
KEEPING ENERGY COSTS AFFORDABLE
IS GOING TO BE A MONUMENTAL
CHALLENGE. THIS BILL WILL HELP
BY ENABLING. AFFORDABLE AND
EQUITABLE FINANCING TO EVERYONE
CAN ACCESSIBILITY IMPROVEMENTS
FOR CLEANER AND HEALTHIER HOMES.
THAT WITH US TODAY TESTIFIED OF
HOMES HUMBLE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CLEAN ENERGY WORKS. AND
JASMINE ALLEN PROGRAM MANAGER.
FOR SILICON VALLEY CLEAN ENERGY.
OKAY WILL BEGIN WITH HOMES
HONNOLD YOU'VE GOT NINETY
SECONDS. AND I BELIEVE IS ON THE
PHONE LINE SO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
HOMES PUMMELED LIKELY DIRECTOR
OF ENERGY WORKS A PUBLIC
INTEREST ORGANIZATION WITH A
MISSION TO ACCELERATE INVESTMENT
IN THE CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY ALL.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN TWELVE
PRINTABLE NEXT STEP IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STORE FALL
AT THE FEET. IT WHAT ARE THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
REPORT ON BARRIERS FACED BY LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES IN THE CLEAN
ENERGY ECONOMY. AND RECOGNIZING
THE FINANCING IS A BARRIER THE
COMMISSION RECOMMENDED THAT YOU
TOLD ME REGULATORS APPROVED THE
INTRODUCTION CARE ON BILL
INVESTMENT. ALL FOX AT THE CLEAN
ENERGY UPGRADES. IN ORDER TO
ENABLE THE FATE OF INCLUSIVE
DISABILITY INVESTMENT. THE
FOURTEENTH. LAWMAKERS HAVE ALL
ENACTED WHY BILLS BACK AS TWELVE
THIRTY THREE ISSUE THAT PROPERTY
ON WITH FINALLY NOTED THAT THE
LOCAL WATER UTILITY HAS PAID FOR
SITE SPECIFIC INVESTMENTS FOR
WHICH IT WOULD RECOVER ITS COSTS
THE SITE SPECIFIC CHARGING A
BILL THAT IS LESS THAN THE
ESTIMATED SAVINGS RESULT GREAT.
ELEVEN ALL THE. SCENE A SPECIAL
MECHANISM FOR TRAINING. IN WHERE
EVER IT MAY BE NEEDED FOR
SIMILAR PROGRAMS OFFERED BY
ENERGY UTILITIES ARE STILL LOVIN
TWELVE ALSO CALLED ON C.
AGENCIES TO COLLABORATE IN
EXPLORATION OF CAPITAL SOURCES
FOR THE CLEAN ENERGY UPGRADE WE
KNOW WITH EMPHASIS BUT THE
FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT AND JOB ACT RECENTLY
AUTHORIZED THE US DEPARTMENT.
ALL IF. GUARANTEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR DISSIPATION FROM THE
STATE ENERGY FOR YOUR
INTERESTING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO JESSAMINE
ALAN WITH THE SILICON VALLEY
CLEAN ENERGY AND I BELIEVE SHE'S
ON THE LINE TO- PLEASE BEGIN YOU
HAVE NINETY SECONDS. THANK YOU
FOR THEIR BACKER OFFERING AT
ELEVEN FALL INVITING US TO
TESTIFY TO THE PORT OF THE BILL
I AM LOOKING BALLOT IN ENERGY IF
YOU SEE A TO PROVIDE CLEAN
ENERGY FOR RESIDENTS. AND
BUSINESSES SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
CELEBRATING HIGHER. ALL NETWORK
BUILDING RETROFITS THE KEY
STRATEGY AND I THINK. FIFTY THE
CARBONIZATION STRATEGY ROADMAP.
THE DALLAS EFFORT NEED A VARIETY
OF. FINANCE PEOPLE MAKING
HARMONIZATION INVESTMENT MORE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE. A FEW
FEET OF COLLABORATING WITH THE
UT TECH INITIATIVE ON A PAIR ON
BILL FINANCING PILOT FOR HOW THE
FINANCING TOOL HELP MAKE
ELECTRIFICATION PROJECTS MORE
FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE SB ELEVEN
TWELVE WOULD HELP IMPLEMENTOR ON
BILL FINANCE. THANK YOU URE THE
OWNER HAD AN ARM FORMED AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE CARBONIZATION
CHARGING A TIMELY MANNER SB
ELEVEN TWELVE ALSO HELP THE
DIRECTED BE EASY TO IDENTIFY
STATE FEDERAL BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION PROGRAM HELLO
SERVING ENTITIES LIKE FTP THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SUPPLY FOR
STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDING. THIS
WILL HELP SKILLED PILOTS LIKE
THE CARE PUMP- FINANCING ONE
THAT I FIFTY IN SUPPORTING
PRETTY REASON WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE SB ELEVEN
TWELVE THREE THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. AT I'M
HERE IN THE ROOM HELLO LIKE TO
SPEAK IT'S- PURCHASE MIGHT THANK
YOU MY NAME IS KATHERINE. ON
BEHALF CINEMA POWER WE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. IS
MEMBERS READ ON BEHALF OF THE
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
COALITION IN SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU VERY GOOD ANYONE ELSE OVER
THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR PLEASE
Q. SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN TWELVE. THE CHECKOUT LADY
THE GOVERNMENT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE IMPORTANCE OF SB. ELEVEN
TWELVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER IN
PLACE YOU BACK Q. WHAT WE GET IF
YOU WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF.
S. B. ELEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE ARE NOW. THANK YOU
MEDICARE NOT FIRST LINE WILL
COME FROM THE LINE OF LINE THREE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JANET **** FOR THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. NEXT BIGGER. LIE
NUMBER FOUR ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME FOR ELEVEN
SEASONS. MY NAME'S LAURA HAIDAR
A SUPPORT. FOR THANK. I DON'T.
THANK YOU LINE NUMBER THREE
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LIE NUMBER THREE TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ANOTHER GREAT
MEMBER OF FIND THAT FOLDER WITH
THE WHITE IMMIGRANTS ON BEHALF
OF EAST BAY COMMUNITY ENERGY AND
STRONG SUPPORT AS- A LOT TWELVE
THE YOU. NEXT BIGGER LINE NUMBER
LINE NUMBER THREE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NEXT BIGGER
AIRCRAFT DENNIS ON BEHALF OF
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA IN THREE
FIFTY VERY AYE ACTION IN SUPPORT
OF SB ELEVEN TWELVE THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER FOUR THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MARYLAND ABOUT THE
LOS ANGELES FIVE WITH THREE
FIFTY DOT ORG ALSO- I WOULD LIKE
TO ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE. YOU
VOTE YES ON SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX WE WILL CANYON GAS
STORAGE FACILITY NEEDS TO BE
SHUT DOWN THANKS FOR THE HELP OF
THE PEOPLE LIVING. IN THAT AREA
TOO MANY PEOPLE GOT AFFECTED
MANY PEOPLE DIED. THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING. NEXT BIGGER. LIE
NUMBER THREE THIRTY THREE THREE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
VERY WELL I NUMBER THREE THIRTY
OKAY. THEN WE DO HAVE ONE OTHER
PERSON IN CUBA MEDICARE. AND MY
NUMBER FOUR OH THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS CHARLES FRANCIS FROM ROHNERT
PARK CALIFORNIA. I'M HONORED
SUPPORT- NEED SIX SPECIALLY
SECTION THREE CONCURRENT. OF THE
TOTAL CAN I BELIEVE THAT THE
UNTIL THAT HAPPENED THERE THAT
SHOULD NOT HAVE RUN BILLS
CERTAIN AND RUN BILL RUN BILL-
SURE WE'RE ON THE ITEM NUMBER
NINE ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT- WERE
ASKING FOR SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
OF ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT. NO START
ONE ONE ONE ONE TWO I'M SORRY
ONE ONE ELEVEN TWELVE AT ELEVEN
TWELVE- THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WANT
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN TWELVE. ELEVEN TWELVE
ONLY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION
ANYONE. WISH TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS. I'M SORRY WE'RE GOING
TO OPPOSITION ANYONE OTHERS NO
ORGANIZED PRESENTATION
OPPOSITION ANYONE HERE IN THE
ROOM IN OPPOSITION. MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT. WELL I'M AGAIN ELEVEN
TWELVE SORRY. I'M ALREADY IN THE
NEXT A COMMITTEE CHAIR. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION S. B. ELEVEN
TWELVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER. IN PLACE
IN THE QUEUE. AGAIN IF YOU WANT
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF F. B.
ONE ONE ONE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THING THERE ARE NOW. LINE NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN
FOR IT HE LEVIN WELL. MY NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY FIVE. OH SORRY I WAS
FOR OKAY IN MY THE BILL ALL
RIGHT OKAY WE'RE GOING TO VOTE
YEAH OKAY MODERATOR ELEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU LINE
NUMBER THREE FIFTY ONE SB ELEVEN
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE.
THREE FIFTY ONE. NO RESPONSE
LINE NUMBER FOUR ELEVEN THE LINE
IS OPEN. MY NAME FOR ELEVEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS LAURA HAGER I
SUPPORT VOTE YES FOR A- PETER
LEVIN FONG THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
. AT THE TIME OF THE CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU OKAY
VERY WELCOME NOW WILL COME TO
THE COMMITTEE IF THERE'S ANY
COMMENTS- WE HAVE NONE SO DID
YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS AND REQUESTS FOR A
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
CAN'T BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM WE'RE WAITING FOR QUORUM-
TRYING TO GET IT NOW. SENATOR
STERN YOU'RE NEXT I ACTUALLY
CENTER BECKER ITEM NUMBER NINE
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT RELATED TO.
ELECTRICITY SUPPLIERS THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS AT HEART THIS IS
A SIMPLE IDEA WE SEKARANG HOUSE
GAS TARGETS FOR OVER ELECTRICITY
SUPPLIERS. BUT WE HAVE NOTHING
IN PLACE TO MEASURE HOW WELL
THEY'RE DOING AGAINST THOSE
TARGETS. THIS BILL FIXES THAT
GAP IT DIRECTED CC TO ESTABLISH
RULES FOR ELECTRICITY SUPPLIERS
TO ANALYZE OUR SOURCES WHAT
TRICITY AND REPORT. ON THE
ASSOCIATED GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THAT CAN MEASURE
PROGRESS HELLO EVERYONE
ACCOUNTABLE TO DOING THEIR FAIR
SHARE TO REDUCE EMISSIONS. HOW
WE TRACK ELECTRICITY SOURCES AND
MEASURE MISSIONS IS VERY
IMPORTANT HISTORICALLY THE MOST
LOOKED AT HOW MUCH CLEANER YOU
USUALLY PURCHASED OVER ENTIRE
YEAR. COMPARED TO THE LOAD
DURING THAT YEAR. BUT AS WE GET
HIGHER AND HIGHER PERCENT OF
CLEAN ENERGY THIS LONGER MAKES
SENSE THE GREAT HAS TO BALANCE
SUPPLY AND LOAD MINUTES A
MINUTE. NOT ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
A COUPLE EXAMPLES ARE MOVING
QUICKLY INTEREST OF TIME BUT
GOOGLE WAS A PIONEER IN THINKING
ABOUT THIS DIFFERENTLY. IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THEY RIDE TO
THE GOAL POWER 1100% RENEWABLE
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS. BUT THEY
REALIZE THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK
TO DO. SO THEY SET A HIGHER
TARGET FOR THEMSELVES TO
UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH ENERGY WAS
COMING FROM CLEAN ENERGY
SOURCES. WITH ALLIES ON A TIME
MATCH SPACES OUR OUR- THEN
IMPROVE ON THAT YOURS. IT'S A
CLEAN ENERGY BUT ONE OF OUR
SPEAKERS WILL COVER THIS. BUT
THEY'VE BEEN A PIONEER IN THIS
AREA AS WELL. THEY FOUND THAT
THE G. G. INTENSITY OF THEIR
PARRIS FIFTEEN TIMES HIGHER WHEN
MEASURED MORE ACCURATELY OUR OUR
THEN MEASURED USING ANNUAL
ASSUMPTIONS. AND THE P. C. ALSO
WISELY CHOSE TO USE ARE REALLY
ANALYSIS FOR LECTURES THE
SUPPLIERS AND THEIR- ASSOCIATES
GHG EMISSIONS AND IN THE R. P.
PROCESS. THE R. P. PLANS ARE
HOWEVER JUST FORECAST WE NEED TO
KNOW WHAT IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING
. BUT THIS BILLS ONLY BY
STABBING A FAIR AND ACCURATE WAY
TO MEASURE HARD ONE IS DOING SO
WILL TRANSPARENTLY WILL HAVE
TRANSPARENCY IN AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. IT'S NOT ABOUT
CREATING NEW TARGETS. I WANNA
CLARIFY ONE PIECE WHICH IS THIS
BILL IS NOT CHANGING THE POWER
SOURCE CLOSER PROGRAM OR THE
POWER CONTENT LABEL THE ORIGINAL
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. INCORRECTLY
REFERRED TO PRIVATE VERSION THAT
WOULD HAVE ALTERED THOSE A
PROGRAMS. THEIR NUMBER OTHER
DETAILS HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT HOW
EXACTLY THESE REPORTING RULES
SHOULD WORK. AND HOW MUCH DETAIL
SHOULD BE LEFT THE CECE'S WERE
MAKING PROCESS DEFINE. I
APPRECIATE COMMITTEE SPORTS DAYS
WE CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE. A LOT.
I WAS THREE I BOOKED BUT WE HAVE
GOT A FREEMAN FROM TURN HERE AND
THEN ON THE PHONE CHEN PEPPER CO
PENCIL CLEAN ENERGY. SO I HAVE
ARMOND COHEN IS A JOINT CHEN
PEPPER. YEAH CAN BE. I WELL
ABOVE CONVENTIONAL SIR WITH MATT
FRIEDMAN HERE IN THE ROOM OKAY
JEFF- MATT YOU HAVE NINETY
SECONDS SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE OUR MONEY IS
NOT FRIEDMAN HERE REPRESENTING
TURN THE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK
HERE TO OFFER STRONG SUPPORT FOR
SB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT. THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE ENERGY
COMMISSION TO COLLECT AND
PUBLISH DATA ON THE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AT EACH RETAIL A
LOOKS AT SELLER OF ELECTRICITY.
IN A MANNER THAT TRACKS ACTUAL
HOURLY PURCHASES OF BOTH CLEAN
AND DIRTY ENERGY TO SERVE
CUSTOMER NEEDS. I'M THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ALREADY
REQUIRES LOAD SERVING ENTITIES
TO FORECAST HOURLY PROCUREMENT
AN HOURLY DEMAND AS PART OF ITS
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING
PROGRAM. AND THIS APPROACH IS
DESIGNED TO EVALUATE PROPOSED
SUPPLY PORTFOLIOS BUT THE PC
DOESN'T ATTEMPT WAS HAS WHAT
ACTUALLY OCCURRED OVER TIME.
THIS BILL WOULD REMEDY THE GAP.
BY REQUIRING ONGOING COLLECTION
OF HOURLY DATA. TO CREATE
MEANINGFUL BENCHMARKS FOR
EVALUATING BOTH FUTURE
COMMITMENTS AND PAST PROMISES.
SB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT WILL ALSO
DIRECT THE ENERGY COMMISSION
MAKE A LONG OVERDUE UPDATE TO
THE EMISSIONS FACTORS APPLY TO
SO CALLED UNSPECIFIED POWER THAT
CAN'T BE TRACKED ANY INDIVIDUAL
GENERATING UNITS. THE CURRENT
PRACTICE OF THIS GOAL GEN ERIC
GHG EMISSIONS FACTOR IN EVERY
OUT PARTY SUNDAY IT HASN'T BEEN
UPDATED TWO. OF TWO OF REFLECT
UP IN GREAT. OVER THE LAST
FOURTEEN YEARS. WE BELIEVE THAT
THE IN RELATE TO ELEMENTS OF
THAT. WOULD PROPERLY DAPT
CALIFORNIA PH DISCLOSURE
FRAMEWORK TO THE REALITY OF
GROUP OPERATIONS AND THE
PARTICULARS ACTUAL PROCUREMENT
BY RETAIL SUPPLIERS IN THIS
EVOLUTION WOULD PROMOTE CONSIST.
BETWEEN VARIOUS PROGRAMS AND
ENSURE THE PUBLIC IS ABLE TO
ACCESS MORE ACCURATE AND UPDATED
INFORMATION. THE OVERALL
GREENHOUSE GAS THANK YOU MISTER
FRIEDEL SUPPLIERS TO RESCUE-
COPPENS. WILL GO TO ARMAND COLIN
NOW THIS ON PHONE. LINE. NINE
THIS IS OUR INCOME ON THE SECOND
DIRECT CLEANER CAL FORCE AND I
TO- INDICATE OUR SUPPORT PRESSED
THE ELEVEN TO EIGHT THIS BODIES
OCCUR TREND TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
CARPENTRY ACCOUNTING WE'RE
SEEING AROUND THE WORLD- AND
COMPANIES LIKE LIKE GOOGLE AND
MICROSOFT STARTED THIS RENT
UNITED NATIONS- AND SO IT IS
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN CARBON FREE
ENERGY COMPACT NOW ENGAGES SIXTY
SIX COMPANIES ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE TAKEN THIS PATH THE BIKE IN
MINISTRATIONS ADOPTED THIS
APPROACH OF TWENTY FOUR SEVEN-
CARBON POLLUTION FREE ENERGY BY
TWENTY THIRTY- HALF OF WHICH IS
TO BE SUPPLIED BY TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN DEMANDS. HOWEVER L. WOULD
PROVIDE A VALUABLE MEASURE
PROGRESS TOWARDS TRUE CLEAN
ENERGY AND PROVIDE ALSO AN
IMPETUS TO THE FULL RANGE OF
STORAGE DEMAND MANAGEMENT IN
GENERATION TECHNOLOGIES THAT
WILL ULTIMATELY BE NECESSARY TO
MEET THE GOALS OF SB ONE HUNDRED
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT
THE BILL MORE GLAD TO WORK WITH
THAT CENTER BACK AND OTHERS TO
IMPROVE IT- IN TAKING TO ACCOUNT
COMMENTS DECEIVED. REAL CLEAN
ENERGY ENERGY USE AND ESOS
REPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS WILL COME TO. MEMBERS
OF- THE PUBLIC HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM FOR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS DAN
JACOBSON SENIOR ADVISOR IN BURMA
CALIFORNIA STRUCK. THANK YOU. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
FENSTER MAKER ON BEHALF OF
PENINSULA CLEAN ENERGY I THANK
THE SENATOR AND A STAFF OF THE
TIME THEY GAVE US WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. WHO ELSE ANYONE ELSE WILL
GO TO- NOW. A MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WHICH WE WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT ON THE PHONE LINES.
A MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SUPPORTERS
OF ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT. THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF ELEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. LINE FOR THIRTY ONE NINE
OR THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOUR THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE NEXT BIGGER PLEASE.
GOING ON THE LINE FOR THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR
THIRTY FIVE. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THAT'S WHERE A LOT
OF WITH ON THE CENTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT BIGGER PLEASE I
AM FOUR THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FOR THIRTY SET. MELISSA
ROMERO WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT
. NEXT PLEASE FIVE FLORAL AFFECT
LINE IS OPEN FOR ALL SET.
SKINNER BROWN ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA COURT.
THANKS NINE FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR THIRTY
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN THE PHILADELPHIA CRANE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
ENERGY STORAGE ALLIANCE SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN FOR FORTY. THE FAN
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND REIMAGINE COUNCIL
IN ORDER AT THE EIGHT EIGHT PM.
NINE THREE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN THREE FORTY NINE.
JACKPOT THREE FIFTY THOUSAND
BALLY IN SUPPORT. NINE THREE
SIXTY EIGHT ALIVE IS OPEN THREE
SIXTY EIGHT. SHOW ME ALL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY TRADE
ASSOCIATION I WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT WE WERE OPPOSE
ALL THE ANALYSIS ON WHAT WOULD
BE AMENDED ON APRIL EIGHTEENTH
AS WELL THE EVERYTHING IN OUR
OFFICE- WE HAVE MOVED TO OUR A
REASONABLE PROPOSITION WE'RE NOT
COMPLETELY FORGET.
THANK YOU. THANK OR LAVENDER
LINE IS OPEN FOR ELEVEN. BROWN
HAIDER FROM FRESNO I SUPPORT
THIS BILL. FIND FREE THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN THREE THIRTY. RALPH
DENNIS ON BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY
EIGHT AREA INTRICATELY BAY AREA
ACTION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FOR TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD
EVENING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE DOLLARS FURLA
BARKER PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
COMPANY WE HAVE A SUPPORT YES
AMENDED POSITION- AND- WE
SUPPORT THE CONCEPT OF OUR
REALLY MISSIONS REPORTING THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS SHOWN LEADERSHIP
ON WE APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
THAT HIM TO STOP AND GIVE ME A
GUN. ON THE BILL AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK PARTY- TO
ADDRESS THAT REMAINING CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ANY OTHERS LINEBACKER. YEAH
LINE FOR THIRTY FOUR YEAR IS
OPEN MORE THAN THIRTY FOUR. GOOD
EVENING BILL MURPHY ON BEHALF OF
OTHERS CLIMATE ACTION CALIFORNIA
IN CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT
SILICON VALLEY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
REAL PROTECTIVE. HE RICH MILLION
THE HALF OF THREE FIFTY SMOKING
VALLEY AND ELDERS CLIMATE ACTION
IN NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
FORTY CLEAR LINE IS OPEN FOR
FORTY TWO. HELLO THIS IS DIANA
WINE AND CHAIR OF THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
CHAPTER CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU EIGHTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO EIGHTY FIVE
. YES UNDER THOMPSON ROSA
CALIFORNIA I DO SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. AND MINE FOR FORTY THREE
YOU'RE OPEN FOR FORTY THREE. HI
MY NAME IS CHRISTOPHER ALICIA
I'M CALLING FROM CEMEX HELP. AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELLS.
AND THERE ARE NO OTHER LINE
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU WILL GO
TO THE LEAD OPPOSITION-
PRESENTATION BY PATRICK WEALTH
WELSH YOU YOU HAVE- THREE
MINUTES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
PATRICK WELCH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THE
STATE'S PUBLICLY OWNED ELECTRIC
UTILITIES AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. WE APPRECIATE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
AND HIS SHAFT AND HIS STAFF AND
WE SHARE THE AUTHOR'S INTEREST
IN PROMOTING CLEAN. DISPATCHABLE
AND RELIABLE RESOURCES THAT
PROVIDE ELECTRICITY DURING
DIFFICULT TO SERVE TIMES SUCH AS
DURING THE EVENING PEAK. CMA IS
ACTIVELY WORKING WITH THE STATE
ON IMPLEMENTATION OF S. ONE
HUNDRED AND MANY PEOPLE USE ARE
ALSO WORKING WITH THEIR LOCAL
LEADERSHIP I'M PLANS THAT
FURTHER REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM
THE GRID. THE DASCHLE HOURLY
EMISSION DATA REQUIRED BY S. B.
ELEVEN FIFTY IN OUR OPINION AS A
NECESSARY BECAUSE IT IS ALREADY
WELL KNOWN THAT THERE ARE
DIFFICULT TIMES A DAY TO
DECARBONISE THE GRID. SEARCHES
DURING THE EVENING PEAK WIND
SOLAR STOPS PRODUCING. THE KEY
CHALLENGES NOT MORE DATA THE KEY
CHALLENGES DEVELOPING COST
EFFECTIVE DISPATCHABLE AND
RELIABLE CLEAN ENERGY
TECHNOLOGIES THAT DON'T EXIST AT
SCALE TODAY. AND THAT'S WHY
SENIOR A SUPPORTING THE
GOVERNOR'S TWO BILLION DOLLAR
CLEAN ENERGY BUDGET PACKAGE
WHICH INVEST IN LONG DURATION
ENERGY STORAGE AND GREEN
HYDROGEN. CMA'S MEMBERS RT TRACK
REPORT GHG EMISSIONS THROUGH
EXISTING MECHANISMS THERE'S VERY
OVERSIGHT FROM THE STATE ON OUR
PS COMPLIANCE WE HAVE TO
PARTICIPATE. IN THE CONTRACT
PROGRAM AND- RETIRE ALLOWED TO
DO THAT SO THERE ARE A TON OF
OVERSIGHT IN ADDITION TO THE
LOCAL ELECTED OVERSIGHT. AFTER
MEETING CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
TODAY. A NEW GHG REPORTING
PROGRAM AT THE CC TO COLLECT I
REALLY GHG EMISSIONS BY
GENERATING RESOURCE WOULD BE
BURDENSOME ESPECIALLY FOR
SMALLER PEER USE. AND WILL
REQUIRE SUBMITTING TENS OF.
PLANTS THIS WILL TO. TIME FROM
THE CORE MISSION OF PROVIDING
CLEAN AFFORDABLE AND RELIABLE
ENERGY. AND I JUST WANT TO KNOW
IN CLOSING. THAT YOUR OF YOUR
GHG EMISSIONS ELECTRIC SECTOR
HAS BEEN REALLY THE SHINING
BEACON AND THE STATE. OUR
MEMBERS IN ELECTRIC SECTOR HOLE
HAS REDUCED EMISSIONS BY MORE
THAN 40% SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX
MORE THAN ANY OTHER SECTOR IN
THE STATE. AND THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO SEE EMISSION
REDUCTIONS BUY THE BEST WAS THAT
THEY'RE MAKING TODAY. OUR
MEMBERS WANT TO KEEP FOCUSING
THEIR EFFORTS AND LIMITED
RESOURCES PUBLIC AGENCIES. ON
THOSE EFFORTS OF REDUCING
EMISSIONS AND NOT NOR REPORTING
BURDENS. AFFORD IF THEY'RE JUST
IS ABOUT HIS OFFICE THE
COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF. I'VE
BEEN PASSED BY SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC AUTHORITY TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION DAYS
WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL GO TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE COMPUTER
ROOM ANYONE. THANK YOU CATHARINE
BRANDENBURG ON BEHALF OF CINEMA
CLEAN POWER WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR IN ITSELF ON
THIS. AND THAT AT THIS TIME WE
MUST STILL OPPOSE THE BILL AS
INSTRUCTED THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WHICH CHAIR MEMBERS
GREG COOK REPRESENT NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION FOR. OKAY
NEXT OF ANYONE ELSE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR PLEASE
Q. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION LAM
FIFTY EIGHT. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
IN OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
THEREFORE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN OR FORTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHURCH MEMBERS OFFERED
A MEDINA CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE INTERROGATION DISTRICTS
OFTEN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
ANYONE ELSE NEXT QUICKER. I'LL
BE JUST ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GET
THEIR NUMBER. NINE FOUR FORTY
SPECTER LINE IS OPEN FOR FORTY
THIRD. HELLO TRICKERY YEAH I'M
SUPPORT OF SB. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIX. THERE ARE NO OTHER LINE
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL COME TO THE COMMITTEE-
FOR COMMENTS WHAT WERE DO BEFORE
THAT- WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM
OUR CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PRESIDENT WESSEL PRESENT DALI.
DALI HERE BAKER YOUR BAKER HERE
FORTUS. BRADFORD DODD EGGMAN
EGGMAN HERE GONZALEZ GROVE
HERTZBERG YEAH HERTZBERG HERE
REQUIRE. MCGUIRE HERE MAN MAN
HERE RUBIO. STERN STERN HERE FOR
YOU HAVE A QUORUM. FEDERATED YOU
ARE PRESENT ON A LOT THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SIX OUR INVOLVEMENT HERE
TO FINISH THIS. OH I'M SORRY
WE'RE GONNA COME BACK TO CLOSING
COMMENTS. DR OF OKAY GOOGLE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR STERN CLERK PLEASE CALL
VOTE. AND YOU ARE ACCEPTING
AMENDMENTS JUST TO BE CLEAR YEAH
. YES ONE O'CLOCK RAIMES EXACTLY
COMMITTEE MEHMET'S AND THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SB ELEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR BAKER DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WESSEL. AYE WESSEL HI DOLLY.
GOLINO BECKER. BECKER I FORGES
BRADFORD DON EGGMAN EGGMAN HI
GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE REQUIRE REQUIRE
AYE MIN WHEN I RUBIO STERN KERN
I. SURE SEVEN EIGHT EISEN WHEN
OKAY LOOK AT THE ROLE OF THE FOR
UP SOME MEMBERS NOW WILL GO TO
ITEM TEN SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX
CENTER CERTAINLY 1% FROM YOUR
CHAIR THE FOR THE- YEAH. IF YOU.
COULD DO THAT WAS A LONG MAN I
WAS GONNA. WOULD YOU CAN SECOND
. MISTER CHAIRMAN. THE BOSTON
GALLAGHER YEAH WHEN WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM CENTER HERTZBERG FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WINDOW. OF
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CONSENT CALENDARS FOR SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO BY CENTER
WESSEL. WESSEL HI WESSEL HI
DOLLY. KELLY HI BAKER. OR JUST.
BRADFORD DODD EGGMAN EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ GROW HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG I REQUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
MAN MAN I RUBIO STERN ALL RIGHT
STERN I. SEVENTIES OKAY WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SINISTER PLEASE
BEGIN WITH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR BEFORE BEGIN ITS ONE TO
NOTE THAT WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- AND- THERE
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE FOCUSING ON
C. C. STRATEGIC PROCUREMENT
PLAN- AND IDENTIFYING. THROUGH
APPROVED I APPEASE REMOVING THE
REFERENCE TO AN ANNUAL
PROCUREMENT TARGET- MEMBERS THIS
THIS BILL IS REALLY AN EFFORT TO
GET THE ENERGY COMMISSION I
ENGAGED IN A MORE SUBSTANTIVE
WAY IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
ONE HUNDRED- AND TO ACCELERATE
OUR ABILITY TO ACHIEVE OUR
CARBON NEUTRALITY GOALS BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. NEED TO GET
STARTED OFF ZERO CARBON BASELOAD
FIRM THE BILL HAS BEEN ORDERS-
SO- GREGORY COALITION HERE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE DID YOU
WANT TO HAVE YOUR SPEAKERS BIG
DAN DAN JACOBSON AND JIMMY JOHN
WHITE. THIS VERSION WAS STILL
HERE. YEAH OKAY I DON'T SEE HIM
AS DID YOU WANT TO HAVE JANE
JACOBS HIM SPEAK. THERE IS A
LIKE. A JUST A STRONG SUPPORT
THE BILL WE NEED PLANNING WE
NEED MORE RENEWABLES THANK YOU
OKAY APPRECIATED VERY MUCH. I
WILL GO TO- SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. SPEAKERS ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT. IT WAS GOOD BUT GETS
CAUGHT BUT NOT IN SUPPORT OF THE
ONLINE. PLEASE. FIVE ONE NINE
THIS TIME. OKAY WE'LL GO TO ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WE DO HAVE PEOPLE
QUEUING UP. I KNOW WHO IT IS GEN
I NEVER MIND OR FORTY TO FIFTY I
HAD. THIS IS DIANA WINE AND-
CHAIR THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
CLIMATE REALITY CHAPTER CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU OKAY WILL NOW MOVE TO
THERE'S AN ORGANIZED I HAVE A
MORNING HE'LL OKAY PLEASE CALL
THEM. THANK YOU A LINE TO FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
TWO FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD FOR SB ONE FOUR EIGHT
SIX NO. OKAY I'M I'M FOR THAT
ONE SYSTEM BY. PENITENCE NINE
FOUR FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
FOR NEXT ONE. PLAN FOR FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM FOR
FIFTY SO YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOUR
FIFTY TWO ONE. I DON'T REMEMBER
MOST WHEN WE HEAR COMPLEMENT.
THANKS FOR FIFTY FILL YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK. STOPPED MARKET.
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. AND THERE'S
NO ONE LEFT THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU WILL GO TO THERE'S AN
ORGANIZED OPPOSITION IS NIKOLINA
EVAN THE STILL HERE. ALTHOUGH
SHE HAS LEFT KEPT HOUSE ON
BEHALF OF ESTY GENIE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WE WILL REMOVE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
OKAY WILL WILL GO TO SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
. OF WE'LL GO TO THE MODERATOR
NOW FOR SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
AND PHONE LINES. FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION IT'S FIVE ONE NINE
ZERO. FOR THIRTEEN SAID THERE IS
SOMEONE IN HUE OKAY VERY WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. HONOR.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX. A MOTION
WE HAVE A MOTION TO JOIN MY
CLOSING COMMENTS ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE OKAY CLICK PLEASE CALL THE
VOTE. SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATOR STERN TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL I WAS
SO HI DOLLY. BAKER. GORGEOUS
BRADFORD DODD EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG HI
HERTZBERG AYE REQUIRE REQUIRE
AYE MAN RUBIO STERN ALL RIGHT
STERN I. FOR THAT BOOK THE BILL
HAS BIBLE OKAY S. AS IN A POSTED
YOU WANNA PRESENT I DON'T KNOW
FIVE SIX FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX
OKAY THE BEGIN. OKAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- FOR BEGAN AGE I
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT- THE
ANALYSIS- THERE SEVERAL
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT I WANT TO ACCEPT-
INCLUDING- DELETIONS OF NUMEROUS
SECTIONS OF THE BILL- SOMEONE
EXCEPT- THE COMMITTEES SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS- IN THE ANALYSIS- THE
CHAIR AND I'VE HAD SOME
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS BILL AND
I KNOW THIS IS A TOUGH TOPIC-
ITALY SO CANYON IS. A DRAWS A
LOT OF SENSITIVITIES. BECAUSE IT
IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT. A PART OF
THE ENERGY MIX FOR ALL SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO BECAUSE IT
HAS BEEN SUCH A DISASTER FOR OUR
COMMUNITY EVERYONE WHO'S STUDENT
SHADOW FOR FAR TOO LONG- SO THIS
BILL HOPEFULLY WILL BRING SOME
PLANNING IT'S IN PROCESS-
AROUND. AT LEAST- CANYONS
CLOSURE AND I DO APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK ON THE BILL- ON
THE AMENDMENTS- BUT I WILL SAY
THAT. THE BILL HAS TO MOVE
FORWARD THIS YEAR- WE FEEL THAT
THE PC DOESN'T HAVE ALL THE
TOOLS AT THEIR DISPOSAL TO BE
ABLE TO SEE THROUGH THE CLOSURE
WITHOUT REPERCUSSIONS FOR. RATE
PAYERS OR- WORKERS AND SO THIS
BILL IS AN EFFORT TO MAKE THAT
PROCESS IS FUNCTIONAL AND IS
STABLE AS POSSIBLE POSSIBLE AND
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE SUFFICIENT.
POWER PRODUCT LINE IN ITALY SO
STEAD- OF WRAP UP MY REMARKS
THERE AND CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE BUT
SINCERELY APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S
ATTENTION IN THIS MATTER I DON'T
THINK THIS IS JUST A DISTRICT
ISSUE I THINK IS AFFECTS ALL
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND WE CAN
WE CAN FIND A BETTER WAY FOR
THAN RELYING ON ON ASSETS THAT
PUT OUR COMMUNITIES AT RISK. YOU
STILL HAVE ORGANIZED A PETITION
SUPPORT JANE FOWLER AND IS FROM
THE NINETEEN- THERE ON THE LINE
OKAY OKAY I WOULD JUST AS MY-
BUT THEY'RE NOT. OKAY WELL WE
CAN WE CAN HEAR BRIEFLY I WOULD
JUST SAY PLEASE KEEP- THE
REMARKS BRIEF IF AT ALL POSSIBLE
HE SOME NOT JIM- FORM PRESENT
PORTER RANCH NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCIL- YOU'RE ON. YOU'VE GOT
THREE MINUTES. JANET THERE'S-
THE JUDGE DOWN THANK YOU YEAH
I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL THANK
YOU YEAH WE CAN TO HEAR
TESTIMONIES WHICH IN REAL TIME
NO WE DON'T. ISRAEL THIS THANKS
A LOT THOSE LIKE. WHEN YOU WERE
IN THE ASSEMBLY. COOL BLOOD OKAY
SO THERE IS NO- IS FROM THE GYM
WILL GO TO- SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
HERE IN THE GALLERY MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M HERE YEAH WE'VE
BEEN WAITING FOR YOU SIR. I
APOLOGIZE I'VE BEEN TALKING AND
REALIZED NO ONE WAS LISTENING.
IF I MAY YES PLEASE CLOCK'S
TICKING THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY MY
NAME IS ZEESHAN MEASURE MINE THE
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE PORT
ORANGE NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL THE
RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY. OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THE MOST IMPORTANTLY I'M
A FATHER OF THREE CHILDREN WHO
GREW UP IN THE SHADOW OF THE
LISA CANYON HEALTH IS AT. SINCE
OCTOBER TWENTY THIRD OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN I HAVE BEEN ENGAGED IN
ALL THE DEBATE ABOUT THE LEAST.
I WAS SPECIFICALLY ENCOURAGED BY
THE PC TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROCEEDING ON A LISA CANYON.
CREATED BY SB THREE EIGHTY. AND
I HAVE BEEN A PARTY IN THE
PROCEEDINGS SINCE ITS INCEPTION
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. BUT NEVER
IN MY WILDEST DREAMS DID I
IMAGINE THIS ALL CONSUMING
PROCESS WILL OCCUPY MY LIFE. AND
THE LIVES OF PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY FOR SEVEN YEARS AND
COUNTING. THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THANKS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY MY- RATHER THE
COUNCIL RENDON OF LOS ANGELES.
BLAM YOU MYSELF SIR. WE'RE GOING
TO. THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND THE LOS
ANGELES CITY COUNCIL VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY FOR THE FACILITY IS
NOT NECESSARY AND HAVE ASKED FOR
IT TO BE CLOSED IN THE NAME OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY YES
SOCAL GAS WANTS YOU TO BELIEVE
THAT THE FACILITY IS NECESSARY
FOR THE REGION. ADDING TIRE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES IS ASKING
FOR IT TO BE CLOSED BECAUSE I'S
NOT NEEDED AND SO AND SO OKAY
GAS IS LARGEST CUSTOMER THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES WANTED IT CLOSED
WHAT REGION SOCALGAS ACTUALLY
TALKING ABOUT. NO COMMUNITY
LARGE OR SMALL CAN FLOURISH
WITHOUT A HEALTHY AND SAFE
FAMILIES I URGE YOU TO DO THE
RIGHT THING BY THE PEOPLE OF LOS
ANGELES VOTE YES ON SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX. THAT APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. WE'LL GO TO SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINES.
DO WE HAVE ANY SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS OKAY. I'M SORRY- I WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IN
LINE FOR THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU FOR THIS GREAT
THEY'LL HAND THIS IS BILL MURPHY
ON SPEAK SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE PUBLIC CLIMATE ACTION
CALIFORNIA THREE FIFTY SILICON
VALLEY- REALITY PROJECT. SILICON
VALLEY IN SUPPORT. THE FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NORTH AMERICA
WITH CALIFORNIAN BERMAN
PROMOTERS IN SUPPORT. ORAL SEX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN A BROAD ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
IMPORT. FOUR FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THEN FOR A MOTHER WITH
THE CLIMATE INSURANCE WHAT. FOR
ALL FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
YOU KNOW I'M A GEOLOGIST AT CAL
STATE NORTH OF THIRTY FIVE OUT
THERE THAT THE FIGHT AND I MEAN
FOR TO FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX. FOUR
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS LAURA
ROSENBERGER HIGHER AND SECONDARY
INSURANCE NEEDS AGAINST ACTING.
WELL YES. THREE FORTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS THE
LEAST CALL PLAN REPRESENTING THE
GLENDALE ENVIRONMENTAL COALITION
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S. U.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX. THREE SIXTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
RESTLESSLY AND I'M CALLING FROM
MOORPARK CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THREE SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALL. THREE MINUS OPEN.
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. MOVING ON TO
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
TWO EIGHTY FIVE. YES SIGN IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE MY NAME
I'M NOT FOUND THEM I LIVE IN
CARMEL I THINK THAT IT'S ABOUT
TIME THAT CALIFORNIA YES THANK
YOU NEXT. HEALTH AND SAFETY OVER
PAST THE FEW. FOR WHAT FOR ONE
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR ONE TO
. HI I'M TERESA BRADY MMR PARK
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL. THREE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THREE THIRTY FIVE. I FOUR OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOUR OH
SEVEN. THIS IS SANDY EMERSON
FROM POSSIBLE FREE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THREE SIXTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PREFIX BEFORE. HI
THIS IS ME- MEMBER AND SUPPORTER
STATE PORTER RANCH LONGTIME
MEMBER AND THE BORDER OF FOOD
AND WATER WATCH AS HE THREE
FIFTY AND I SUPPORT HIS FELLOW
AND FOR EVERYONE WHO WAS TALKING
ABOUT HEIGHT BEGAN ON ALL THE
OTHER NONSENSE WE SHOULDN'T YOU
CAN PLEASE TELL EVERYONE PLEASE
REMAIN UNCLEAR LINE IS OPEN.
THREE NINETY TWO. HELLO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE NEW YORKER
SORRY- YES MY JOY MY LIFE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. FOUR FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR FORTY
TWO. DIANA WHY NINE CHAIR SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMB REALITY
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
. THREE SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN THREE SEVENTY FOUR. HI YEAH
MY NAME IS TERRY SUFFERING AND
I'M IN NORTHRIDGE AND I KNOW A
LOT OF PEOPLE NEGATIVELY
AFFECTED BY THIS LEAK IT WENT
MUCH FURTHER DOWN. NINE THREE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.%
THANKS FOR FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FOUR FORTY THREE. NINE
THREE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS RHONDA THANK RICHARD
WITH THE EMERSON YOU CHURCH IN
CANOGA PARK AND BY MIDDLE
JUSTICE MINISTRY STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT. FIND TO FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO FORTY
THREE. FIVE HEAR ME IF I HAD
OKAY YEAH MY NAME IS MATT BOOK
ON PRESIDENT AND CO FOUNDER OF
SAVE PUT AROUND A FIVE OH ONE
SEE THREE AND A FOURTEEN YEAR
PORTER RANCH RESIDENT WE ARE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX AND ASKING
FOR YOUR YES VOTE WITH THANK YOU
CAN I SPEAK INTACT THANK YOU
NINE THREE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THREE TWENTY FIVE. THE
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE NINE THREE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS NEIL REISMAN ON A
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES AND- I
BELIEVE THE HEALTH AD SAFETY OF
LA RESIDENTS SHOULD BE GIVEN
PRIORITY. OVER SO CAL THANK YOU
AND PLEASE LIMIT YOUR COMMENT
ITEM NAME AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE WE
HAVE A LOT OF SPEAKERS WE WANT
TO GET TO ALL OF THEM- MODERATOR
PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS. LINE THREE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
THREE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ROSE VAN
WITH WITH THE CAÑADA WHO CLIMATE
COALITION IN THOUSAND OAKS
CALLING TO SAY WE STAND WITH OUR
NEIGHBORS IN PORTER RANCH AND
URGING SENATORS TO VOTE YEAH
OKAY FIFTY ONE FOUR EIGHT OKAY
FOR THAT I KNOW THE RIGHT PEOPLE
ON THE LINE SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO IS TO TAKE NOTE. THAT THERE
ARE THOSE PEOPLE OPPOSING THE
BILL WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE THOSE
IN IT I'M SORRY SUPPORTING THE
TO ALSO REGISTER WITH OUR
COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
SO WE ALSO HAVE YOUR NAMES-
WE'VE GONE OVER ON TIME IN TERMS
OF FOR SUPPORT WE'RE GONNA-
ALLOCATE THE EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME FOR OPPOSITION WE'RE GONNA
MOVE OVER TO THE ORGANIZED.
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WE HAVE-
TWO SPEAKERS AT EACH GET NINETY
SECONDS. UP MATT BROAD AND CAN'T
COUNSELORS BROUGHT IN. THERE
OKAY AND SOME. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MAP RIGHT HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE UTILITY WORKERS UNION OF
AMERICA IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION- YOU KNOW JUST BY WAY
OF BACKGROUND WE REPRESENT THE
WORKERS IT SOMEHOW GAS- A
UNIONIZED EMPLOYER WALL TO WALL-
OUR OPPOSITION'S PRETTY SIMPLE
TO THIS BILL IT WOULD SHUT DOWN.
A FACILITY IN IN WHICH YOU KNOW
I DOZENS OF UNIONIZEDWORKERS-
MAKE A GOOD LIVING I'M IN TO US
THAT'S FRANKLY UNACCEPTABLE I
WOULD JUST ALSO ADD THAT THE PC
HAS BEEN PRETTY CLEAR THEY SPOKE
TO ABOUT SIX MONTHS AGO THAT
THERE IS A I STILL AN EXISTING
NEED. FOR A LEASE- CANYON I'M IN
FOR THOSE REASONS WE WOULD URGE
YOUR NO VOTE ON THIS BILL TODAY
THANK YOU. KHENTKAUS ON BEHALF
OF- SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS
COMPANY WE AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR
THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING SOME
PLANNING A PROCESS TO LOOK AT
THIS. WE ARE DOING EXACTLY THAT
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PROVED SB THREE
EIGHTY THAT LOOKED AT THIS EXACT
QUESTION. TO DETERMINE THE
FEASIBILITY OF MINIMIZING OR
ELIMINATING THE USE OF A LEASE
OF CANYON- IN THAT PROCEEDING
THE QC DETERMINED THAT THERE IS
A NEED THROUGH AT LEAST TWENTY
THIRTY ABSENT SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO DEMAND OR SUPPLY
WHICH HAS NOT HAPPENED YET. THE
CPUC ALSO ADOPTED PROTOCOLS
ORIGINALLY IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND THEY HAVE SINCE
ADOPTED UPDATES TO THOSE. AS
RECENTLY AS LAST YEAR LOOKING AT
COST AND RELIABILITY CONCERNS.
THERE'S AN ONGOING PROCEEDING
ADDITIONAL DECISIONS ARE
FORTHCOMING LATER THIS YEAR
PERHAPS BEYOND WE BELIEVE WOULD
BE A RESPONSIBLE TO. AVOID ALL
OF THAT DISCUSSION IS TAKING
PLACE IN THE PEWSEY PROCEEDING
AND JUST MANDATE CLOSURE OF
FACILITY- AND PUT CALIFORNIA OF-
RATEPAYERS AND RELIABILITY
ARREST. WE ASK FOR YOUR NOTEBOOK
OKAY THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE HERE
IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIX. IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE
ALL. LINE TWO OH FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY TWELVE FIVE OF THE
PREVIOUS OUR- MONIES ERNIE SHOP
PRESIDENT OF UTILITY WORKERS OF
AMERICA LOCAL FORTY THREE
TRAVESTY STORAGE AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE SB FORTY SIX THANK YOU A
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO
YOUR NAME- AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL FOR THOSE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION-
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. OPPOSITION
SPEAKERS. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ONLY APPLIED TO TWENTY
THREE OPEN. DAHLE REYES UTILITY
WORKERS LOCAL FIVE TWENTY TWO.
IN OPPOSITION. AND THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU OKAY WILL
COME TO THE COMMITTEE NOW-
CENTER HERTZBERG HE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THE CO AUTHOR OF
THIS AND IS THE- JOINT AUTHOR OF
OUR MEASUREMENT WAS A TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN IT WAS
SEVENTEEN WE DID THAT I CAN'T
RECALL LIKE HOW TO MOVE THE BILL
AS AMENDED. OKAY VERY WELL ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. I JUST WANNA MAKE.
MAKE BRIEF COMMENTS I APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR. THE
AUTHOR- WORKED IN- MADE OF
BEVERLY GOT A TENT TO TRY TO
WORK OUT OF THIS BILL I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS THE AMENDMENTS FOR ME
ADAMO FAR ENOUGH I MEAN THEY
SPEAK TO THE CLOSURE I THINK
THAT. IS ALREADY COVERED IN SB
THREE EIGHTY I THINK THIS BILL
IN THIS REGARD IS A NECESSARY
THIS IS A STRATEGIC RESOURCE FOR
THE FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT MANAGED MANAGE AS A
RESOURCE THAT SERVES MY DISTRICT
IN A VERY BIG WAY AND I KNOW
IT'S SERVICE- MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES DISTRICTS YEARS WELL
THE SAME WAY. AND SO- SAFETY IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO ME I KNOW
WE'VE- AVERRED THAT I KNOW THAT
THE- UTILITIES HAVE BEEN WORKING
TO TRY TO- MAKE THE SITE SAFE
FOR AND TO I MEAN WE I WAS HERE
AS A CHAIR WE'LL- WHEN WE WROTE
SB THIRTY. THREE EIGHTY WORKING
TOGETHER AND I UNDERSTAND LOTS
OF WORK HAS BEEN DONE INCLUDING
THE AUTHOR TODAY STUNNA. QUITE A
QUITE A BIT OF WORK AT ADVOCATE
FOR HIS DISTRICT AND I'M- I
RESPECT THAT VERY MUCH BUT I'M
FOR SOME- ALL AGES THE STAFF THE
BILL TODAY. SO IF THERE'S NO
FURTHER COMMENTS. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY CENTER HERTZBERG.
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX BY SENATOR
STERN DEPRESSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL. NAY OR I
AM GONNA STAY OFF NOBODY. WHAT
WAS A NOVELTY DOLLY. DOLLY NO
BAKER RIGHT BAKER I FORTUS.
BRADFORD DODD EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I GROW
HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG AYE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE I IN. MAN I
RUBIO. STERN STERN I. SEVEN
EIGHT ONE NO OKAY WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OF PERHAPS OF MEMBERS- WILL
MOVE ON NOW THAT BRINGS US TO
THE END OF OUR CALENDAR SO WILL
ADD ON ABSENT MEMBERS TO THE
VOTE BEGINNING WITH ITEM NUMBER
ONE CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND AS OR LET'S SAY
COULD WE ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
S. B. TEN TWENTY MOVE. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY CENTER HERTZBERG CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB TEN
TWENTY BY SENATOR DECLARED DO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL. I
WAS SO I. DALI. DALI KNOWN ACTOR
. BAKER I OR JUST. BRADFORD DOT
EGGMAN EGGMAN I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I GROW HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE REQUIRE I
MEANT WHEN I RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
STERN. BUT STERN AYE. NINE A
SOMEONE ELSE NINE IS ONE NO THAT
HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER CHU CAN
ENTERTAIN A MOTION SB TEN TWENTY
SIX BY WIECKOWSKI SO WE HAVE A
MOTION CLERK PLEASE CALL. THE
ROLL. SB TEN TWENTY SIX BY SEVEN
WORKOUTS SKI DOO PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL. I WAS
SO I. DALI. DALI IN THE L.
BECKER. BAKER I FORGES BRADFORD
DODD EGGMAN EGGMAN I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG HI
HERTZBERG I REQUIRE REQUIRE AYE
MIN. RUBIO RUBIO AYE STERN STERN
I. AS ONE OF HER OKAY THAT'S THE
BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OF THE RAPS
OF MEMBERS WILL GO TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE SB TEN SIXTY THREE
BY SENATOR SKINNER CONTAINER
INTERCHANGE MOTION WE HAVE A
MOTION BY CENTER HERTZBERG CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE VOTE SB TEN
SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR SKINNER
DEPRESSED APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL
I WAS SO. HI DOLLY. BAKER BAKER
HI FORGES BRADFORD DOT EGGMAN
EGGMAN I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
GROW. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE MAN WHEN I
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE STERN STERN I.
THAT HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT
HAS NINE VOTES FROM NOT MISTAKEN
PRESS- BUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM
NUMBER FOUR S. B. TEN SEVENTY
FIVE WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
HERTZBERG CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SB TEN SEVENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR SKINNER TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL
BY WESSEL. HI DOLLY. ALI HI
BAKER BAKER I FOR JUST. BRADFORD
DODD EGGMAN EGGMAN I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I GROW HERTZBERG HIGH
HERTZBERG BY MCGUIRE REQUIRE HI
MAN MAN I RUBIO. RUBIO AYE STERN
STERN I. THE BILL HAS TEN VOTES
IS ENOUGH TO GET OUT WILL CALL
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
WILL- CAN ENTERTAIN ON MOTION
FOR ITEM FIVE S. B. ELEVEN OH
NINE I GOT CYNICAL YET WE HAVE A
MOTION BY CENTER MEN CLERK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL S. B.
ELEVEN OH NINE BY SENATOR COVER
YOU DON'T DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL I WAS SO
HI DOLLY. DOLLY HI. BAKER FOR
JUST BRADFORD DODD EGGMAN EGGMAN
I GONZALEZ. WELL GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HIGH HERTZBERG I'D
REQUIRE MCGUIRE AYE MIN WHEN I
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE STERN. STERN I. THAT VOTE THAT BILL HAS IT BUT
IT'S ENOUGH TO GET OUT WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OF PREPS AND MEMBERS
CAN ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON ITEM
SIX US BEING LEVEL NINETEEN
ELEVEN NINETEEN WE HAVE A MOTION
BY CENTER- MAN WASN'T. I HAD
SEVERAL- CLICK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE ROLE SB ELEVEN NINETEEN
BY SEVEN EARLY ONE TWO PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WESSEL. HI WESSEL HI DOLLY.
TELLING THEM BAKER. WRECKER I
GORGEOUS BRADFORD. DOT AYE DODD
AYE EGGMAN EGGMAN I GONZALEZ AND
SALAS I GROW HERTZBERG HI
HERTZBERG AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE MAN. WHEN I RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
STERN STERN I. THE BILL HAS
TURNED TO THE TEN TO ONE TEN
YEARS ONE KNOW ENOUGH TO GET OUT
WILL HOLD A ROPE IN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS CAN ENTERTAIN A MOTION
ITEM SEVEN S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
TWO. WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
HERTZBERG CLERK PLEASE CALL. THE
ROLL SB THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO BY
SENATOR ALAN DEPRESSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL. HI
WESSEL HI DOLLY. BAKER BAKER I
FORGES BRADFORD DODD DODD AYE
EGGMAN EGGMAN I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I GROW HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE REQUIRE REQUIRE I
MEN. RUBIO STERN STERN I. THE
BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT
WILL HOLD THE ROLE PREFER ABSENT
MEMBERS CAN ENTERTAIN A MOTION
ON ITEM A IS B. LEVIN TWELVE. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR MEN
CLICK PLEASE CALL. THE ROLL. SB
ELEVEN TWELVE BY SENATOR RECORD
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WESSEL I WAS THE AYE GOLLY.
BAKER GORGEOUS I'M SORRY BROKER
. I APOLOGIZE YOU WANT TO VOTE
ON YOUR BILL. BAKER HI BURGESS
RADFORD DODD. DODD AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
GROW HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE MAN WHEN I
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE STERN. STERN I
. THAT BILL HAS TEN VOTES ENOUGH
TO GET OUT WILL HOLD THE ROPE OF
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- COULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ITEM NUMBER
NINE S. B. LUM FIFTY EIGHT. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR EGGMAN-
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL RIGHT
NUMBER NINE AT NINE THIRTY. WE
EMOTIONS. YEAH AUTHORITY ON CALL
WE'RE ALREADY ON ON CALL BILLS
OKAY- PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND ITEM NINE SB ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT MY GOODNESS AYE
SENATOR BAKER DEPRESSES AMEND IT
TO APPROPRIATIONS WE WERE JUST.
OR JUST KNOWN BRADFORD DODD DODD
AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROW.
RUBIO RUBIO AYE WE ONLY DID
CONSENT. ON THE LIST. HOW MANY
WHAT'S ACCOUNT TENDED TO FEATURE
TENDED TO OF THE BILL IS OUT
WILL HOLD THE ROLLOVER FRAPPES
AND MEMBERS CAN I ENTERTAIN A
MOTION LATER WE ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION ON ITEM TEN CAN WE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND ITEM TEN.
SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATOR STERN DEPRESSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS DOLLY
. DALI KNOWN BECKER BAKER I OR
JUST. BRADFORD DODD. DODD I.
ONLY THIRTEEN GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
I ONLY GROW. MAN MAN I RUBIO.
RUBIO. FIVE WHAT'S OF ACCOUNT
TEN TO ONE CHURCH AND ONE ON
ITEM TEN THAT BILL IS OUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE PERHAPS MEMBERS-
KANAI- COULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
MAKE AND ON ITEM TWELVE CAN I
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON ITEM
TWELVE. RIGHT TWELVE THIRTY WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR MEN ON
S. B. TWELVE OH EIGHT O'CLOCK
PLEASE CALL. THE ROLL. SB TWELVE
AWAIT BY SENATOR WESSEL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WESSEL AYE WESSEL
AYE DOLLY. BAKER RIGHT BAKER I
PORCHES FORGES I BRADFORD DOT
DODD AYE EGGMAN EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROW
HERTZBERG. MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE
MAN MAN I RUBIO. RUBIO AYE STERN. HI STERN I. CAN YOU JUST
DOUBLE CHECK STERN IS ON EVERY
BILL IS VOTED ON EVERY. DID YOU
VOTE ALREADY ON EVERY NO YOU
HAVEN'T VOTER AND EVERY. NO I
KNOW WHO I THINK YOU ARE THANK
YOU ARE YOU CAN. OKAY YES WE
HAVE WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA
COME BACK- AGAIN AROUND THE- YOU
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND ITEM
THIRTEEN. THE THREE THIRTY. OKAY. OKAY CONSENT CALENDAR FIRST SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO BY CENTER
WESSEL. BAKER BAKER I BORDERS
WERE JUST AYE BRADFORD. DODD
DODD AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
GROW. RUBIO RUBIO I. YEAH YOU
DID YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GREAT WORK OKAY WE'RE GONNA COME
BACK TO ITEM NUMBER ONE- SB TEN
TWENTY- CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. SB TEN TWENTY BY
SENATOR LAYERED TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. FORGES. GORGEOUS
NO. BRADFORD DODD. DODD I GROW.
TENDED TO CHECK TEN TENDED TO.
OKAY SO- WILL KEEP THE ROLE
PERHAPS MEMBERS ON ITEM TO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
S. B. TEN TWENTY SIX BY- CENTER
WORKOUTS SKI. SB TEN TWENTY SIX
BY SENATOR AKOWSKI DEPRESSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. OR
JUST. NO BORDERS NO BRADFORD DOT
DOT I GROWTH MEN. FOR BURFORD
NINETY TEACHER NINE NINE TO KEEP
THE ROLE OF A FRACTION MEMBERS
ITEM THREE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AS BE TEN SIX THREE BY
CENTER SKINNER SB TEN SIXTY
THREE BY SENATOR SKINNER
DEPRESSED APPROPRIATIONS DOLLY.
NUMBER THREE. TEN SECONDARY. TEN
SIXTY THREE. FORGES FOR JUST NOW
BRADFORD. DOT DODD I WROTE.
TWENTY ONE- THE END OF ONE WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OF PROFESSOR
MEMBERS NUMBER FOUR BY CENTER
SKINNER TEN SEVENTY FIVE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS SB TEN
SEVENTY FIVE BY SENATOR SKINNER
DEPARTS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS GORGEOUS GORGEOUS
HI BRADFORD. DODD GOD I GROWTH.
THE BILL HAS TWELVE VOTES WILL
HOLD THE ROPE ROLLABLE FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER FIVE
S. B. ELEVEN OH NINE BY SENATOR
KELLY- PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS S. B. ELEVEN OH NINE BY
SENATOR CORYADULT DEPRESSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
BECKER GORGEOUS BRADFORD DOT GOD
I GONZALEZ. GROW. NINE ZERO
THREE NINE ZERO WE'LL LOOK AT
THE ROLE OF A FRACTION MEMBERS
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB ELEVEN
NINETEEN BY CENTER LAMONT PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS SB
ELEVEN NINETEEN BY SENATOR LIMON
DEPRESSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. FOR JUST.
BRADFORD GROWTH. OKAY WE WILL
KEEP THAT BILL OF ON CALL OF
NUMBERS THAT BILLS HAS ENOUGH TO
GET UP WILL KEEP OF THE RELEVANT
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN- S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO BY CENTER
ELLEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SB THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO
BY SENATOR ALAN. THE PRESIDENT
APPROPRIATIONS DOLLY. GORGEOUS
BRADFORD. GROW MAN RUBIO. BY
OKAY THAT THE BILL HAS EIGHT
VOTES WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- NUMBER EIGHT
HI SPEED ELEVEN TWELVE I CENTER
BECKER SB ELEVEN TWELVE AYE
SENATOR BAKER DEPRESSED
APPROPRIATIONS DOLLY. DOLLY NO
GORGEOUS. BRADFORD GROW. HI
TWENTY ONE- THE BILL'S TURN ONE
WILL KEEP THE ROLE PERHAPS A
MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER NINE SB 150%
OR BAKER PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR RECORD DEPRESSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. BRADFORD
GROVE. OKAY ITEM NUMBER TEN- SB
THIRTY SEVEN SIX BY CENTER STERN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATOR STERN DEPRESSES AMEND IT
TO APPROPRIATIONS GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD ROVE MINIBUSES AT BILL
HAVE. TEN TO ONE TEN TO ONE
OKAY- ITEM ELEVEN BY CENTER
STERN SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX UP
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX BY
SENATOR STERN DEPRESSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WESSEL FOR JUST. BRADFORD DODD
DODD I ROW. RUBIO. WHAT'S SPOKEN
ON THE BILL EIGHT TO ONE. A TO
WIN THE BILL IS OUT WILL HOLD
THE ROLE PERHAPS OF MEMBERS ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE- S. B. TWELVE
LABOR CENTER WEST SO PLEASE CALL
TO MEMBERS. SB TROUBLE WAIT BY
SENATOR WAS SO DEPRESSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. DOLLY
BRADFORD. GROVE HERTZBERG.
WHAT'S OF ACCOUNT. TWENTY ZERO
TEN ZERO CALL THE ROLL
CONTRAPTION MEMBERS ITEM TWELVE
WHAT'S VOTE COUNT AN AN TWELVE.
THAT WAS A- WHAT YEAR OF
O'CONNOR MADE HIM THIRTEEN TH.
YES FROM THEM. TWELVE ZERO NINE
THIRTEEN. OKAY- WE ALREADY DID
THAT. YEAH YEAH YOU'RE GOOD
EVERYBODY- SUSAN YOU'RE GOOD
OKAY SO WHAT WILL- NOW HERE WE
COME TO THE END. OF OUR CALENDAR
. I WNT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION TODAY AGAIN
IF YOU- WORD- SOMEHOW NOT ABLE
TO REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT OF
OPPOSITION A BILL PLEASE CONTACT
OUR COMMITTEE AND ADD ON- FOR
THOSE. I JUST WANNA THANK
EVERYBODY FOR THEIR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION HAS BEEN A CRAZY DAY
AND WE HAD A QUITE A BIG AGENDA
LOTS OF TESTIMONY. BUT WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE PUBLIC'S
PARTICIPATION AGAIN IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE THAT TESTIFIED TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS ARE READY TO THE
SENATE ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS%
AND SUGGESTIONS REPORT JUST ONE
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY. AND THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS WE'RE
ACTUALLY GONNA- WE'RE GONNA
CLOSE ROLE NOW AND WILL- THE ALL
THE BILLS- THAT WERE ON
COMMITTEE TODAY PASSED. NINE
FAILED. AND SO FOR THOSE THAT
WERE- DEPART THIS WE WANT TO
THANK YOU. AND NOW THE
COMMITTEES OFFICIALLY ADJOURNED
GOOD NIGHT EVERYONE.